Die Ankündigung der Telekom, dann doch mal hier die Tarife ein bisschen anzupassen in der Zukunft.
Naja, also es gibt da schon Probleme. Was mich zumindest als, was mir als allererstes aufgestoßen ist, dass alle Leute das Ding Drossel nennen. Das ist keine Drossel, sondern sie machen den Anschluss einfach nur kaputt. Das ist einfach kaputt. Funktional kaputt.
Ja, die neue Hymne.
So sieht es aus. Jetzt wissen wir zumindest, es ist schon mal klar, wie man das alles akustisch untermalen kann, wenn dann demnächst die Horten vor die Telekom-zentralen Deutschlands ziehen, mit dem Ghetto-Blast-Sound am Arm.
Machen wir eine Single-Auskopplung?
Ja, ja. Also, ich habe David schon Bescheid gesagt. Und wenn alles klappt, dann gibt es noch die Extended Maxi-Version irgendwie auf Soundcloud, während wir hier senden. Also, es ist für alles gesorgt. Da fällt mir auch wieder mein altes Kaputt-T-Shirt ein.
Wie Extended ist die denn? Kann man die runterladen, bevor die Drossel anspringt? Die Funktionalkaputt-Drossel?
Die Drossel ist ja nicht kaputt. Leider.
Kennt das überhaupt irgendjemand noch?
Nee, nie gesehen.
Ich weiß natürlich jetzt kein Mensch, worauf wir schauen. Ich werde das mal hier gleich mal irgendwie ins Netz tragen. Aber das erste Mal, dass ich Ärger hatte mit der Telekom, bzw. gleich der ganze CTC, war, als wir irgendwie diese T-Shirts gemacht haben. Das war sozusagen die Initialzündung seinerzeit für Interhemd. Und da hat die Telekom ihre Privatisierung so gefeiert. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch, das war diese Werbe-Maßnahme mit so tanzenden Buchstaben, wie sie das nannte, wo dann immer so Deutschland, und dann das T als Telekom-T, und die Buchstaben halt so gegeneinander versetzt und toll. Und ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was da Zukunft, also komische Worte.
Wir haben dann halt so diese Serie von T-Shirts rausgebracht mit Toia.
Was war das andere nochmal gleich? Das ist schon so lange her. Toia, Nulltarif war auch sehr schön, Betrug und kaputt. Fanden sie natürlich total scheiße, weil gerade so Betrug und so, und dann gleich hier mit Unterlassungserklärung und Pipapo und so. Aber den Spaß war es auf jeden Fall so.
Du mein Sound ist gefühlt auch so ein bisschen irgendwie, ist nicht so richtig crisp, ist so ein bisschen kratzig. Bei dir auch?
Kratzig?
Nee, irgendwie so nicht klar.
Vielleicht einfach zu leise?
Ne, ich will leiser, wenn überhaupt, dann will ich leiser.
Leiser.
Leiser Minnelli.
Willst du vielleicht selber lauter sein und uns nur leiser hören?
Das reduziert zwar nicht dieses unkrispe Wahrnehmungsphänomen, aber es schnarzt ein wenig. Es schnarzt, das ist noch nicht so ganz sauber. Hat irgendjemand das auch?
Wollen wir uns nicht mal einen Profi-Produzenten suchen, diese Hobbykiste hier in der Metaebene, diesen komischen Prittler?
Es ist so wie ein bisschen Noise oben.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, dass ich hier Reaper gefahren habe und das sind sozusagen noch die Echo-Wellen davon. Da reden wir noch drüber.
Na gut, also ich ertrags einfach, das du.
Ich kann ja auf jeden Fall gerade mal keine...
Akute Verarztung.
Genau, ich wüsste jetzt gerade nicht, was ich da noch tun sollte.
Start doch noch ein bisschen Mischpult neu.
Das werde ich jetzt bestimmt nicht machen. Hier startet sich sowieso viel zu viel von alleine neu. Ich muss mal kurz hier diesen Kaputt-Link, das ist ja jetzt nicht so geil, dass das für die Nachwelt unbedingt erhalten bleiben muss, aber der Vollständigkeit halber eher kaputt für die Bewohner des Chats.
Da haben wir die auch befriedigt.
Jaja, das ist ja überhaupt das Wichtigste, dass die Bewohner befriedigt sind. Ja, auch die Bewohner unserer Stadt Berlin werden befriedigt sein.
Berlin! Weil der Frühling endlich Einzug erhalten hat.
Ach so, wir müssen ja erst mal, Entschuldigung. Aber ja, stimmt, Berlin kann sowieso aufjauchzen. Du hast noch gar nichts gesagt. Du hältst dich dem Zentrum. Also wir sind heute, Entschuldigung, ich bin ein bisschen neben der Tasse, fast vollständig, Denis ist nicht da, aber Huckel ist da, Clemens ist da, Roddy ist da, ich bin da. Und außerdem ist Niels da. Den haben wir gleich mal ambulant dazu berufen, um unsere WW-Chinnen und Unfähigkeiten hier auszubessern.
Ja, hallo.
Hallo Niels.
Guten Tag.
Du bist ja auch schon ganz fleißig am Podcasten eigentlich, ne?
Ja, ich mach da so einen Retro-Spiele-Podcast und so eine kleine Solonummer.
Du darfst ruhig die Namen sagen.
Ja, also zum einen beim Retro-Zirkel mit Mapp und Lucy. Mapp von den Fanboys. Lucy macht sonst keine Podcasts. Genau, Lucy vom Retro-Zirkel oder von Kleiner 3. Über Retro-Spiele, jeder alle zwei Wochen ein altes Spiel. Und wir reden halt drüber und sagen vorher an, worum es geht. Damit die Leute mitspielen können und wissen, worüber wir reden. Und gegebenenfalls sogar vorhin in den Kommentaren, was zu dem Spiel sagen.
Mitspielen können.
Naja, damit sie halt vorher selber spielen können. Also wir sagen eine Woche vorher Bescheid, welches Spiel. Zwei Wochen. Zwei Wochen. Also in unserer Folge sagen wir an, das werden wir beim nächsten Mal besprechen.
Und dann rennen sie alle irgendwie in den Keller?
Dann können sie alle in den Keller rennen, auf Ebay kaufen oder den nächsten Flohmarkt aufsuchen. Oder den alten C64 ausgraben oder so.
Sag mal fünf der Themen, die ihr schon gehabt habt.
Fünf der Themen. Summer & Winter Games für den C64 war eins der aktuellen.
Der Joystick-Mörder.
Sonic CD, Snatcher, Mario World und Zelda 1 werden jetzt mal so.
Ich bin ja so dermaßen überhaupt nicht eure Zielgruppe. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich weiß. Ich weiß.
Und das wird mir dann wieder klar. Ich hör dann ab und zu mal rein und denk mir immer nur so, Fieeeep. Ja, jetzt weiß ich, wie es den Leuten bei meinen Podcasts geht.
Den Leuten.
Ja, und dann hab ich noch so einen Blog unter niels.kobschätzki.net, wo ich auch ab und zu podcaste, wo es dann um alles Mögliche geht. Ich versuche Japan-Bezug, aber es klappt nicht immer. Und dann kommt auch irgendetwas zu Pen-and-Paper-Rollen-Spielen oder zu Updatnet drin vor.
Genau, Updatnet. Das ist definitiv ein Thema, das hier auch noch.
Da bist du hier richtig, genau.
Genau, da bist du hier richtig. Wer mich für ein Apologeten dieses Netzwerks hält, hat Niels noch nicht länger zugehört. Du bist ja mittlerweile schon komplett konvertiert, ne?
Jaja, ich habe meinen Twitter-Account jetzt auf Privat gestellt, damit niemand Neues mir folgt, weil ich der Enix poste. Ansonsten halt nur alles auf Updatnet. Außer Retro-Zirkel-Account natürlich, aber der ist auf Twitter und Updatnet.
Aha, jetzt kommt's raus.
Wir haben ja sogar eine Facebook-Seite.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, man hat ja auch seinen Podcast-Feed im Internet. Also ich meine, Twitter ist ja im Prinzip mittlerweile nichts anderes als so ein glorified RSS-Rieder. Ja, also jeder drückt da irgendwie seine News rein. Ich mach das auch. Und...
Als RSS-Rieder ist er aber kaputt, wie manche Leute sagen würden.
Funktional kaputt.
Register your trademark online.
Die Domänen müssen noch zu haben sein.
Funktional kaputt?
Nicht mehr lange.
Was? Zehn Sekunden Vorsprung vor dem Stream.
Ich sag dir, ich hab schon ein paar Domainnamen hier bei MobileMax getropft und als ich dann doch mal dachte, ach jetzt registriere ich mich immer, war es schon weg.
Free, Free.
So kann es gehen. Live-Hörer.
Beide mit und ohne Bindestrich. Free, Free. Von wegen wir hätten Live-Hörer.
Heißt Free jetzt schon reserviert?
Status Free.
Ja, Free heißt?
Frei, verfügbar.
Jetzt kann noch jemand klicken.
Funktional mit Bindestrich zwischen Funktional kaputt und Funktional kaputt zusammengeschrieben.
Entscheide dich jetzt.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall die richtige Demoseite, um da mal so ein bisschen die Welle zu machen.
Genau, Chet, mach dir mal.
Ja, ich meine jetzt, wo das mit den Piraten eh durch ist und so, da können die Nerds mal wieder so ein einigendes Thema. Nicht immer diesen langweiligen Datenschutz und Freiheitsdebatten, sondern jetzt einfach hier, wir wollen einfach mehr Netz, mehr Porn, mehr alles direkt.
Ungefiltert.
Genau.
Auf den Tisch. Das dauert ja auch fünf Minuten, bis der Domain-Robot das abgegrast hat.
Denik ist auch echt schnarchig. Zwischen denk ich jetzt schon 20.NET-Domains registriert.
Das weiß ich gar nicht so richtig, womit wir anfangen, aber ich glaube, eine Sache müssen wir dann doch vorne anstellen. Nämlich? Es ist soweit. Es gibt einen Termin für den Apple Store Berlin. Und?
Ich glaube es erst, wenn es passiert.
Ich auch. Aber es hat sich in der letzten Woche verdichtet und ich habe gleich aus zwei Richtungen Bestätigungen bekommen für den Termin. Und von daher gehe ich mal davon aus, dass es ist. Und zwar handelt es sich um den 3. Mai, welches ist ein Freitag.
Freitag ist sie nie da.
Ah, funktionierkaputt.de ist jetzt registriert. Connected.
In Berlin, da kriegt man immer irgendwelche Fertigstellungstermine und Eröffnungstermine genannt.
Es ist jetzt nicht nur so ein Plan, sondern es ist so, Leute haben ihre Reise gebucht, Mitarbeiter dürfen sich nichts anderes aussuchen für Urlaub, also müssen sie sich was anderes aussuchen für Urlaub und bla. Und Mitteilungen gehen raus und so. Allerdings ist der Zustand auf der Baustelle noch eher fragwürdig. Und ich bin mir da noch nicht so hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich deute das mal so als 99% Apple Store wird keine Glastreppe haben.
Ohhhh Kriegen sie nicht mehr hin in den zwei Wochen, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht wollten sie auch nie eine.
Das würde ich jetzt auch behaupten an der Stelle.
Also es war jetzt auch lange Zeit so ein bisschen der Indikator, dass man immer so geglaubt hat, naja, da geht ja nichts voran. Ist ja noch nicht mal eine scheiß Glastreppe da. Aber es kommt wohl auch wahrscheinlich keine. Na ja, und innen ist alles noch so ein bisschen Halligalli. Heute haben sie die schwarzen Hüllen fallen lassen. Also das Ding wurde heute schon entpackt sozusagen.
Nackig gemacht.
Nackig gemacht. Apple Store macht dich nackig. Und ja, es geht voran. Und wir können da demnächst unsere teuren Elite-Geräte dahintragen und sagen, hier machen wir heile.
Ja, keine Glastreppe, weil sie wirklich nur einen Raum haben? Oder?
Nee, weil das ja Haus Wien, Kino, lalala, da ist schon eine Treppe drin und die kannst du jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres rausreißen.
Und noch eine einbauen ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen bekloppt, oder?
Ich kann dir das nicht beantworten, weil dazu kenne ich jetzt das zu wenig. Aber ich vermute, das hat einfach was damit zu tun, dass das denkmalgeschützte Struktur ist und dass da sich das nicht so ohne weiteres oder auch gar nicht.
Ja, aber da war doch mal eine Rolltreppe drin.
Ich weiß. Ich kann dir das nicht beantworten.
Wir werden sehen.
Vielleicht zaubern sie auch noch eine her. Jetzt gibt es auf jeden Fall keine.
Eine gläserne Rolltreppe.
Also wenn sie das noch...
Glastreppe haben wir nicht, kommt auch nicht wieder rein.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt in zwei Wochen. Das heißt, wir haben die nächste Sendung vielleicht am 1. Mai, wenn wir da Zeit haben. Und dann, am 3. Mai, ist es schon so weit und dann muss die gepflegte Langeweile aufkommen. Wie live, wie das Team festgenommen wird, oder was?
Naja, 1. Mai dann so um die Uhrzeit, da wird es ja dann langsam...
Achso, und du meinst jetzt zur Sendung? Ja, ne, ja... Keine Ahnung. Ach, 1.
Ich grüße übrigens einen unserer Hörer in Bitburg. Wir haben mindestens einen, der in einem Wäldchen wohnt. Wollte ich nur mal so zwischendurch sagen. Der hat die Domentsregistration. In einem Wäldchen. Ne, Wäldchen.
Gibt es noch keine...
Gibt keine Wäldchen in Bitburg. Da gibt es noch Wäldchen.
Keine Rumlaute bei Denis vielleicht? Doch, da sind wir schon so weit.
So, jetzt sind wir also alle ganz ekstatisch vor...
Ich weiß nicht, was machen wir denn jetzt mit diesem scheiß Apple Store?
Ignorieren.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, ignorieren.
Ja, klar, ignorieren. Aber die Frage ist, aktiv ignorieren vor Ort? Also, ja.
Also... Wenn die da wirklich diese Jubel-Nummer machen, dann sollte man da schon hingehen und die Jungs ausdämpfen, finde ich schon.
Wann ist so eine Eröffnung, üblicherweise?
Also, die allermeisten Eröffnungen, an die ich mich jetzt so erinnere, waren immer an einem Samstag. Von daher bin ich schon ein bisschen überrascht, dass sie jetzt einen Freitagstermin genommen haben. Aber vielleicht ist es einfach aus Rücksicht auf meinen Podcast-Workshop, der ist nämlich am vierten.
Oder sie haben es verwechselt, dass die Woche in Deutschland am Montag anfängt, nicht am Sonntag.
Ich glaube, du musst noch ein bisschen kräftiger an den Fingern saugen.
Also, ein Teller wie für das Argument jetzt irgendwie durchgehen. Also keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht. Sie werden schon irgendwelche Gründe haben, die kenne ich aber nicht, du weißt es nicht.
Die kommen alle zu deinem Meeting.
Ist da jetzt hektisches Schrauben angesagt und ab jetzt arbeiten sie auch Tag und Nacht an der Baustelle. Also ist jetzt sozusagen Nachtschicht eingeführt worden. Die letzten zwei Wochen müssen sie aus diesem staubigen Loch, was es ist, einen schönen shiny, shiny, shiny Ort machen. Vor zwei Wochen sei angeblich Tim Cook auch noch mal vor Ort gewesen.
Wollen wir die tollen?
Ein zweites Mal.
Können wir mal beim Ordnungsamt anrufen, damit wir zeigen, was ordentliche deutsche Arbeitsschutzbehörden können. Nee, wollen wir nicht.
Ich glaube, Berlin hat jetzt genug gewartet. Es ist, glaube ich, auch wichtig für diese Stadt, ein bisschen Hoffnung den Bürgern zurückzugeben, dass auch mal was eröffnet.
Und nicht nur zugemacht wird wie der Hauptbahnhof.
Sogar der Frühling hat sich ja Zeit gelassen.
Kommt mit berlinischer Verspätung.
Jetzt kommt es allerdings Schlag auf Schlag. Erst Frühling, dann Apple Store. Da kann es jetzt einfach bis zum Flughafen soweit nicht mehr sein.
Die Huckel neulich, das warst du, die so schön gesagt hat, der große blaue Raum mit dem offenen Fusionsreaktor ist jetzt wieder geöffnet.
Mit der offenen Kernfusion, ja. Genau.
Ist jetzt wieder geöffnet.
Wir sitzen hier auch schon in Unterhose, weil es einfach kaum auszuhalten ist vor Hitze, Schwallungen. Gut, hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Mal im Ernst, mit welcher Uhrzeit muss man da so rechnen, wenn da der Store aufmacht?
Du willst doch nicht etwa arbeiten. An dem Tag, an dem der Apple Store Berlin eröffnet, willst du doch nicht etwa arbeiten.
Ne, wollen nicht, aber muss wahrscheinlich.
Wie du weißt, dass da keine Glastreppe drin gibt, aber du weißt nicht, wann das passiert.
Also wann da keine Glastreppe drin ist.
Ich weiß jetzt, 3. Mai, das ist schon mal sehr viel akkurater als alle anderen Angaben, die wir hier bisher so gemacht haben. Ich glaube, vor einem Jahr hatten wir schon mal den Mai ausgerufen. Ach nee, den Juni, genau, als Ankündigung. Aber das war halt auch tatsächlich der erwartete Termin. Nur, dass sich das eben aus zahlreichen Gründen, die ich jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht aufzählen kann, verschoben hat. Also Statik und keine Ahnung, was da alles noch mit reinkam. Und dann haben Dinge nicht gepasst und mussten nochmal neu gemacht werden.
Brandschutzanlage. Ja, und Nachbar, tralala und so.
Aber ich meine, Apple hat da auch einfach die stoische Ruhr und die finanzielle Stamina, um das irgendwie auch einfach durchzuziehen.
Im Gegensatz zum Land Berlin.
Ich meine, mal ehrlich, ein Laden, ein Laden, der zwei Jahre hergerichtet wird, das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Zwei Jahre bauen die an diesem Scheiß.
Sind die schon länger?
Also, sie haben Januar letzten Jahres ging das so richtig fett los, aber sie haben auch schon vorher gearbeitet, also es sind ungefähr zwei Jahre. Aber sie dachten mal, sie könnten das so im halben Jahr oder ein bisschen mehr, sechs, sieben, acht Monate stemmen.
Das dauert.
Ja, alles Mögliche. Tralala, keine Ahnung. Ich meine, es ist halt auch Denkmalschutz wahrscheinlich. Es ist halt auch altes Kino, altes Gemäuer, hat schon ein paar Kriege erlebt, so was weiß ich, was sie da alles gefunden haben.
Deswegen, Brandschutz. Gerade bei den alten Gemäuern.
Fun fact, in Deutschland geht ein bis zwei Mal im Jahr ein Blindgänger von alleine hoch. Doch, wenn du danach googlest, findest du auch, dass zum Beispiel auf so einem Radweg irgendwie plötzlich so unvermittelt so ein Blindgänger, ohne dass irgendwas ringsrum passiert ist, aber geht dann einfach hoch. Oder es gibt auch so Fotos von Baustellen an der Autobahn und so, wo dann plötzlich der Bagger...
Das ist echt krass auch. Und dann gibt es noch so Leute in München, die denken, so ein Blindgänger, den können wir doch einfach spät.
Ja genau, da gibt es dieses tolle Video, wo sie das in Schwabing irgendwie mal hochgehen lassen, mit so einer Wuff.
Und irgendwie fünf Häuser mitgenommen haben oder so.
Ja, wer weiß, was sie da im Apple Store noch rausgebuddelt haben.
Es gibt ja Leute, die sind total schmerzbefreit. Ich hab das mal in Paris am Flughafen Charlie Gorman erlebt. Da steh ich rum an so einem Schalter von so einer Airline und plötzlich großet Grumore und wir werden so ein bisschen zur Seite geschoben. Jemand kommt hin, sperrt ein Absperrband. Dann fährt so ein kleiner Roboter um die Ecke. Ja, so ein kleiner Mini-Panzer mit so einem Greifer vorne dran. Fummelt dann in so einer Tasche rum, fährt damit um die Ecke, macht das einmal, brumm. Danach kommen ein paar Typen mit Fegern und dem Absperrband wieder aufgehoben. Dann durften wir weiter hin und die haben das einfach an Ort und Stelle, eine Schminktasche von irgendeiner Frau gesprengt. Die sind da irgendwie unbeaufsichtigt.
Ja, das ist in Israel glaube ich auch tagtäglich.
Ja, aber normalerweise hätte ich jetzt erwartet, dass sie einfach mal den Scheiß-Flughafen oder Terminal räumen. Sie haben jetzt so ein bisschen mit dem Absperrband um die Ecke geschoben und dann, pff, fand ich das schön.
Wahrscheinlich wussten sie, dass es keine Bombe ist und haben das mal so zu Lernzwecken. Lässt du dein Zeug rumstehen, sprengen wir es halt.
So, kommen wir zu dem eigentlichen Punkt. 3. Mai heißt ja auch, aber es könnte noch einen anderen Grund geben, warum 3. Mai?
Ja, am 1. Mai geht ja nicht.
Wann? Neues iPhone.
Hat Apple das letzte Mal ein neues Produkt vorgestellt?
1874 gefühlt.
Ja, kurz nach dem Sezessionskrieg.
Ja, ich meine, es ist einfach in diesem Jahr noch nicht ein Produkt vorgestellt worden.
Im letzten Jahr? War im letzten Jahr eins?
Ja, das letzte war das iPad.
Und das iPad Mini?
Das iPad Mini. Gab es noch ein Speedbum von irgendwas? Gab es noch irgendwie so ein... irgendwie...
Hatten die nicht irgendwie Retina MacBook 13 Zoll? Wann kam das? Das war doch auch...
Oh wow, ja, that's exciting.
Mit dabei irgendwie, ich glaube, bei der iPad Vorstellung.
Genau, irgendwie so.
Aber das ist halt einfach ein halbes Jahr her.
Entschuldigung. So, naja, ich meine, vielleicht ist der 3. Mai ja nicht der Termin, an dem der Store fertig ist, sondern an dem der Store fertig sein muss.
Das wäre auch sehr berlinisch.
Tja, nun mal so in den Raum.
Oder vielleicht haben sie sich einfach angemeiert und 3. Mai sitzt jetzt gerade jemand in Cupertino, der zuhört, sagt, ha ha ha ha, aber die Brittler vom Arsch.
Aber Produkt starten auf den Freitag?
Also, gab es das eigentlich ohne Steve, weiß man jetzt eh nicht mehr, was Apple eigentlich macht.
Gab es alles schon mal.
Vielleicht sollte es ursprünglich der 5. März werden. Und Deutschland konnte sich gerade noch so rausreden.
Oder sie haben wieder mal eine Datum umgedreht. Ich habe einen Freund, der benutzt diese dämliche Trippit. Kennt ihr das? Sagt euch Trippit was? Das ist auch so ein toller Cloud-Dienst. Da kannst du deine ganzen Mails, die du bei irgendwelchen Reisen von deiner Airline kriegst, mit dem, was du buchst, kriegst du ja immer so eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail. Oder von deinem Hotel. Und die schickst du einfach hin. Und diese Trippit ist einfach ein Monster-Perl-Script, was von allen Airlines und Hotels diese Mails apparst und deine Daten da zusammen und dir so schöne Treble-Itineräre da mit zusammenbastelt. Was du natürlich wieder sharen kannst mit Facebook, Kreti, Pleti und was, weiß ich, wer noch alles nicht wissen will. Und wie gesagt, ein Freund von mir, der benutzt das, auch sehr rege, und der ist aber Amerikaner. Und der hat jetzt dummerweise mal eine Reise nach Europa gebucht und hat dementsprechend auch Bestätigungen von ihm gekriegt. Die hat er da reingeschmissen. Und dadurch, dass sie mal wieder irgendwie 11. Mai mit 5. November wechselt haben, hatte er jetzt also einen Trip für ein halbes Jahr. Irgendwie ist jetzt eine gebucht in Dublin. Weil sie wie gesagt, 11.5, 5.11. Tja, nur gerade als Erklärung zu deinem Thema, was du gerade sagtest, mit dem 3. Mai und so.
Ja, die Amerikaner und ihre Datumsformate, Maßeinheiten, überhaupt sonst alles, das ist alles ganz furchtbar.
Ja, wie die es überhaupt auf dem Mond geschafft haben.
Es hat sie schon mal eine Maßsonde gekostet.
Der 5.3. wäre übrigens ein Dienstag gewesen im März, ja.
Da wird ja einiges klar.
Magst du vielleicht mit deinem Informanten nochmal Rücksprache halten?
Der ist eigentlich schon geöffnet.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall, da geht was. Und wir erwarten kreative Vorschläge unserer Hörer in den Kommentaren.
In den Kommentaren schreibt jemand ISO 8601. Leute, ich rede über Amerikaner. ISO ist eine Unterorganisation der UNO. Was die Amerikaner von dieser UNO halten, muss ich euch doch jetzt nicht erzählen. Also erzählt mir doch nicht, dass sich Amerikaner an ISO 8601 halten sollen. Es gibt keine Standards, außer wir setzen sie, hat die IBM früher mal gesagt.
Ich finde auch dieses Zitat, I love standards, there are so many to choose from.
So, jetzt haben wir also ein Gerücht auf dem Tisch.
Jetzt haben wir ein Gerücht auf dem Tisch, und dann können wir das mit dem Store vielleicht auch mal wieder beiseitelegen. Ich weiß nicht, hier zu dem schon im Vorspann angesprochenen Telekom-Drossel-Tralala, gibt es da eigentlich noch irgendwas nachzutragen? Hat sich da irgendwas getan? Hat sich irgendjemand geäußert?
Oder irgendjemand von irgendwas in Kenntnis gesetzt?
Nö, sie haben eigentlich nur noch neue Mobilfunk-Tarife jetzt doch heute verlauten lassen, die irgendwie weniger geworden sind von den Datenmengen. Das war heute. Ich habe es heute noch angeguckt, das ist ein toller Ding. War bei Heise sogar drauf, dass die Telekom irgendwie die Tarife ändert. Bei L gibt es jetzt nur 750 Megabyte oder so.
Es sieht trotzdem noch näher.
Alles muss weniger werden.
Ja, wo kommt man denn dahin? Die Telekom ist halt ein Staatsunternehmen zum Teil und muss von daher auch die Direktive unserer Regierung umsetzen. Und wenn man sich unsere Regierung so anschaut, dann kann das nur der Rückbau der Internettechnologie bis zum 2020 bedeuten, um wieder einfach dem eingetretenen Pfaden den Weg zu ebnen. Wie sagst du, Telekom gehört nicht dem Staat?
Jetzt haben die sich schon so hinkonstruiert, dass da gar nicht erst irgendjemand in die Ruchbarkeit kommt, der Telekom eine Anweisung hätte geben zu können.
Wer hat sich das konstruiert?
Die Leute, die so dachten, dass mit der Privatisierung von Staatsunternehmen, von wichtigen Infrastrukturunternehmen, wäre eine tolle Sache.
Ich verstehe dich jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Irgendjemand ist hier mal auf die tolle Idee gekommen, aus dem ehemaligen Staatsunternehmen Deutsche Bundespost, mit mannigfaltigen juristischen Tricks ein mehr oder weniger privates Unternehmen zu machen. Ja, dem Staat gehören noch irgendwie eine Handvoll Aktien an diesem Laden, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass jeder Aktionär einfach irgendwie mitreden kann oder da Ansagen macht. Das ist auch extra so gewollt, weil das Ding soll Geld machen. Vielleicht auch für die Aktionäre, aber was sie nicht verstanden haben, ist, dass es eine Infrastrukturaufgabe hat. Oder das haben sie verstanden oder das war ihnen egal. Ebenso wie bei der Bahn, bei Wasserunternehmen, bei Strom und Trallada hatten wir hier schon ein paar Mal. Das ist nicht die Aufgabe der Politik, da Vorgaben zu machen. So ist das Konstrukt nicht aufgesetzt. Die Politik kann einfach sagen, hallo, wir sind hier Aktionäre bei dir. Ich als Aktionär fordere mehr Shareholder-Value. Und dann sagt der Telekom-Chef, wer auch immer das jetzt gerade ist, machen wir, bauen wir eine kleine Drossel ein, kaufen die Leute mehr Zeugs und fertig. Achso, dazu gab es noch einen kleinen Kommentarabschlag, Abtausch in ab.net oder so, wo jemand jetzt gerade noch mal die alte AGB entdeckt hat, oder die jetzt gültige AGB, wo drin steht, dass sie dir deinen VDSL nur auf 6 Megabit runterdrehen. Und daraufhin habe ich dann auch gleich zurückgeschrieben, ja, das kann so nicht bleiben, weil 6 Megabit würde dich nur ärgern als Kunde, aber dich nicht dazu anhalten, nachzukaufen. Deswegen drosseln sie dich auf 384, weil das ärgert dich so sehr, weil das nämlich nicht gebrauchen kannst, weil das nämlich funktionale kaputt ist. Hatt ich das schonmal erwähnt? Dann, dass du dir jetzt sozusagen den Upgrade kaufst. Ob nur permanent oder einmal, dass du dir die Bits nachkaufst. Aber wenn sie dich nur auf 6 Megabit runterdrosseln, macht das keiner. Das heißt, sie haben in beiden Fällen einen ärgerlichen Kunden am Arsch. Nur im einen Fall kriegen sie nochmal Geld, und im anderen nicht. Deswegen ist diese 6 Megabit-Drossel für die Tatsache, dass Telekom nicht praktikabel ist. Weil nur den Kunden ärgert, ihnen aber nichts bringt.
Also ich habe das auch in meinem Vertrag hier. Und wenn hier gedrosselt wird, dann gibt es echt auch für Oma. Es gibt da auch noch so komische andere Verträge, von denen ich noch nie was gehört habe.
Pass auf, ich bin heute so richtig. Sorry, ich habe heute schlechte Laune. Der alte Vertrag sieht ja kein Upsale vor. Oder deine alten AGBs oder wie auch immer, die sind ja Bestandteil des Vertrages, sieht ja nur vor, dass du ab einem Volumen von X gedrosselt wirst auf Y. Und genau für diese Dinger werden sie keinen Upsale anbieten. Und werden dich halt einfach drosseln. Werden dir dann sagen, ja Herr Pritzloff, wenn sie mehr Bits kaufen wollen, dann müssen sie in einen unserer neuen Verträge wechseln.
Wollen wir mal wetten?
Das kommt so.
Hält ja keiner dagegen, mit wem willst du wetten?
Also ich mache mir heute mal den Max, und bin jetzt mal so richtig voll der Pessimist. Wie gesagt, genau diese Nummer werden sie fahren. Und die ist völlig legal und völlig klasse. Und genau so werden sie sich machen. Das heißt, die werden nur den Neukunden, die ihren neuen Scheißvertrag unterschreiben, den werden sie in Abseil anbieten. Den alten werden sie sagen, das geht leider aus technischen Gründen nicht. Technische Gründe oder wegen... Vertragstechnischen Gründen. Aus vertragstechnischen Gründen. Sehr klasse, wenn ihr euch mal so anhört. Es gibt so ein paar von diesen Stopwords, die inzwischen gebraucht werden in der Öffentlichkeit, wenn man irgendwelchen Leuten klarmachen will, dass man was nicht will. Geht aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen nicht, aus vertragstechnischen Gründen nicht, aus rechtlichen Gründen nicht. Und wenn sonst irgendwelche dämlichen Maßnahmen immer zu rechtfertigen sind, wenn der Staat das macht, ist das wegen des Kampfes gegen den Terror. Und wenn Privatfirmen das machen, ist das so wegen Socks. Das ist der Sabans-Oxley-Act. Das ist ein US-Amerikaner, das ist ein US-Amerikanisches Gesetz, was dort den dortigen Firmen oder an der dortigen Börse gelisteten Firmen bestimmte Spielregeln aufoktuiert. Und das führen selbst deutsche Unternehmen, weil sie vielleicht auch eine Aktie an der New Yorker Börse handeln, dazu, dass sie hier in Deutschland dieses amerikanische Gesetz zu befolgen, gedenken oder das versuchen, durchzuführen. Und das ist immer so, die Regeln, die da drin stehen, sind völlig konfus. Und die Leute denken sich immer etwas bei. Aber wenn du zum Unternehmen irgendwas willst, sag mal, hier, sie haben da was kaputt gemacht, krieg ich jetzt mal irgendwie eine Ersatzstellung oder eine Ausgleichszahlung oder so. Nee, das geht leider nicht wegen Socks.
Das heißt, die Drossel kommt?
Wegen Socks.
Wegen des Kampfes gegen den Terror?
Nee, das ist ja kein Staat.
Das muss ja sein, dass man die Leute aktiv daran hindern möchte, einfach Bombenbauanleitungen runterzuladen. Das wurde ja jetzt auch gerade wieder gemacht.
Du wirst nach 3 Giga-Terror-Drogen, wirst du halt getrosselt.
Auf eine Handgranate pro Stunde.
Genau, das können sie ja gleich in ihren Prospekt machen. Wie viele Bombenbauanleitungen man mit dem verleihen kann, das sollte für mehrere Anschläge reichen. Daher überhaupt keine Gefahr.
Wie groß ist denn das Anarchist Handbook?
Das ist eine Plain Text Datei, die ist nicht groß.
Übrigens, wenn ein Konzert zu spät anfängt, und das ist ein größeres Konzert, sagt der Veranstalter immer, sie hätten Probleme an der Videotechnik. Das ist noch unkritisch. Als Zuschauer weißt du, wenn ein Video nicht geht, dann spielt trotzdem noch die Band und der Sound ist da und so weiter. Das Video dann trotzdem funktioniert, obwohl es eine Viertelstunde später angefangen hat, das ist dann irgendwie auch okay. Hat wahrscheinlich der Gitarrist nicht ausgeschlafen.
Die Version 2004 ist immerhin, Stolze 3,7 Megabyte groß.
Haben sie jetzt Bilder zu den Bombenbauanleitungen?
Hands-on-Videos. Meanwhile in Japan, gibt es irgendwie für was? War da der Preis 39 Euro umgerechnet?
Also knapp 5000 Yen, ich habe es umgerechnet, zwar 38,50 oder so was. Ja, 40 Euro gibt es 2 Gigabit down und 1 Gigabit up.
Also mehr als du überhaupt physikalisch heutzutage in deinen Rechner mal so ohne weiteres reinführen kannst.
Ein echtes All-you-can-eat.
Wobei es dann auch wieder so ein Fake ist, weil ich habe mir gerade die Speck gezeigt dafür. Du kriegst bloß nur einen Gigabit Ethernet-Port. Das ist schön, dass du dir 2 Gigabit angeblich in dein Haus reinkippst, wenn du dir das anerkannt hast.
Nein, da sind 3 Ports dran an dem Ding. Das Ding, das ich dir eben gezeigt habe, ist das, was sie bei den Specks, das sind die Specks für die Unternehmen. Die zahlen genau das Gleiche. Da ist dann an dem LAN-Switch 3 Ports dran, 3 Gigabit Ports dran und dann kriegst du halt noch 450 MBit, ABGN, WLAN. Und du kriegst halt einen Medien, also wenn du das Haus selber besitzt, also wenn es quasi bis zur Tür geht, das Kabel, kriegst du halt einen Medienwandler rein, mit einem SC-Connector, an dem wird der Router angeschlossen. Also das ist wirklich Fiber to the Home. Und ich kann hier auch nichts finden, was irgendwelche Einschränkungen oder sowas drin hat.
Aber ganz ehrlich, solange der Ethernet-Port das Bottleneck ist, beschwere ich mich auch nicht.
Du, 27 Euro, zweite Thunderbolt, Gigabit Ethernet, mit Bonding, wie sie es nennen.
Ich hab gesagt, ich beschwere mich nicht, wenn der Ethernet-Port das Bottleneck ist.
Link Aggregation und dann kriegst du auch die zwei GIG in deinen Mac rein.
Die liefert bloß keiner.
Ich glaube uns nicht, ernsthaft, wenn du mir das jetzt so beschreibst, ich glaube uns nicht, dass das zwei GIG sind, die du in Download-Richtung oder sowas hast, weil das geht nämlich so gar nicht mit der Technik. Aber die rechnen wahrscheinlich ab und down Link zusammen, oder?
Nee, sie führen Downlink, Upstream 1 Gigabit, Downstream 2 Gigabit.
40 Euro, bei dem Preis können sie auch mal zwei zusammenfließen. Weil, wenn man eh schon so viel Geld dafür bezahlt, dann kann man doch wohl mal auch davon ausgehen, dass man mal 2 Gigabit nimmt.
Was mich nur wundert, IPv4 gibt es dynamische IPs, und IPv6 gibt es auch dynamische IPs, wobei sie aber irgendwie sagen, das wäre ein native, so ein native dynamische IPv6-IPs. Was soll das sein soll?
Naja, wahrscheinlich mit diesem EUG64-Assignment. Die holen dann Präfix raus, und jeder greift sich, was er haben will.
Mann, Mann, Mann, Tim, du und dein Telefon.
Ich versuche das gerade huckelkonform zu konfigurieren.
Und knapp 90 Euro Anschlussgebühr bei einem 2-Jahres-Vertrag.
90 Euro?
Das ist echt hart, Japaner. Ich bin echt scheiße dran.
Was die zahlen müssen, das ist der Hammer.
Dafür haben die echt hohe Handy-Rechnungen in der Regel.
Google und gibt dir für 3 Jahre mal eben das Gigabit kostenlos.
Aber auch nur in bestimmten Gegenden, ne?
Ja, es ist in Japan, es ist auch nur aktuell 6 Bezirke von Tokio, die das kriegen.
Ja, aber ich meine, wir sind hier so dermaßen weit weg. Auch nur von der Idee, dass das irgendwann mal vielleicht sein könnte. Oder?
Ich meine...
Ja, aber nur politisch. Also technisch sehe ich da jetzt keinen Hexenack drin. Nee, ich auch nicht. Aber das ist jetzt irgendwie eher so... Weil ich mich eher verheiratet, habe ich von Beginn der Sendung schon mal gesagt, ich bin doch so ein bisschen skeptisch. Die können nicht einfach, gerade bei der PC-Begeistertheit in Japan, können die nicht einfach jedem Kreti und Pleti einen Gigawit ins Haus legen, damit der da sein Viren verseuchten PC dransteckt. Weil das...
Das ist ein ganz schöner Bedenkenträger, ne?
Das gibt die Nile of Service doch.
Deswegen kriegst du ja das...
Da gibt es irgendeinen Provider, der gibt dir Gigawit nach Hause und du nimmst da...
Du kriegst einfach Elfje mit dazu. Nee, das ist alles Scheiße, das können die nicht.
Die spammen alle zu, das wollen wir nicht.
Ich warte nur mal ab, wann das passiert.
Da gibt es bestimmt noch ein paar Leute, die... Die machen mir meinen 384 Kilo Bit.
Genau, die machen mir den 364.
Jetzt hör mal, um rumzuhäulen. Lass uns mal die Japaner da ein Freundenfest feiern.
Ich rechne jetzt mal gerade schnell aus, wie viel deutsche DSL-Anschluss ein Japaner mit seinem Gigawit-Anschluss runterfahren kann.
Vielleicht kinken sie deswegen kostenlos Gigawit dazu bei ihrem Anschluss.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall...
Sind so 3000 sein oder so.
Die feiern da ein digitales Kirschblütenfest und wir stapfen hier im Sumpf. Ja, das ist wirklich nicht schön.
Also ich hab ja in der Firma immerhin dickes Internet.
Was ist denn bei dir dick? Drück mal dick in Zahlen aus.
Gigabit und 2x100 Mbit-Synchron.
Also ein japanischer Haushalt.
Drei unterschiedliche Provider. Das heißt, wenn einer failt, haben wir immer noch zwei anderes. Schon alles ganz ordentlich.
Wenn Denis, der einen Router aufgesetzt hat, auch verstanden hat, was er da tut. Schönen Gruß an Ulf.
Kirschblütenfest.
Kirschblütenfest. Wobei ich jetzt noch kurz nachschieben möchte. Immerhin, wir könnten ja, wenn mal jemand auch wieder den politischen Stock aus dem Arsch nähme, ginge auch bei uns noch ein bisschen was. Ich habe ja nach der letzten Sendung mal noch mal kurz ein bisschen gespielt und habe mal eine handelsübliche Fritz-Box an einem befreiten D-Slam betrieben. Und hatte da auch mal so ein Bildchen rum gepostet.
An einem befreiten D-Slam? Was ist bitte ein befreiter D-Slam?
Das ist ein D-Slam, der ein VDSL-D-Slam, der, will ich jetzt so ja nicht sagen, aber, jedenfalls ein D-Slam, der genau dieselben Profileinstellungen und so, es gibt ja auch so regulatorische Vorgaben. Die Telekom kann ja auch nicht so, wie sie will. Da kommt ja so eine Behörde hin und sagt ja, so, hier gibt es ja auch noch Amateurfunker in Deutschland und die darfst du nicht stören mit deinem VDSL. Deswegen machen wir hier mal noch so 2, 3 Bandpässe rein und so. Aber diese ganzen Vorgaben und so weiter, wenn man die da drauf macht, aber jetzt diese politische Entscheidung, VDSL bei 50 slash 10 zu kappen, also funktional zu destabilisieren.
Von meinem geistigen Auge sehe ich irgendwie Robin Baut und seine Bande, wie sie durch die Straße zieht und die D-Slams befreit.
Ja, so ungefähr habe ich das noch gemacht. Ich bin vor die Tür gegangen, mich hat das genervt, habe die Tür aufgemacht, meinen Laptop auf die Konsole von dem Ding drauf gesteckt und den erstmal in ordentlichen Config verpasst.
Und siehe da auf einmal, kannst du eine Fritzbox richtig durchatmen.
Ja, und wie gesagt, selbst mit den Telekom-Profilen kriegt man 102 Mbit Download hin und 64 Mbit Upload. Das war jetzt für den Upload, die 102 Down begeistert dich gar nicht so.
Man muss sich auch manchmal damit zufrieden geben, einfach nur über Urlaub nachzudenken.
Bei meinem Lebenswandel ist mir der Gedanke an Urlaub fremd.
Stell dir einfach Palmen vor, ausufernde Sandstrände, wo so ein kühlendes Bächlein noch ein paar Steine runter brutzelt, bevor es irgendwie......mit 64 Tropfen wieder hoch brutzelt.
Wollte ich wie gesagt nochmal sagen, also geht. Weil die Leute gefragt haben, so nein, ich hab's nicht gefotoshopt. Nein, ich hab auch nicht. Das ist einfach eine handelsübliche Fritzbox, die einfach mal an einem Diesel betrieben wurde, dem man mal den Stock aus dem Arsch gezogen hat. So, haben wir jetzt auch dit.
Haben wir, würd ich sagen.
Haben wir genug gejammert hier.
Genau.
Vielleicht sollte man in den Brieftauben investieren.
Da gibt's auch einen Standard für. IP über Brieftauben.
Einer von den berühmten, den ersten April, IP over Avian Carriers.
Ich weiß. Und ein paar Warnsbäger. Keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Leute haben's mal gemacht.
So, waren wir jetzt über internationale...
Haben die USB-Sticks an die Taubenbeine gebunden?
Nein, pass auf. Steht im RFC. Ist für den RFC 1149. Geht so. Du nimmst dein Paket, druckst es aus als Hexdump, wickelst es deiner Taube um den Fuß, schickst die Taube los. Der, der das drüben macht, hat zwei Möglichkeiten. Der kann das einscannen oder abtippen. Ja, und dann geht es sozusagen wieder in den Brand. Und es ist sehr interessant, die haben tolle Betrachtung gemacht. Da sagte man, gibt's denn... Kann man denn so Traces finden an Hochspannungsmasten und so? Und es ist sehr, sehr lustig. Ach ja, und das Interessante ist, wenn sonst ein Carrier droppt, es gibt ja so mal Carrier droppt, als Bezeichnung, wenn mal so ein Link runtergeht, hier bei IP Orwellien-Carriers besteht sogar noch die Chance, dass ihr Carrier von alleine wieder hochkommt und weiter geht. Das ist sehr... Der ist vom 1. April 1990, RFC 1149, sehr zu empfehlen.
Ja, wie gesagt, das haben ein paar Leute gemacht, gibt ein schönes Video dazu, wie sie irgendwie immer ihre Pakete ausdrucken, dann um das Taubenbein wickeln und auf der anderen Seite wieder so abknibbeln und auf den Scanner legen.
Am 28. April 2001 hat das die Bergen Linux User Group gemacht und dann sieht auch ein Ping unten mit einer Rondtripzeit von 6.165.731 Millisekunden. Und, interessant ist, die Paketreihenfolge ist 0421. Drei ist so getropft.
Ja, vielleicht ist das eine Option.
Die Vierertaube ist auch viel schneller erflogen. Die hat nur 3.211.900,8 Millisekunden gebraucht.
Aber wenn man Telekom ernst macht, sollte man sich vielleicht wirklich mal mit solchen Brieftaube-Züchtern auseinandersetzen.
Ja, ein Freund von mir, der hat sich jetzt eine 64-Gigabit-Karte für seine Digitalkamera gekauft.
Gigabit-Taube.
Nein, aber ich meine, wenn man solche Karten nimmt und an Brieftauben ranmacht, kommt man doch irgendwie auch noch auf einen ganz guten Durchsatz, oder?
Ja, das ist ein schöner...
Da gab es doch dieses What-If, was ist die Bandbreite von UPS? Von What-If XKCD. Also der XKCD-Mensch schreibt ja jetzt so einen Blog, What-If, wo Leute ihm seltsame Fragen stellen und er sie ernsthaft beantwortet. Und es gibt eins, wo er die Bandbreite von UPS ausrechnet. Das könnte auch Pavel sein. Ob das Internet jemals UPS überholen kann. Nein, kann es nicht, weil man irgendwie auf so einen Schiff echt viele dünne SD-Karten draufkriegt.
Haben sie übrigens auch gerade... Ich guck gerade nochmal diesen Wikipedia-Eintrag mit den Brieftauben. Haben sie später nochmal ausgerechnet, wenn man den jeder von diesen Tauben irgendwie 8 32 GB SD-Karten ans Bein bindet, die damit durch die Gegend schickt, kriegst du eben auch eine schöne Transferrate hin, so von 9,3 Gigabit oder so.
Ja, Paul hat das irgendwann mal ausgerechnet, was der Preis ist, vor allem auch so SMS-Preis damals, so im Vergleich zu Festplatten mit der Post schicken und so. Das ist schon enorme Unterschiede, ja.
Also ich finde ja immer noch erstaunlich, dass so eine SMS teurer ist als irgendwie Daten zur ISS hochzuschicken. Ja, und zwar ein deutlicher Faktor wohl. Weil du ja für eine SMS was zahlst jetzt? 19 Cent oder so? Hast du 160 Zeichen?
140 Bites, übrigens nur.
140 Bites, wie auch immer.
Ich zahle nix.
Ungewollt.
Ich habe mir jetzt konstant neu geschrieben, du zahlst jetzt nix mehr für deine SMS.
Ich glaube, die haben mittlerweile auch Probleme, ihr Businessmodell aufrechtzuerhalten. Also diese Cashcow-SMS wird jetzt nicht mehr lange halten.
Ist auch zu teuer. Die haben sich jetzt alle billigere SMS-Cs gekauft. Schon vor etlichen Jahren. Weil das alte Modell war, es ist sehr lustig, mal darüber zu reden. Das alte Modell war so, die Netzbetreiber müssen ja auch das Equipment dafür einkaufen. Und natürlich auch Lizenzen. Es ist ja nicht so, dass du jetzt einfach hingehst zu einer Firma wie CMG, die sowas herstellt, sagst, ruf mir doch mal ein SMS-C. Dann legst du ein paar Millionen auf den Tisch und das wartet. Nein, die wollen ja immer noch mitabgreifen. Und die machen das nicht nach Anzahl, oder haben das damals jedenfalls nicht nach Anzahl der SMS gemacht, sondern die haben gesagt, nach Durchsatz, nach Tacho. Also je nachdem, wie schnell das geht. Und die Vereinbarung war halt eben, dass CMG da irgendwie jederzeit messen kann, haben sie aber nicht. Sie haben nämlich immer nur an Silvester gemessen. Das war der Tacho, den sie abgelesen haben und haben gesagt, so, das waren jetzt mal 50.000 SMS pro Sekunde, hier ist unsere Rechnung. Und das war denen jetzt auf Dauer ein bisschen zu teuer. Dann haben sie schon vor ein paar Jahren angefangen, so billigere Dinger anzuschaffen und so. Das ist eine ganz abgründige Sache.
Das ist also ein Beschiss. Die ganzen Telekommunikationen als Verbrecher.
Alles Verbrecher.
Dann haben wir das Thema durch.
So, das war es dann auch. Roddy hat eine kurze Sendung versprochen.
Ich habe keine kurze Sendung versprochen.
Aber hallo? Willst du dir mal deine Mail zeigen?
So, worüber wollen wir als nächstes reden?
Mach doch mal diese To-Do-Liste an die Wand, Wiener.
Kann ich auch tun. Ich wollte die eigentlich formatieren. Das klappt aber nicht so, wie ich mir das gerade gedacht habe. Es war ein Experiment, mit dem Chess fehlt.
Damit wir jetzt nicht die ganzen Themen von deinen anderen sehr gut sehen.
Ich gehe da auch nicht immer linear durch, weißt du?
Hättest du mal Markts genommen und dann das auf das da dringerennert? Oder kann er nicht mit Markten gehen?
Wo wir gerade bei bösen Firmen sind? Da reden wir doch mal hier über Dit. Da reden wir doch mal über Google.
Webstuff für 200, sag ich doch.
Genau.
Die ist für 200 nur böse Firma.
Hat doch viel für neulich, habt ihr das gesehen? Es gibt auch irgendwelche Leute, die die schlechtsten US-Unternehmen geratet haben und die treten gegeneinander an, weißt du wieso, die Mannschaft bei so einer Fußball-WM. Also immer Zweie gegen Andere und wer es schlimmer und wer weniger schlimmer ist, fliegt raus. Google hat es relativ weit geschafft. Oder sind die relativ vorne? Ich finde die gleich noch mal eine Pfanne. Irgendwie sehr witzig. Ob sie schon in der Vorrunde ausgeschieden sind oder wie weit sie es gebracht haben als missliebigstes Unternehmen.
Wie es ausgeht, wissen wir noch nicht, aber auf jeden Fall gibt es einen interessanten Shift in dieser ganzen Webwelt. Das hat sich dadurch innerhalb zweier Tage entwickelt. Als erstes meldete sich Mozilla gemeinsam mit Samsung und kündigte an, dass sie ihr Gecko, also ihre bisherige Rendering-Engine des Firefox, komplett neu machen, neu implementieren, auch in einer neuen Programmiersprache namens Rust.
Die auch ganz viele Freunde schon gefunden hat. Ja, hat sie. Viele Leute, die sich jetzt so Go angeguckt haben, als so eine neue C-Interpretation oder Rust, die meisten, die ich so jetzt gesprochen habe, fanden Rust eigentlich sogar ein bisschen charmanter.
Ist die auch funktional eigentlich?
Hatte so ein Rewrite-Netscape-Navigator schon kaputt gemacht?
Ein Rewrite ist immer eine unheimlich gute Idee, wenn man ein großes, komplexes Projekt hat und all die Bugs schon einmal gefunden und gefixt hat.
Aber irgendwann geht es halt nicht mehr.
Es sind halt immer noch genug da.
Da hat man endlich neue Bugs.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr gewagt, wenn auch nicht schlecht, dass sie jetzt sagen, wir haben jetzt hier gleich mal eine neue Programmiersprache gewählt. Das ist an sich sehr doch funktional. Also es ist eine kompilierte Concurrent Functional Imperative Object-Oriented Instructure.
Supporting Pure Functional.
Ja, muss man nicht, kann man aber.
Also es ist eine Multiparadigmen-Sprache.
Alles. Und das ist ja etwas, vor allem ist sie concurrent und ich denke, das ist auch der Trend generell und gerade für so etwas wie einen Webbrowser einfach absolut unerlässlich, dass man einfach in der Programmiersprache, in der runtime schon Parallelität, Konkurrenz sozusagen drin hat. Gut, darüber Besprache kann ich mich nicht groß auslassen. Ich schätze mal, sie werden sich da schon ein paar Gedanken gemacht haben. Das sagt natürlich im Umkehrschluss nicht darüber aus, wie gut diese neue Engine sein wird, die da heißen soll Servo. Und es ist natürlich sehr interessant, dass sie da ausgerechnet mit Samsung ins Boot springen. Mozilla ist auch darauf angewiesen, neue Allianzen zu finden. Ich glaube ja, dass das Firefox-OS, was sie sich da ausdenken und da in Brasilien und anderen Märkten, wo die anderen noch nicht so stark sind, launchen wollen, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob das überhaupt jemals vom Flag kommt.
Ja, die sind sowieso von WebKit, glaube ich, ziemlich gut abgeschossen worden, oder? Also Mozilla und ihr Firefox-Gekko.
Ja, das kann man auch sagen, weil WebKit einfach besser war. Also ich meine, sie haben in den letzten Jahren mit dem Speed von WebKit so nicht mehr mithalten können. Das hat man gemerkt.
Und in dem Markt zählt sowas wie besser noch?
Na ja, besser hieß ja in den letzten Jahren bei den Rendering-Engines vor allem schneller. Die Renderer sind ja wirklich schneller geworden.
Also ich habe ja relativ viel mit Endnutzern zu tun in meinem Job und die haben alle irgendwie einen Firefox installiert.
Ja klar, das wird ja auch noch benutzt, aber die Zahlen sind deutlich zurückgegangen.
Weil der IE4 ihnen nichts mehr darstellt, oder was?
Nee, keine Ahnung, warum sie den haben. Sie haben trotzdem irgendwie ihre Windows-Updates an, aber viele haben Firefox. Also wenn sie so weit sind, sich einen anderen Browser zu installieren, installieren sie einen Firefox in der Regel.
Na gut, das hängt immer davon ab, wer deine Freunde sind.
Kein Chrome. Kein Chrome, da wäre mir jetzt noch niemand untergekommen, der mir mit einem Chrome angekommen wäre.
Aber kennst du jemand, der auf einem Mobilgerät einen Firefox benutzt?
So viele ist die Frage, wie viele von nichten als mit Mobilgerät.
Also nein, irgendwas, wo ein Armprozessor und ein Akku drin ist.
Doch, rein theoretisch kenne ich da jemanden.
Ich glaube, das ist auch einer der Hauptgründe, warum sie überhaupt auf eine neue Plattform umsteigen. Dass sie einfach diese ganze mobile Entwicklung mit ihrer alten Engine so nicht mehr mitziehen können. Aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Ich kenne den Code nicht, ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist ja sehr offensichtlich. Entweder wollten sie nicht oder sie konnten nicht. Tatsache ist, da kam nichts und die Bedeutung von Gecko ist doch stark gesungen.
Da gibt es auch so eine Doku über die letzten Tage von Netscape. Wie waren das nochmal, wo die Hacker von Netscape zeigen, wie sie dann noch den Code open sourcen wollen, was das für ein Akt war. Die war eigentlich ganz interessant. Ja, das weiß ja vielleicht der Chat.
Also was ich in dem Zusammenhang empfehlen kann, es gibt einen Podcast, der heißt Debug. Da hatten sie neulich eine Folge mit dem Chef von dem WebKit-Projekt bei Apple, der ja vorher bei Netscape war. Dieses Open Sourcen, von dem Netscape tatsächlich auch betreut hat. Der erzählt so lustig, er wäre zu dem Projekt gekommen, in dem irgendjemand ist aufgefallen, da sind ja total viele Swearwords in dem Code drin, die ganzen Fax müssen wir vorher rausmachen. Und dann hat er so geschrieben, was ist denn mit? Und hat in der internen Mailingliste eine Liste von 20 Swearwords geschrieben. Die müssen wir auch alle noch rausmachen. Und dann meinte der oberste Chef nur, du hast den Job. Da hat jemand den Link in den Chat geworfen. Der ist sehr spannend, der Podcast. Den kann man sich wirklich mal anhören.
Der schreibt auch interessante Bloganträge.
Auch die ganze Story, wie er dann zu Apple gekommen ist.
Ich pack mal den Link hier kurz in den Chat von der Wikipedia, wo das kurz beschrieben wird. Auf YouTube gibt's da auch Clips von, kann man wahrscheinlich sogar mittlerweile komplett frei gucken. Ich hab mal vor einigen Jahren geguckt. Da kann man mal sehen, wie das auch im Silicon Valley zu der Zeit dann noch so abging. Und wie die Nerds da so drauf waren.
René Ritchie ist auch auf UptopMed.
Ist klar. Der ist auch unter Creative Commons irgendwo auch zu finden. Und auf YouTube, glaube ich, in voller Länge auch.
Aber nix kostet taugt nix.
Ja, den kann man hier im Web gucken. 56 Minuten. Alles auf der Wikipedia-Seite verlinkt. Guckt euch das mal an.
Documentary.
Genau. Und hört euch den Podcast an.
Werd ich tun. So, zurück zu den Engines, also Mozilla mit Samsung. Da stellt sich natürlich auch so ein bisschen die Frage, was soll der Move? Und das klingt für mich natürlich so ein bisschen so, als ob Samsung seine Aktivitäten verstärkt, seine Abhängigkeit von Google einzuschränken.
Meinen Sie, so manche Dealer können Sie das nicht ausdrücken?
Na ja, irgendwann werden die Karten sichtbar. Und wenn es so ist, weiß Google das jetzt eh schon.
Aber mal ganz ehrlich, also sich mit Mozilla in ein Boot zu setzen, einen Browser neu zu schreiben, wo in frühestens drei oder vier Jahren die ersten greifbaren Ergebnisse rauskommen. Was soll das? Das vergute ich.
Du weißt ja nicht, wann die angefangen haben.
Na auf jeden Fall erst seitdem es Rust gibt. Und das gibt es noch nicht so lange. Aber wer weiß. Ich meine, immerhin kennen sie sich ja aus und wissen...
Ja, natürlich kennen sie sich aus, aber ein kompletter Rewrite ist gerne mal so ein Totläuferprojekt, ne?
Ja, aber ein kompletter Rewrite kann auch manchmal die einzige Lösung sein. Ich meine, das ist das, was Netscape Navigator zu Firefox auch überhaupt erst mal wieder aus der Versenkung geholt hat. Da war halt die alte Codebase. Wie hieß das noch? Der alte Renderer? Hieß der eigentlich überhaupt irgendwie?
Der hatte so einen Namen, warte mal.
Das war halt das Elend. Ich meine, erinnern ihr euch noch? Nur mal so... Das war jetzt kurz der Zeitenwende-Sound, weißt du so? Rückblende, wie geht das immer so in den Filmen? Du hast eine Webseite offen. Und dann fasst du sie rechts unten mit der Maus an, resize sie. Und was macht die Webseite dann?
Redrawn.
Sie lädt neu.
Und wenn du Glück hast, stürz Netscape dabei nicht ab. Und zieht dir vor allen Dingen das ganze Betriebssystem nicht weg.
Du füllst ein Formular aus, hast es halb ausgefüllt, schiebst dann das Fenster auf, damit du den Platz hast, um es zu sehen, dann lädt die Seite neu und alle deine Eingaben sind weg. Das war die Realität dieser alten, so genannten Rendering.
Ich wollte meinen Blinken leiten.
Clemens, das habe ich schon in der anderen Podcast erwähnt, aber an der Stelle kann ich es echt nochmal sagen. Du bist ja derjenige, der mir das erste Mal einen Webbrowser gezeigt hat.
Diese NCSA-Mosaik-Dinger. Ja, genau.
Hier ist er mit Guck mal und so. Hier im Internet gibt es jetzt auch einen Bund und so. Da waren wir noch so dabei und so aus den Commandlines.
Ja, vor allem Bund war damals, wenn ein Bild in der Seite mit drin war.
Nach einer dieser CRE-Sendungen im letzten Jahr hat jemand hier, glaube ich, von der TU oder so, eine alte Grafik ausgegraben. Ich weiß nicht, von 91 oder 92. Das deutsche Web, das passte damals noch auf eine DIN-A4-Seite drauf. Und da sind zwei Server von mir auch mit drauf. Und da hast du richtig gesehen, so eine Karte von Deutschland, wo denn jetzt welche Web-Server stehen. Die will ich sehen, die Grafik. Das passt noch auf eine A4. Ich finde die noch mal wieder. Ich fand echt super, das Ding.
Ich wollte ja mal einen Blinken-Lights-Editor bauen, als Blinken-Lights noch gerade das hippe Ding in Berlin war. Dann wollte ich das mit JavaScript machen, weil ich keinen Bock hatte auf diese Director-Sache. Dann habe ich das so reduziert und hatte diese Matrix nur mit kleinen Bildchen für die Fenster. Einmal aus und einmal an in einem Bild. Mit JavaScript hin und her schieben. Ein Fenster an und aus machen mit 25 Frames in Sekunden. Das hat den Browser schon auf 100% CPU gebracht, weil er das ganze Fenster redrawed. Das habe ich in dem Moment auch gemerkt. Was kann denn jetzt hier so lange dauern, um dieses scheißkleine Bild hin und her zu schieben, und dann Quarz-Debug angemacht, oder was auch immer. Und dann irgendwie alles wird gerendert. Verstehe, super.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, da gibt es einiges zu verbessern. Und so ein Re-Fright kann schon das Richtige sein. Und ich gehe jetzt aber auch nicht davon aus, auch wenn ich es nicht weiß, dass sie das jetzt angekündigt haben und sie haben noch keine Zeile Code geschrieben. Sondern ich vermute mal, dass sie so irgendeine Proof-of-Concept-Phase mindestens durchstochen haben, wenn sie nicht schon im stillen Kämmerlein mit irgende... Also wenn sie nicht diese ganze Programmiersprache damit entwickelt haben, diese Engine zu schreiben. Ja, dass das sozusagen auch der Bootstrap für die Language als solche war, weil die hatten da ja sicherlich ein klares Ziel. Die Sprache ist ja auch von Mozilla selbst. Also die ist ja zu diesem Zwecke erfunden worden. Und ich vermute mal, vermuten heißt nicht wissen. Aber davon gehe ich jetzt erstmal aus. Und Samsung kann sich von Google freimachen. Und das Interessante ist, ich sage, die Abhängigkeit loswerden, dann klingt das ja so ein bisschen wie vom Moloch Google befreien. Der Punkt ist nur, dass Samsung mittlerweile viel stärker ist als Google. Und dass es im Wesentlichen ein Problem für Google darstellt, wenn sich Samsung abkoppelt, insbesondere was den asiatischen Markt betrifft.
Jetzt musst du aber erklären, warum gerade die Rendering-Engine für das HTML da jetzt die Tür aufmacht, sich von Google befreien.
Wenn du heute ein OS brauchst, dann brauchst du auch eine Rendering-Engine.
Ja schon, aber so ein Webkit ist ja immer noch Gnu-Code und das ist immer noch open source.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass du das jetzt teuer von der die zu sehen bist.
Und vielleicht will ja Samsung auch zu Firefox-OS oder sowas gehen. Von Android weg.
Das kann alles sein. Samsung haben ja sogar schon ein eigenes OS gehabt. Wie hieß das noch gleich?
Bada? Was soll das sein? Eine Sprache? Nee, das war auch irgendwie ein OS von denen. Ich erinnere mich, das ist...
Es gab da schon so Advancen und dann sind sie voll auf den Android-Train aufgesprungen. Und jetzt sind sie so an einem Punkt, wo sie alle Profite des Android-Marktes haben. Das muss man sich auch nochmal klar machen. Es gibt nur ein Android-Hersteller, der verdient jedes Geld auf diesem Markt.
Weil die andere Geld verlieren oder was?
Oder keins machen. Also die anderen HTC, etc., die verdienen derzeit nichts oder machen Verlust. Und auch Nokia und auch alle anderen sozusagen. Aber auch, also wenn man jetzt nur Android-basierte Technologie nimmt, Smartphones oder überhaupt Telefone, gibt es nur Samsung, die Geld verdienen. Und die verdienen halt 30% der Profite, die international zu holen sind. Und die anderen 70% kriegt Apple. Natürlich mit oder ohne Android. So, das heißt, Samsung steht saustark da. Die verdienen unfassbar viel Geld und vor allem sind sie die Firma, die nahezu 100% der Technologie, die sie da verkauft, selber herstellt. Mit der einzigen Ausnahme dieses kleinen Layers, der zwischen Linux und ihren Apps liegt oder ihren Bildschirmen, je nachdem, wie man das sieht, nämlich dem Android-Kram. Und vielleicht haben sie jetzt einfach beschlossen, dass die Leute sowieso nicht wissen, was sie da benutzen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch so. Also Leute, die jetzt ein Galaxy S4 kaufen.
Die kaufen ein Galaxy S4 und nicht ein Android-Device.
Genau. Also laut GitHub-History sind sie seit über einem Jahr an diesem Servo dran.
Also was ich nicht so ganz verstehe, aber vielleicht habe ich auch noch nicht verstanden, warum, ist, warum die Leute denken, ein Betriebssystem wäre irgendwie ein Kernel und eine HTML-Rendering-Engine. Also das ist so... Ja, aber ich meine, also für mich ist eine HTML-Rendering-Engine eher ein Sahnehäubchen als jetzt der Hauptteil eines Betriebssystems.
Nicht, wenn dein Plan ist, auf der Basis mit JavaScript auch deine ganzen Ups zu machen. JavaScript ist mittlerweile so schnell, dass du sehr wohl darüber nachdenken kannst, dass als deine native Poemin-Sprache zu verwenden.
Meinst du nicht, die werden dann eher Rust sogar supporten?
Keine Ahnung, aber auf jeden Fall jetzt nicht komplett von der Hand zu weisen, dass das demnächst schnell genug ist.
Du meinst so wie bei Palm und so wie bei dieses, wie hieß es?
Da liegen aber noch mal ein paar Jahre dazwischen.
Zwischen einer halb fertigen Ring-in-the-Ring-Engine und einem kompletten Palm.
Naja, ich meine so von dem, was da im Prozessor drin steckt, dass es mit dem Kram umgehen kann. Die Frage ist, wie würde WebOS aussehen mit heutiger Prozessorleistung?
Ja, das ist natürlich richtig. Wenn du dir dieses GitHub-Ding anguckst und siehst, dass sie es nur in 64-Bit entwickeln, dann weißt du, dass es auch erst mal nicht morgen rauskommt. Sondern dann, wenn die Arm-Prozessoren sicher 64-Bit können.
Ja, es sagt ja niemand, dass die das morgen haben wollen.
Tja, naja, auf jeden Fall. Jetzt ist ja erstmal Bierbringendienst angesagt. Also, Tim hat es zwar noch nicht erwähnt, aber es steht ja schon da. Und eigentlich ist es jetzt ja auch die nächste Ankündigung, dass jetzt ja Google WebKit gefolgt hat und das Blink nennt. Und die haben natürlich den Vorteil, dass jetzt die ganze epische dimensionsspaltenartig große Test-Suite von WebKit wahrscheinlich einfach übernehmen können. Und nicht irgendwie von vorne anfangen müssen. Jeder, der mal WebKit ausgecheckt hat und mal die Tests hat laufen lassen, also schon der Checkout von den Tests dauert ja gefühlte Jahre. Da wird einem auch erstmal klar, was so ein Browser eigentlich für eine Scheißarbeit ist heutzutage. Also das würde mich auch mal interessieren, ob die bei Mozilla dann wenigstens ihre alte Test-Suite übernehmen können oder ob sie da auch von vorne anfangen.
Ich hatte ja diesen Podcast schon erwähnt, wo sie da diesen Apple-Menschen interviewen. Und der meinte, das erste, was er an den Start gebracht hat, war eine Test-Suite, die nicht nur testet, ob das Zeug korrekt ist, sondern auch, ob eine Performance-Regression aufgetreten ist. Und er meinte, eine Zeit lang wäre er der gehassteste Mensch in der Crew genau dafür gewesen, weil er halt immer alle Commits, die irgendwas langsamer machen, halt sofort den Leuten wieder um die Ohren gehauen hat.
Jetzt haben wir also wieder, nachdem wir die Mono-Kultur-Webkit schon fast als Realität akzeptiert haben, plötzlich wieder mannigfaltige Optionen.
Eigentlich müssten wir uns freuen.
Da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob ich mich da so darüber freuen soll, weil in gewisser Hinsicht war ja auch die Vereinheitlichung der Rendering Engine in letzter Zeit auch sehr entscheidend beim Fortschritt in dieser ganzen HTML-Welt. Ich meine, es war immerhin offen. Da haben mehrere Firmen an dem gemeinsamen Kern gearbeitet. Und man ist das so ein bisschen auch wie Linux. Es ist sozusagen auch der Kernel, den andere alle verwenden, die nicht ihren eigenen gerade haben. Und darauf konzentrieren sich dann halt so die Energien. Es gibt dann natürlich auch immer noch so viele BSD, aber angenommen es würde jetzt morgen irgendwie drei Linux Kernel developments geben. Also ob das jetzt so allgemein begrüßt werden würde als die neue Freiheit, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Stimmt, warum hat eigentlich noch niemand die Linux Kernel gefragt mit großem Memborium? Das ist doch echt...
Ja gut, in gewisser Hinsicht gab es das ja tatsächlich mit den eigenen Maintainer-Prinzipien und so. Da stecke ich jetzt aber auch nicht so drin. Wie auch immer, das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt alles evil sein. Ich finde es nur interessant. Also Samsung geht mit Mozilla zusammen und das riecht für mich nach Mozilla. Sie brauchen einen starken Partner und den haben sie gegebenenfalls sogar auch gefunden. Wobei ich zweifel an der Durchsetzungs-Power von Samsung. Samsung kann gut Telefone bauen und vielleicht auch verkaufen. Und sie können auch gut kopieren, aber Software machen und OS machen, da ist auch der gesamte Ostteil dieses Planeten auch noch nicht so hervorgetreten.
Also ich frag mich halt, ob dieser Schritt von Samsung, jetzt Mozilla zu unterstützen, nicht mehr so ein Drohgehabe ist. Also in Korea macht man das ja eh scheinbar gerne, Drohgehabe.
Gangnam Style.
Ja, Kim Jong Un Style.
Irgendjemand hatte das getwittert oder so. Das war so ein schönes Zitat, dass irgendwie Kim Jong Un irgendwie so daherkommt, als hätte er das Diplomatieverhalten aus einer alten Version von Civilization gelernt oder so. Wer war das? Nee, aber das fand ich eigentlich sehr treffend so, weil jeder, der mal Civilization gespielt hat und wieder die Diplomatie so funktioniert hat, wenn nicht irgendjemand so mal das erste Mal besucht hat und so. Es war so im Wesentlichen, gib mir Gold oder ich mach dich platt. Es gab dann nur sehr eingeschränkte Verhandlungsmodi. Hatte dieser schon im Retro-Zirkel?
Civilization hatten wir noch nicht im Retro-Zirkel, nee.
Das ist zu neu, oder was?
Nee, das ist nicht zu neu, aber wir machen wenig Computerspiele, wir machen mehr Konsolenspiele.
Spätestens nach 2000 Episoden müsst ihr umsetzen.
Wir haben ja schon immer mal wieder das eingestreut. At least I could do. So ein Webcomic hat ja als Theorie, dass Kim Jong Un das alles wegen seiner Frau macht. Dass er die quasi beeindrucken will.
Wenn sich die Welt nur mal sicher wäre, wer denn nun eigentlich seine Frau ist. Ist ja auch schon mit mehreren Torten unterwegs gewesen.
War das?
Jetzt kriegen wir wieder eins auf die Nuss, ne?
Scheiße.
Das T-Shirt.
Oh, North Korea Mod for Civilization. What? Raufklick, was ist das denn? Hoffentlich ist das lustig.
So, wir haben Torte gesagt, wir sind böse.
Du musst jetzt erstmal 10 Minuten aussetzen.
Ja, okay, dann lass mich kurz noch...
Ich muss aufzusetzen, dann lass mich kurz.
Ich muss jetzt sagen, worüber wir reden. Also ich meine, jetzt hatten wir Samsung, Mozilla, Gekko wird zu Servo, benutzt Rust und Samsung baut vielleicht, aber vielleicht auch nicht, ein neues Empire auf, in dem sie Google rausschmeißen von ihrer Plattform. Das ist jetzt so die Verschwörungstheorie. Aber das habe ich auch nicht verfolgt.
Ja, wie gesagt, also der Gegenentwurf wäre halt, sie machen jetzt hier einen auf Hallo Google entweder, oder wir benutzen wirklich das neue Rust.
Es kann auch einfach sein, ich meine, was genauso gut sein kann, was ich in gewisser Hinsicht sogar für wahrscheinlicher noch halte, ist, dass sie sich was Neues bauen, was sie vielleicht gar nicht mal jetzt primär auf denselben Telefonen, auf denselben Smartphones anwenden, wo sie derzeit Android haben, sondern dass sie quasi die Billigsparte darunter, die Feature Phones, wo es irgendwie ausreicht, einen Facebook- und einen Twitter-Client drauf zu haben, dass sie dafür eine neue Plattform nehmen, die sie vor allem auch in China und anderen asiatischen Märkten zum Einsatz bringen kann.
Und dafür brauchen sie eine neue Rendering-Engine.
Sie wollen sich unabhängig machen von Google.
Ja, aber sie sind doch eh unabhängig. Ich meine, sie haben irgendwann geforkt. Sie haben irgendwann geforkt und jetzt haben sie ihr eigenes Android und fertig.
Sie haben nicht geforkt.
Die haben nie geforkt, oder? Die haben nur ihre eigene Oberfläche draufgesetzt.
Das können sie ja auch gar nicht, weil sie wollen ja die App-Infrastruktur auch unterstützen. Es ist noch nicht so weit, dass jetzt die App-Developer auch gegen Samsung Android programmieren, sondern da gibt es im Wesentlichen nur die Versionsvorgabe von Google und andere APIs. In dem Sinne gibt es nicht. Also ich denke eher ZweitOS für Feature Phones oder das, was früher mal die Feature Phones war, die zweite Liga, tendenziell aber schon mit dem Anspruch, mehr Unabhängigkeit zu haben. Nicht, dass sie sich jetzt dumm und dimmlich für Android zahlen würden. Aber Samsung denkt sich halt auch, wer sind denn hier die starken? Und auch um Apple da die Stirn zu bieten, hätten sie halt auch gerne mal eigene App Store, eigene Infrastruktur, eigene Marschrichtung, wohin die Reise geht etc. Auf allen Telefonen tendenziell. Sie werden jetzt nicht morgen Android komplett lebewohl sagen. Das können sie auch nicht, weil sie natürlich da auch in der Abhängigkeit der Store-Realitäten drin sind. Aber da fühlen sie sich halt nicht sonderlich wohl. Und warum? Das ist ja auch jedem klar. So, jetzt in dem Fahrwasser. Einen Tag später kam dann die Ankündigung von Google, dass sie sich aus WebKit rausziehen bzw. dass sie ihre Teilnahme an WebKit dadurch beenden, indem sie das forken und umbenennen in Blink.
Vor allen Dingen ist WebKit auf SVN immer noch. Das heißt, ein Fork ist ein richtiger Fork. Da geht es auch nicht wieder zurück.
In gewisser Hinsicht forken sie gar nicht vollständig, weil sie ja ohnehin schon eine ganze Menge Sachen drin haben, die gar nicht in WebKit sind. Also zum Beispiel das Prozessmodell von Chrome hat nie den Weg zu WebKit gefunden. Angeblich wollte Apple, oder haben Sie Google gefragt, ob sie denn vorhaben, das zu kontributen, was sie dann nicht getan haben. Das war zumindest die Aussage von so einem WebKit-Menschen. Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie Blink. Und was die Richtung hier ist, kann man auch nur mutmaßen. Entweder sind sie da generell nicht der Meinung, dass so wie WebKit abgeht, ist so ihr Weg. Aber auch hier, glaube ich, wollen sie sich einfach von Apple lösen. Einfach zu nah an Apple dran, keine Angst. Opera, die ja gerade angekündigt hatten, auf WebKit zu gehen, folgen, glaube ich, auch dem Blink-Pfad.
Ja, das haben Sie ja schon gesagt, weil Sie ja gesagt haben, Sie folgen Chromium und haben dann auch direkt angekündigt. Ja klar, machen wir dann auch Blink.
So, und auf einmal ist diese schöne einheitliche Landschaft innerhalb einer Woche komplett wieder 1000 Stücke zerhackt worden. Ob das jetzt so hilfreich sein wird für die Web-Developer, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Aber auch wenn das alles, was heutzutage WebKit heißt, ist ja letzten Endes anders. Also ein Chrom verhält sich einfach auch heute schon sehr viel anders als ein Safari an vielen Stellen. Und Chrom hat einiges an Support, was Safari nicht hat und umgekehrt. Naja, wobei ich glaube Chrom es doch mehr hat.
Zum Beispiel bei Chrom geht doch WebM, ne?
Bei Chrom geht zum Beispiel seit längerer Zeit schon WebGL. Läuft da schon lange im Release. Ist bei Safari immer noch nicht drin.
Dazu hat der Apple-Typ auch was gesagt.
Was denn?
Er findet es sehr spannend, aber im Standard anschalten, no way, weil du natürlich eine Web-Technologie, die runtergeht, bis auf die Grafikkarte, da musst du den ganzen Stack bis runter auf den Grafikkartentreiber so sicher haben, dass du in der Lage sein kannst, halt einen beliebigen Inhalt aus dem Internet tatsächlich auch auf deine Grafikkarte zu lassen. Und da sieht er die Welt noch nicht.
Ah ja, interessanter Gesichtspunkt.
Ja, aber es ist ja nichts anderes. OpenGL auf der Grafikkarte, webgetrieben. Und wenn du die Welt auf deine Grafikkarte lässt, dann...
Und auf den PCI Express Bus. Dann geht die Party los.
Das war jetzt für mich auch nur so ein Beispiel, dass sie das halt haben. Und das ist halt bei Safari jetzt so nicht drin.
Man kann es wohl irgendwie anschalten.
Na ja, und dann haben sie doch auch diese, die Prozesstrennung, dann läuft auch anders ein Chrome und Safari.
Wobei ich da ehrlich gesagt den Chrome-Way irgendwie für erfolgreicher halte.
Ja, mir stürzt Safari immer komplett ab, wenn ich einen bestimmten Tabs aufmache.
Ja, weil sie halt einen Prozess haben, der halt das ganze Rendering macht. Und wenn der halt irgendwie vor die Hunde geht, dann gehen halt alle deine Seiten vor die Hunde. Und bei Chrome hast du halt eine Kapselung auf Prozessbasis, was so für meinen Geschmack irgendwie, na ja, ganz sane klingt. Hat natürlich auch Nachteile.
Ja, irgendjemand müsste um dieses Chromium mal eine ordentliche Oberfläche drum stricken. Naja, also ich meine, na ja, bei Google und Benutzeroberflächen, das riechst du jetzt.
Das wird nichts mehr, meinste.
Da will ich mich gar nicht drüber ausweichen.
Über Oberflächen werden wir uns gleich noch sehr ausführlich verahnen.
Obwohl es da doch auch heißt, dass Google schneller im Design besser wird als Apple bei Web-Services, von daher...
Ja, bei mir ist davon noch nichts angekommen.
Ja, ich finde schon, dass sie besser geworden sind.
Mag sein. Bei mir ist noch nichts davon angekommen.
Ich weiß, sie sind nicht auf dem Standard von Apple, aber sie sind besser geworden. Also die Lücke wird kleiner.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall ganz spannend, gerade so, dadurch, dass sie sich da alle wieder so ein bisschen auseinanderziehen.
Wird bestimmt aber die Innovationsleistung befeuern, wenn der eine wieder nach vorne springt und dann...
Na gut, aber WebKit verliert jetzt erstmal die Hälfte seiner Entwickler.
Browser War Nummer 3.
Das muss ich auch alles erstmal wieder einpendeln. Auf jeden Fall gibt es eine Menge Opportunities hier für findige Programmierer, mal wieder eine neue Heimat zu finden. Naja, wo wir gerade im Bereich der Abhängigkeiten sind, Google scheint da ja so diverse Einstiegslöcher zu bieten in Android, wo man sich nett einklinken kann. Mir persönlich war das so nicht bekannt. Diese Launcher-Sache, dass man jetzt unter Android sich so als Hauptprogramm, so quasi als Finder ins OS einklinken kann und damit quasi so die Default Experience beim Einschalten und so auf dem Homescreen quasi wiedergeben kann. Das hat dann Facebook einfach mal genutzt und angekündigt, dass sie jetzt dieses Facebook Home demnächst rauswerfen, was sich eben genau an der Stelle so einklingt. Ja, da hast du mehr Gesichter auf deinem Screen. Du kannst die ganze Zeit mit deinem Finger auf irgendwelchen Gesichtern rumwischen und die durch die Gegend draggen.
Schlimm daran ist eigentlich nur, dass es wahrscheinlich Leute gibt, die das gut finden und sich das holen werden.
Ja, für die hat das Leben endlich wieder einen Sinn.
Ja, also keine Ahnung. Ich finde es interessant, Facebook propagiert damit ja eine Experience, die sozusagen bedeutet, alles geht über die Person. Du kommst von der Person, du kommst zu Informationen, du kommst zu Kommunikation etc.
Was für einen interessanter Ansatz ist.
Was für einen interessanter Ansatz ist. Und auf IOS kommst du halt immer über die App. Ich meine, wenn du eine Person aufrufen willst, auf ein iPhone, dann musst du dir erstmal Gedanken machen, mit welcher App du das machst.
Das stimmt, das ist jedes Mal so. Das verbraucht ein paar Hirnzyklen.
Rufst du jetzt irgendwie Kontakte oder Telefon-App auf oder so?
Ich benutze natürlich Siri.
Ich benutze meistens das Spotlight, also einfach die Suche. Das ist für mich der schnellste Weg.
Wobei der aber nervt.
Ja klar nervt das.
Er nervt deswegen, weil du tippst was ein, er findet das, und denkst, genau das wollte ich haben. Und während du mit dem Finger auf dein Display zusteuerst, 3 Nanometer bevor du das Display berührst, findet er noch was und schiebt an die selbe Stelle, wo dein Finger gerade hin tippt.
Ja, und dann startest du erstmal. Wobei ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen kann, wie das jetzt bei Facebook so sehr viel einfacher sein soll, weil ich meine, keine Ahnung, wie viele Leute ihr in eurem Adressbuch habt, aber bei mir ist das wirklich eine signifikante dreistellige Zahl.
Man kann ja mal schauen.
Ich kann ja mal schauen.
Es kann sein, dass die Zahl so signifikant dreistellig ist, dass sie schon vierstellig ist.
Toll. Dieses geomorphische Adressbuch zeigt total nicht mehr an.
Das Alter hat es einmal angezeigt, stand immer unten.
Zwei Karten. 502 Karten. Wenn du ganz runterskreust, steht ganz gut.
Oder select all, kannst du auch machen. Ab für A und dann 475 immerhin.
719. Aber ich habe neulich mal aufgeräumt.
Aber ihr seid ja auch alle viel älter als ich.
886?
Also ich habe 2655.
Aber ihr seid doch alle älter als ich.
Ja gut, ich meine ich stelle mir jetzt mal vor, dass ich irgendwie 2600 Gesichtseicons auf meinem Homescreen habe, wo ich dann irgendwie... Was soll ich da so machen?
Ja aber Moment, wie viel von diesen 2600? Also die sind ja natürlich auch nach Aktivität und Kommunikation und Interesse gewichtet. Du kriegst ja jetzt nicht den letzten Hansel, den du vor 13 Jahren das letzte Mal kontaktiert hast, dann gleich auf deiner Startseite.
Die ist noch irgendwie Chat Hats oder so. War das nicht irgendwie so, dass sie quasi immer den Instant-Messager einblenden? Also ich habe es selber noch nicht benutzt, aber so habe ich es zumindest verstanden.
Ich habe gar keine Facebook.
Ich habe Facebook, neue iOS-Facebook-App auch nicht ausprobiert, weil da geht es ja angeblich ähnlich.
Geht was wie?
Facebook 6.0 ist doch für iOS rausgekommen und da gibt es auch Chat Hats. Du musst sie gegebenenfalls aktivieren. Beziehungsweise, das muss für deinen Account aktiviert werden. Oder kannst du irgendwelche P-List-Dateien ändern, dann kannst du es auch schon vorzeitig aktivieren. Es gibt jetzt ein Update für Facebook, für iOS, wo dieser ganze Kram, so Chat Hats und dieses Zeug, auch schon drin ist.
6.0?
Ja, genau. Das hängt aber von deinem Account ab, ob du das alles so benutzen kannst. Also sprich, ob es Facebook für dich aktiviert hat. Falls sie es nicht aktiviert haben, kannst du irgendwie P-List-Dateien editieren und kannst es dann trotzdem sehen. Ich habe heute festgestellt, dass Facebook die einzige Seite ist, bei der ich mich alt fühle. Ich weiß endlich, wie mein Vater sich fühlt, wenn er vor einem Rechner sitzt. Ich muss nur Facebook aufmachen und ich weiß, wie er sich fühlt, weil ich verstehe es nicht.
Wie fühlt er sich denn?
Ich bin verwirrt und verstehe es nicht.
Das geht mir auch so, da bin ich auch alt genug. Facebook ist für mich jedes Mal eine Webseite, wo ich überhaupt nicht Facebook und die Support-Seiten von Amazon. Das ist ungefähr so auf dem selben Level.
Wenn ich versuche, meine Kindle-Seite zu finden.
Oder wo kann ich einen Rechnungsdoppel anfordern? Das ist wirklich eine Herausforderung. Da kann man sich wirklich sehr alt fühlen. Und mit Facebook ist es ähnlich. Aber ich glaube, es geht allen anderen auch so. Die sind bloß nicht bereit, das zuzugeben. Es wird noch niemanden getroffen, der meint, Facebook ist wie meine Westentasche.
Was nach deinem 30. Lebensjahr hinzukommt.
Aber das muss er auch nicht. Ich muss ja nicht wieder eine Westentasche kennen. Es geht auch so.
Ich kenne mich schon gerne aus. Aber ich verstehe einfach bei Facebook überhaupt nicht, was es von mir will. Da tauchen da die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Sachen auf, die ich nie wollte, geschrieben habe.
Das Beste finde ich bei Facebook, wo man so eine tolle Facebook-Fanpage aufmacht, dass man gar nicht alle sehen, die einem folgen, sondern nur bestimmt viele. Nur, wenn man Geld einwirft, quasi. Na ja, du kannst ja so Werbung schalten. Du kannst sagen... Genau, Promote. Und 80% meiner Fans sollen auch meine Nachrichten sehen. Und nicht nur 20%. Dann musst du Geld einwerfen. Ich muss Geld einwerfen. Genau, du musst Geld einwerfen, damit mehr Leute, die dir eh folgen, dich sehen können.
Damit sie mich sehen.
Ja, genau, weil sie kriegen irgendwie nicht alle deine, wenn du eine Meter ebenden Seite...
Naja, sie kriegen es nicht gleich. Also ich glaube, sie kriegen es dann schon alle auch so.
Also wenn ich verstanden habe, war es irgendwie, dass eben, wenn Tim jetzt auf einer Meter ebenden Seite seine Podcast veröffentlichen würde, dass nicht alle Leute ihre Meter ebenden Seite voll dem Kram sehen.
Das kriegen schon alle, aber nicht alle jetzt sofort. Das tropfelt dann so durch. Und wenn du jetzt so den immediate impact willst, dann musst du ein paar Münzen einwerfen.
Das ist aber übrigens genau das Ding bei Facebook. Also es ist mir noch nie ersichtlich gewesen, von irgendetwas, welchen Weg es nimmt. Ich meine, bei Twitter ist das irgendwie sehr klar und einfach zu verstehen.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute benutzen das halt einfach zum Chatten auch. Das sind halt einfach alle ihre Freunde.
Nee, klar, zum Chatten. Und die tauschen da alle mögliche Fotos auf, Party-Einlagen.
Und Events aufmachen.
Und schon praktisch.
Also, dann gibt es noch diese Spiele und so.
Es ist eigentlich eine Schande, dass das offene Internet es nicht geschafft hat, da irgendwie halbwegs stabile Standards durchzusetzen, um einfach mal ähnliche Dinge zu machen. Also allein, dass wir uns auf einen Termin einigen oder ich kündige dir mal einen an. Was das für ein technischer Aufwand ist, wenn du das zuverlässig tun willst, mit E-Mail und Kalenderstandards und so weiter. Das geht nicht. Das ist auch einfach nur eine E-Mail zu verschicken, oder nur eine E-Mail, die irgendwie einen definierten Look und ein definiertes Ankommen und Ankommensbestätigung und all diesen ganzen Scheiß hat. Das ist einfach nicht vorgesehen. Du bewegst dich immer im Intranet.
Oder einen Instant-Messaging-Service, den genug deiner Freunde benutzen und der dann auch noch Gruppenchat kann.
Und vor allen Dingen der performt. Der Facebook-Chat ist schon extrem performant. Auch wenn du da einen verschiedensten System, deine Tabs offen hat, das ist sofort da, sofort synchronisiert, kannst du zwischen den Devices wechseln. Technisch gesehen, auch wenn das alles auf PHP und MySQL läuft. Der Chat nicht in Erlang, aber trotzdem so ihr großes Cluster und so. Sie haben ja auch eine wahnsinnige Infrastruktur. Das haben die schon ganz cool im Griff.
Facebook ist eigentlich das Intranet des Internets.
Ja, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut. Du hast ja auch so Gruppen, wo du dann wirklich auch geschlossene Benutzergruppen haben kannst.
Hat das einzige, wofür ich Facebook benutze, eine Gruppe.
Ich glaube, dass das wirklich auch das Gefühl ist, was sich bei den Leuten langsam einstellt, dass wenn sie Facebook verlassen, dass sie das Intranet verlassen, nach draußen gehen müssen. So, als ob du im Hemd im Flur stehst, draußen regnet es und du musst dann halt den Bus kriegen.
Du trittst aus der Mall raus.
Du fühlst dich aus der Mall aus.
Das Neon-Licht flackert nicht mehr, draußen ist Wetter.
Du weißt nicht, wo der nächste Apple Store ist.
Du weißt nicht mehr, wo du dein Geld ausgeben kannst.
Raus aus der Mall.
Raus aus der Mall. Raus aus der Mall.
Ich meine, ähnlich wie Skype, wenn du bestimmte Kommunikationsprobleme löst, schafft das Facebook schon auch einen gewissen Teil. Also, was du sagst, hier Events, Chat.
Kommen wir noch mal kurz zurück zu Facebook Home. Sie haben hier einen Launcher und dieses komische Schnubbel-Interface.
Es ist hier gerade... Irgendwie ging es hier so einmal so quer links, rechts, links, rechts.
Ich habe nur mal einen Echo davon gehört. Das tut mir leid. Ich weiß nicht genau, was da los ist.
Vielleicht habe ich einen Kabel...
Worauf wollte ich hinaus? Facebook, bla, bla, bla. Home. So, jetzt, was macht Facebook konkret? Es gibt irgendwie so ein Telefon von HTC, wo sie das quasi mit ausliefern. Ich glaube nicht, dass dieses Telefon jetzt als solches das Allerwichtigste dieser ganzen Strategie ist, aber es ist auch schon mal interessant, dass jetzt diese ganzen anderen Android-Hersteller, die überhaupt gar kein Geld mehr verdienen, jetzt quasi sich Richtung Facebook strecken, um dann wiederum ein besonderes Merkmal für ihr Telefon zu machen. Auch wenn es theoretisch etwas ist, was auf jedem anderen Telefon genauso repliziert werden kann. Aber sonst noch mal mit dem Default.
Nein, irgendwas war, dass Facebook quasi die Zugriff auf die Hardware braucht, damit sie irgendwelche Rechte zusätzlich bekommen, die sie bei einem normalen Android-Gerät nicht haben.
Klar, hätte ich auch gesagt.
Deswegen brauchen sie irgendwie gleichzeitig diesen Partner, damit sie irgendwie mehr Facebook Home machen können als bei anderen Android-Telefonen.
Einer im Chat trifft es eigentlich ganz gut gerade. Facebook ist das neue AOL.
Jaja, ist es.
So ist das eigentlich. Trifft es wirklich ganz gut.
Jaja, das ist richtig.
Das heißt, wir werden demnächst alle Facebook-CDs in den Riff geben.
Ja, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau. Ich habe das so gehört, dass eben die normale App, die du auch über den App Store dann beziehen kannst, dass wenn du die installierst, dass es sich dann auch schon die notwendigen Privilegien gibt. Ob es da jetzt nochmal irgendwelche Hooks gibt in dieser HTC-Variante, die noch irgendeinen anderen Punk ermöglichen, das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Das ist auch nicht ganz so wichtig. Die eigentliche Frage, die ja im Raum steht, ist, zwei Fragen stehen für mich im Raum. Erstens, ist das jetzt sozusagen nur so ein Versuch, etwas mehr Visibility zu machen oder ist Facebook dabei, quasi auch so eine Art OS zu bauen? Ja, ähnlich schon wie bei Samsung. Also ein bisschen so der Herrscher über das UI zu sein. Das hat ja auch Samsung schon immer probiert.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du es schaffst, eine Plattform zu etablieren, dann hast du gewonnen. Und deswegen ist jeder, der die Chance hat, eine Plattform zu bauen, sollte es auch tun. Weil dann bist du derjenige, der die Leute zu dir kommen lässt und nicht derjenige, der zu anderen gehen muss. Und deswegen wird Facebook natürlich, also Facebook ist ja jetzt schon eine Plattform. Also hier Spiele und so. Und deswegen haben sie natürlichen Interesse daran, als Plattform auf den Geräten zu sein und nicht als App. Also damit ist deine Frage auch beantwortet.
Ja gut, dass sie ein Interesse daran haben, das ist natürlich außer Zweifel. Die Frage ist, verfolgen sie jetzt auch konkret eine Strategie im Sinne von, wir nehmen jetzt auch Android oder irgendein anderes zugrunde liegendes OS und bauen da drauf auch tatsächlich was auf. Versuchen wir sozusagen jenseits von iOS und Android API noch mal was anderes?
Ich finde es naheliegend. Ich meine, selbst Amazon hat das gemacht, nur damit du ein paar Bücher angucken kannst.
Ich würde mal sagen, dass Facebook das gar nicht braucht, sondern dass es reicht, dass sie da als dieser Launcher drauf sind.
Es gibt ein paar Milliarden Leute, denen reicht es noch aus.
Auch später. Facebook hat ja doch, oh Gott, das war auch ein Podcast, in dem ich das gehört habe. Ich weiß jetzt aber nicht mehr, in welchem das war, dass Facebook ja schon immer irgendwelche anderen Technologien genommen hat. Facebook hat das Web genommen und hat da drin sein Ding aufgezogen. Sie haben da drin ihre Spiele aufgezogen. Sie brauchen jetzt nicht ihr eigenes OS unbedingt, sondern sie nehmen das, was schon da ist und packen sich dann rein.
Ja, aber sie werden Anbieter dieser Plattform. Also Facebook will nicht auf Android sein. Sondern Facebook will auf dem Telefon sein und du kannst Android-Apps installieren. Das wird passieren und das werden sie wollen.
Das hast du doch, wenn ich das richtig sehe, hast du das ja bei Facebook. Es gibt doch viele User, die sind voll auf dem Trip, was Facebook nicht hat, brauche ich nicht. Das vertritt vielleicht Facebook auch.
Und es gibt ja schon Apps, die Facebook für ihren ganzen Kram, für ihre Spiele, wie heißt es, die Ranglisten und so was, die Highscore-Listen und so was über Facebook Connect machen und den ganzen Kram. Sie sind ja schon in den Android-Apps drin. Sie sehen, dein Android-Telefon sieht jetzt auch noch mit Facebook Home nach Facebook aus. Warum sollen sie jetzt anfangen, irgendwie wie Amazon, irgendwie Android zu forken, wenn es reicht, wenn sie den Launcher draufpacken? Werbung können sie ja auch reinschleusen.
Ein Wort, User-Login. Wenn Facebook für irgendetwas steht, dann ist es User-Login. Es ist ganz einfach, Inhalte nach Facebook reinzukriegen. Es ist ganz schwer, Inhalte aus Facebook rauszukriegen. Wenn du die Leute auf dem Telefon auch in Facebook einsperren kannst...
Den User-Login haben sie über einen Social Graph. Den brauchen sie auch gar nicht. Den machen sie nicht über die Technologie, sondern über die Leute.
Ja, aber wenn sie den Leuten erstmal ein Telefon untergeschoben haben, dann hat sich auch Twitter mehr oder weniger erübrigt. Dann sind sie nur noch bei Facebook.
Das mit dem Login ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil derzeit ist es ja, wenn du ein Android-Telefon hast, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du da früher oder später und wahrscheinlich sogar auch als erstes ein Google-Account-Login vornimmst, sehr hoch. Angenommen, sie können das Telefon so umdrehen, dass du ein Facebook-Login machst, bevor du ein Google-Login machst, dann haben sie schon mal gewonnen. Das ist auch die zweite Frage. Wie reagiert Google?
Also Eric Schmidt hat gesagt, es ist okay, dass es gemacht ist. Sie haben die Regeln gelesen, die haben sie genutzt.
Ja, und we've never been at war with East Asia. Der Eric Schmidt kann sagen, was er will. Das ist für mich vollkommen uninteressant.
Da werden die Telefon an die Wand geflogen.
Man schaut ja an, was die in letzter Zeit gemacht haben. Alles ist nur noch plus. Eigentlich möchten sie so etwas wie Facebook Home, wahrscheinlich wird nicht lange dauern. Und wir haben so etwas wie Facebook Home als Google, was ist Home in Google-Nerdsprache? Home, Google Seller. Wo du dann diese ganze Pluswelt dann irgendwie dich einloggst und dann eben auch deine ganzen Plus-Mumpets irgendwie so als Homescreen kriegst. Dann hast du auch nicht mehr die Apps, sondern du hast quasi deine Pluswelt als UI deines Telefons mit diesen ganzen, dann gibt es nicht mehr die App, mit der du Plus machst.
Ja, aber das benutzen deine Freunde nicht.
Naja, aber Google will, dass deine Freunde das deine nicht.
Ja, aber das...
Deine nicht.
Okay, ich kenne niemanden außer Ingress-Spielern, die Google Plus benutzen.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du nur Nerd kennst, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du mit denen über Plus kommunizierst einfach höher als über Facebook.
Ja, Google Plus ist jetzt nochmal so ein eigener Fail.
Na gut, aber das ist das Einzige, was Google an der Stelle hat. Und alle anderen Änderungen, auch das Einstellen von Google Reader, weist ja sozusagen darauf hin, dass ihre Strategie derzeit darauf basiert, alles in Richtung Plus zu verschieben. Es wirkt ein bisschen panisch. Ich frage mich nur, was ist mit dem nächsten Android-Release? Gibt es dann vielleicht irgendwie das Flag nicht mehr, ohne weiteres, um so eine abzuinstallieren? Apple ist da fein raus. Die sagen, auf so eine Idee, dass sich hier so was als Launcher installieren kann, wenn wir nie gekommen wären. Beziehungsweise wissen wir schon, dass die anderen drüber nachgedacht haben. Aber hier, ihr habt ja einen Arsch offen.
Das widerspricht doch mindestens der Hälfte der App Store-Rules.
Genau, sowas würden die gar nicht machen.
We are not with war at Facebook. Aber die können uns trotzdem nichts entwerfen.
Kommen wir zum Plattformkrieg hier. Da gibt es ja dann auch wieder bei unserem Lieblingsdienst Flatter neue Atombomben-Einschläge. Twitter auch.
Er ist jetzt ein Subfeature. Mal Ball flach halten. Ist zwar schade, aber ist jetzt ein Subfeature.
Aber irgendjemand.
Vielleicht sollt ihr erst mal erklären, worum es geht.
Also Flatter hat sich ja vor ein paar Wochen, es ist schon ein Monat her, ich weiß nicht, relauncht. Und nicht nur die Webseite optisch angepasst, sondern dieser ganzen Flatter-Experience auch einen neuen Default gegeben. Und der heißt, du flattersst primär über Social Networks, indem du halt diese Favoritenfunktion benutzt. Das heißt, Pfaffs bei Twitter, Sternchen bei ADN. Interessanterweise sprechen sie auch von Likes, aber der Facebook-Like-Button gehört gar nicht dazu. Aber halt so all diese Pfaffs und Sternchen, Instagram etc., all diese Dienste, wo man irgendwie Dinge toll finden kann, da gibt es dann die Möglichkeit bei Flatter, sich direkt in seinem Account, in diese Account einzuloggen und zu sagen, liess mal für mich hier die Sternchen aus, die ich da vergeben habe und Flatter das, wenn du es flattern kannst. Und dadurch, dass du dann eben eine relativ gute Zuordnung dieser Items, die da gestern wurden, zu Leuten machen kannst, wenn die wiederum in Flatter auch ihren Account damit assoziieren, funktioniert das an sich technisch recht gut.
Und das, habe ich den Eindruck, ist bei mir in den letzten Wochen so zwei, dreimal passiert, dass irgendjemand so schon sehr viele Tweets von mir gefavet hat und dann einmal dieses Feature angemacht hat und dann hatte ich da so 36 Mails auf einen Schlag so BAM, you've been flattered. Wo du dann natürlich weißt, okay, das wird jetzt vielleicht zwei Cent pro Flatter am Ende sein, aber war dann erstmal Schockwelle.
Du meinst, die Mail war teurer.
Ja, wahrscheinlich war die Mail sogar teurer. Oder die Mails waren ja dann 36 und das ist dann so zwei, dreimal passiert. Also scheinbar hat da irgendjemand noch schon auf netzem Drücker sozusagen nochmal alles rausgeflattert, was gefavt wurde.
Genau, das Problem bei diesen Sternchen auch meistens ist, dass sie ja kein Datum haben, wann es getan wurde. Das heißt, sie können dann eben nur irgendwann mal anfangen und ziehen sich irgendwie alles rein und im ersten Monat wird dann irgendwie viel weggehauen und danach ist es nur noch das Diff. Ja, so, jetzt hat Twitter da aber irgendwie von gehört, dass das getan wird und ihre Lawyer haben sich das irgendwie angeschaut oder vielleicht auch ihre Geschäftsführung oder beide.
Ihre gelangweilten Lawyer.
Genau und haben sich das angeschaut und haben da irgendwie in ihre App Store Rules reingeschaut und gesagt so, ja, also nee, ach nö, lass mal. Ihr monetarisiert ja hier den Content, der ist ja unser. Interessante Geschichte jetzt hier. Du bist sozusagen bei Twitter. Twitter ist da was, aber der Content gehört halt zumindest so weit Twitter, dass sie dir untersagen können oder in dem Moment demjenigen, der begünstigt wird, dass du damit Geld verdienst oder beziehungsweise, dass du da Geld über den Umweg des Auslesens dieser Information monetarisieren kannst. Geld monetarisieren, jetzt rede ich hier mit weißen Schimmeln. Twitter hat auf jeden Fall Position bezogen gegenüber Flatter und einfach gesagt, dass was ihr da macht, passt uns nicht in den Kram, lasst das bleiben. Und seit vorgestern lassen sie es auch bleiben.
Aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen übrigens. Also an sich finde ich ganz toll, was ihr da macht, aber aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen geht das leider nicht.
Das ist einfach richtig schwierig. Die Videotechnik funktioniert nicht, deswegen geht das nicht. Na ja, ist natürlich jetzt, wie du schon so schön sagtest, das ist ja nur so ein Nebenfeature. Kann man so sehen, dass das nur so ein Nebenfeature ist. Tatsächlich ist es aber die Basis ihrer neuen Strategie. Damit gehen sie nach draußen, dass das möglich ist. Und natürlich ist Twitter einer der wichtigsten, wenn nicht sogar der wichtigste Dienst in dieser Liste der Dienste. Weil Facebook ist nicht dabei. Twitter ist das nächstgrößere Netzwerk. Klar, sie haben auch noch Instagram etc. Aber das ist natürlich was ganz anderes.
Das ist ja auch zu Facebook.
Das Signal ist halt schwierig. Was ich ganz pfiffig finde, ist, dass sie das so getimt haben, dass zum Zeitpunkt der Ankündigung das Twitter eingestellt wird, dass sie wiederum die Erweiterung, das Twitter-Feature eingestellt wird, dass sie dann eben auch gleichzeitig bekannt gegeben haben, dass sie das jetzt auch für YouTube machen. Das heißt, du kannst jetzt quasi auch YouTube-Videos flattern. Über zählt zu meinen Favoriten. Was übrigens technisch wohl eine ziemliche Herausforderung war, weil es so schwierig ist, beim YouTube-Video so eine kanonische URL festzustellen. Weil es ja alle möglichen URLs gibt mit Banzalata dahinter etc. Ja, so. Und das ist halt so das Ding. Und ich frage mich jetzt in zunehmendem Maße, ob Flatter eigentlich überhaupt eine Chance hat, diese Trutzburgen da einzurennen und sich so parasitär an den Rest des Internets noch dran zu hängen, dass ihr Modell auch irgendwann mal aufgeht. Weil bisher hatten sie sich ja vor allem auf das freie Web konzentriert. Da haben sie den Vorteil, dass es keine Einschränkungen gibt. Aber da haben sie auch den Nachteil, dass sie nicht alles flättern kann, sondern nur das, was eben auch explizit zum Flättern freigegeben ist, so dieses alte Hähnenei-Problem mit dem entsprechenden Aufwand, den man dann treiben muss. Buttons erkennen, klicken, etc. Keine Automatismen möglich, etc. Ja, möglich war es bei...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, sie haben das, aber da verstehe ich es wieder nicht. Da haben sie es ja jetzt sogar schwerer gemacht, manuell, weil dieses manuelle Button-Herstellen so schwer geworden ist mit der neuen Oberfläche.
Ist es?
Manuell einen Button zu erstellen, da suche ich mir jedes Mal einen Wolf. Mit der Begründung, irgendwo steht es, in irgendeinem Foren, Eintrag oder so, haben sie geschrieben, naja, wir wollen halt, dass ihr Plugins oder was auch immer benutzt, dass es automatisch läuft. Und dass ihr nicht manuell... Was auch immer, aber Fletter selber sagt, wir wollen, dass ihr automatisch eure Buttons erstellt, nicht manuell. Und deswegen machen wir es euch jetzt schwer, manuell Buttons zu erstellen.
Na ja, okay, gut. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das jetzt wirklich so das Kernproblem ist.
Kannst du ganz kurz meinen Kopfhörer noch ein kleines bisschen leiser machen?
Ja, du kannst deinen Kopfhörer auch selber ein kleines bisschen leiser machen. Du bist ein bisschen weiter weg von dem Panel. Naja, ich muss nur noch mal ein drittes iPad herstellen.
Wir wollen endlich die Mac-Version von dieser Software hier haben.
Ja, will ich auch.
Tja, das Flatter ist ein bisschen... Also ich finde das ja eigentlich ganz toll. Und freue mich ja auch über die mannigfaltige Flatterung. Auch wenn immer so Freunde, die jetzt auch mal so einen Flatter-Button irgendwo einbauen und dann so sagen, ja, letzten Monat 87 Cent. Also das kommt dann natürlich nicht so überzeugend für die jeweiligen Personen rüber. Also es ist nicht so, dass wenn man... Also gut, wenn du jetzt hier bei dir auf Chaos Radio oder Mobile Max guckst und dann siehst du 15.000 Flatterklicks, dann ist ja, oh, das funktioniert.
Die Sterne bei up.net haben ja gut angezogen. Die haben einen Flattermach... Also einen Zehner erhöht, was die Verwöchlung ist.
Aber für so Leute, die jetzt noch nicht so ganz gut vernetzt sind und jetzt denken, okay, ich habe jetzt hier so einen Block und ich mache mal so einen Flatter-Button rauf und dann sehen sie halt, krass, einen Flatterklick und so. Also man merkt schon die Grenze zwischen digitaler Avantgarde und den Facebook-User. Die ist dann schon relativ deutlich auch. Also dass dann irgendwie das halt in der breiten Masse einfach noch nicht angekommen ist. Und ich fürchte ja nach den ganzen Jahren auch irgendwie jetzt nicht mehr ankommen wird, so schade das eigentlich auch ist.
Flatter separiert die Blog-Sphäre in Arm und Reich.
Nee, also weiß nicht, hier die ganzen Netzaffinen-Leute, alle die so Podcasts hören, bloggen und sowieso schon mehr als 10 Follower auf Twitter haben und ganz aktiv im Netz sind, für die funktioniert das super, für alle anderen halt noch nicht.
Aber ist das jetzt Flatters?
Nee, es ist keine, also ich mache jetzt gar keine Schuld zu, es ist nur eine Feststellung.
Darauf wollte ich nämlich auch hinaus, weil ich glaube, es wäre kein Problem alles für Flatter, wenn sie sich beliebig integrieren könnten. Aber Instacast-Refusal im App-Store, das Ding, ich meine, dieses Feature war in Instacast drin und es hat irgendwie einen Monat gedauert und Instacast allein hat für die meisten Flatterklicks gesorgt. Das hat sozusagen explodiert, ist dann von Apple gleich wieder eingesammelt worden. Jetzt irgendwie dieses Feature, keine Ahnung, wie erfolgreich das war mit den Tweets, so, aber auch das, diese Automatisierung des Bezahlens, das ist ja genau das, was du beklagst, dass es eben noch nicht überangekommen ist, weil man den ganzen Aufwand nicht haben will. Natürlich will man den nicht haben. Und genau das ist das Problem. Das eigentliche Problem ist aber nicht Flatter, sozusagen, also für Flatter ist das ein Problem und damit auch für alle, die davon profitieren.
Ich habe nur einen Einspruch dazu.
Ja, sondern das Problem, mit dem wir jetzt in zunehmendem Maße zu tun haben, ist halt Api-Policy. Diese ganzen Walled Gardens, die einfach sagen, hier kommt keiner rein.
Also ich würde ja nochmal sagen, das ist ein strategischer Fehler, weil ganz am Anfang auf Euro zu setzen und nicht gleich den Dollar mit rein zu holen. Ich habe so viele Leute auch schon geschrieben hier, von irgendwelchen amerikanischen Services. Wir wollten nicht mal Flatterbutton. Ja, haben wir uns angeguckt, aber es ist alles in Euro. Das kommt hier bei den Usern nicht an. Machen wir nicht. Und ich glaube, da haben sie schon ganz am Anfang ganz viel so verspielt. Weil viele Leute haben sich das angeguckt und dann so, hier überall Eurosymbole und es ist irgendwie so ein Euro-Ding und hat schon mal sozusagen ein paar User oder Early Adopter verbrannt einfach.
Na ja, 5x5 hat ja auch ein paar Mal was. Also Benjamin hat ja auch irgendwie mal in einem 1-2 Podcast drüber geredet und das war dann jedes Mal so ein ja, das ist auch so ein Service und da klickt doch eh niemand. Und da hatte ich mehr so das Gefühl, na ja, über Werbung kommt halt Geld rein und wir glauben nicht dran, dass irgendwer da Geld einwirft, sondern die Leute wollen kostenlos und Werbung.
Aber da, was schon richtig ist, ist American Spy American. Das ist schon ein Faktor. Also ich glaube, wir haben das schon mit dem Euro-Symbol, aber jetzt, ja gut. Das Problem ist aber anders. Du hast eh, wenn du irgendwo in den nordamerikanischen Markt gehst, hast du wahnsinnige Markteintrittsschwellen. Ich kann dir mal ganz kurz eine Anekdote beisteuern. Als ich vor vielen, vielen Jahren mal eine kleine Firma gegründet habe, haben wir uns dann auch so eine Firmenversicherung besorgt und da kam dann so ein Versicherungsvertreter und dann hat uns dann gefragt, was wir denn so machen und so und dann war eines seiner Fragen, ob wir denn auch in den USA tätig werden und ich so, nee, ist nicht unser Markt und blööö und so. Sagt er, das ist auch gut, weil sonst wäre ich ziemlich aufgestanden und gegangen. Ich so, wat, nee, dann hätte ich ihn meinen Kollegen vorbeischickt von unserer Filiale auf den niederländischen Antillen oder sonst und wat, aber wir versichern keine Firmen, die in den USA tätig sind. Wegen Produkthaftung, tralala, pipapo.
Aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen.
Aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen, ist kein Witz.
Aber, dein Mikro sitzt irgendwie da halb auf der Augenbraue, die Leute beklagen sich schon.
Macht auch Phonik hinterher. Das wird ja gut. Aber, der Marktentritt für so ein kleines Unternehmen und Flatter ist ja in Uvassa da schon mal. Besitzen die in Göteborg oder so? Wie viele People sind denn da so bei Flatter? Malmö.
Das ist so ein Team. Also, last time I checked, als ich da war, war das ungefähr so eine Truppe von 15 bis 20 Leuten. Ich glaube, in der Größenordnung ist es immer noch so. Die haben dann so eine offizielle Niederlassung noch in einer Briefkastenfirma in Britannien. Wegen dieser Money-Agent.
Aber du kannst, wie gesagt, als 15-Mann-Firma kannst du einfach nicht gegen die legal Barriere dort in den USA ankämpfen.
Aber ich glaube halt auch trotzdem, dass sie jetzt halt einfach, also so bei uns hier in der Firma, da diese Facebook-Spielefirma, wo ich so bin, die mit dem Gigabit-Anschluss, die mit dem Gigabit-Anschluss, da ist so eine Regel halt, wenn du was launchst, und das ist noch nicht richtig fertig, oder das ist nur so halb gar, und du setzt das jetzt schon mal so in einer ganz großen Menge vor, und die klicken das einmal an, findest doof, die kommen nie wieder, die hast du ja sozusagen verbrannt. Deswegen, wenn du was launchst, dann mach es erstmal so vielleicht in einem kleinen Land ganz still und leise, bis es relativ rund ist, und dann einmal groß raus. Und ich glaube, viele Leute haben sich zum Beispiel Flatter schon angeguckt, weil es gibt es jetzt schon eine ganze Weile, und eben die ganzen Amis haben dann gesagt, ja, alles Euro, find ich doof, und damit hast du die jetzt auch schon eigentlich alle... Es hat jetzt schon mal so ein Stempel sozusagen, bis die jetzt... Also ich glaube, für mich zumindest gefühlt, weil ich ja eben schon echt ein paar Leute aktiv angeschrieben habe, auch hier zum Beispiel den Oatmeal-Typ, mit dem habe ich so eine kleine E-Mail-Kommunikation dazu gehabt, ich habe auch schon mit den Gitableuten mal geschnackt, und das war überall immer so das gleiche, immer das gleiche Argument.
Das Problem mit den Amerikanern ist, glaube ich, auch noch ein anderes. Flatter ist halt ein Modell, was sagt, gebt freiwillig Geld, ohne etwas dafür zu bekommen, was ihr nicht schon habt. So, da gibt es einen Ford in Amerika dafür, das heißt Socialism. Und das ist denen einfach generell suspekt. Man bezeichnet sich gar nicht mal als Witz.
Bezeichnet sich die Leute von Flatter nicht sogar selber als Sozialisten?
Ja, als sozialistisches veganes Unternehmen.
Ja, das ist für die USA ja so. Das ist doch das Ding, was immer Obama vorgeworfen wurde.
Weißt du ja, die kommen ja aus dieser Stinkefinger-Fraktion mit irgendwie Herrn Sunde und so weiter. Uns auch egal, was die Amerikaner denken. Ich glaube auch nicht unbedingt, dass es jetzt die USA unbedingt bräuchte. Das wäre sicherlich kein Fehler gewesen.
Definitiv.
Aber es hätte im Prinzip auch hier schon ziehen können. Es hätte ja auch gezogen.
Aber das Ding ist halt auch...
Diese Apple-Ablehnung von Instacast ist ein viel, viel, viel größeres Problem. Viel, viel, viel größeres Problem.
Aber zum Beispiel diese ganzen globalen Internet-Geldverdien-Markts-Lage ist Amerika einfach auch einer der größten Märkte, sozusagen.
Aber du kannst auch ohne die USA erstmal bekannt werden.
Das stimmt. Aber du willst die USA definitiv mit dabei haben?
Ja, natürlich willst du die. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt jeder in den USA sagt, dass das stinkt.
Das sind dann auch die Leute, die in ihrer Mailsignatur reinschreiben, dass die im Walled-Chen wohnen, statt im Wäldchen.
Also ich denke, das ist jetzt auch klar, was hier das Problem ist. Die Leute, die vielleicht nach wie vor mögen, können das jetzt auch für YouTube aktivieren. Das könnt ihr ja mal machen. Ich habe das gemacht. Und außerdem muss man halt mal schauen. Ich frage mich natürlich auch, jetzt kommen wir im Prinzip auch zu unserem ADN-Eckchen, glaube ich, ob denn außer Flatter noch irgendjemand dieses Micro-Payment-System irgendwann mal zur Anwendung bringen wird, weil ich glaube grundsätzlich ist das nämlich schon eine gute Sache.
Definitiv, das frage ich mich eigentlich auch.
Die schwache Position von Flatter ist halt das Problem. Weil Flatter nicht Facebook ist.
Aber du hast ja gerade gesagt, das Grundprinzip ist Socialism, das wird ja auch appelliert. Ah, da ist dann ein Eurozeichen drauf und dieses Grundprinzip.
Aber in Zeiten von Kickstarter, wo dir irgendwie 10 Dollar überweist und dann dein Name auf einer Webseite steht als Dankeschön, da bist du auch echt nicht weit weg von, ich gebe einfach mal Geld für die Sache TM.
Cloudfunding ist einfach eine Frage. Micropayment ist sowieso einfach der Türöffner für viele Anwendungen, die es heute noch nicht gibt. Jetzt nennt man das halt noch Subscription Pricing. Und macht das freiwillig und redet von kleinen Beträgen, dann hast du im Prinzip dasselbe Ding. Also die Übergänge sind da sehr flüssig. Ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt das Flatter-Modell diametral allem gegenüber steht, was so im Internet zu finden ist, was mit Geld zu tun hat. Es ist nur so, dass es sich eben sehr von dem Kauf-Mich- oder-dass-das-bleiben-Modell sich stark unterscheidet. Aber all das, was jetzt in anderer Form dazwischen wächst, das weist schon viele Ähnlichkeiten auf. Und wenn du eine stärkere Plattform hast, die eben auch dieses Problem nicht hat, dass du darfst hier nicht rein und darfst hier nicht mitspielen, die aber in der Lage ist, sowas besser zu automatisieren, kann das sehr wohl funktionieren. Und ich könnte mir das zum Beispiel vorstellen bei Abdotnet, die ja nun auch klar gesagt haben, dass sie überhaupt schon mal demnächst auch in diese ganze Geldbezahlerei mit reingehen wollen und auch eine Vielzahl von Bezahlmodellen unterstützen wollen, auch wenn jetzt von Micropec mit selber noch nicht so die Rede ist.
Aber Abdotnet ist ja auch eher so ein europäisches Phänomen, das habe ich letztens gelesen. Ich glaube, das ist ein zentriertes Problem. Ja, das habe ich nur irgendwo. Warst du auf Abdotnet, dass irgendjemand meinte, dass auf der Global Timeline...
Ja, morgens wird es immer sehr deutsch.
Ja, das meinen auch schon die anderen. Aber das ist klar, das ist ein bisschen wie mit Flatter auch. Deutschland ist gar nicht so schlecht. Es gibt schon irgendwie so Sachen, wo hier Dinge verstanden werden, bevor jetzt Franzosen oder so das machen. Ansonsten, die Briten sieht man nicht so.
Wenn das Netz noch an ist und nicht gedrosselt.
Ja, es gibt da auch Briten, die fallen bloß nicht so auf.
Da sind sogar eine ganze Reihe Briten mit bei.
Ja, ja, also das ist jetzt nicht so...
Sehen wir die auch noch zu Hause?
Ja, Abdotnet, das ist übrigens auch ein Grund, warum ich Niels eingeladen habe, weil, wie schon angedeutet, Niels ja sehr da aktiv ist, nicht nur weil er jetzt irgendwie...
Die japanische Seite des Abdotnet.
Nee, es gibt auch Japaner auf Abdotnet.
Ja, es gibt auch Japaner, das stimmt. Aber das ist jetzt nicht der Grund, warum du dem da gejoint bist. Ich glaube, uns ging es beiden eigentlich gleich am Anfang. Wir haben da einfach was gesehen. Oder?
Ja, ich dachte mir, also ich war ja schon lange der Meinung, wenn, ich glaube ähnlich wie du, so wenn ich Geld einwerfen könnte in Twitter, würde ich in Twitter Geld einwerfen, damit ich das Ding in Werbe frei habe und naja, damit der Dienst halt bestehen bleibt. Ich mag irgendwie so Geschäftsmodelle, die ich verstehe. Und Geld einwerfen ist so ein Geschäftsmodell, da ich verstehe.
Aber Niels, das ist doch elitär. Was ich da deutlich auf Twitter wieder verantworten bekommen habe. Unglaublich. Das muss ich gleich mal raussuchen. Das war wirklich unfassbar.
Öffentliches, wie sagt man, Bloßstellen von Twitter-Kommentaren.
Man muss ja keine Nutzer dazu nennen. Ach so. Ich dachte mir einfach nur, ich finde das Modell gut. Und deswegen interessiert es mich. Und ja, habe mir das dann angeguckt und habe Global gelesen, habe Leute gefunden. Das ist übrigens eine Empfehlung, die ich grundsätzlich aussprechen kann, wenn ihr neu auf abde.net seid. Versucht nicht, die Leute von Twitter auf eure Abde.net-Leute zu mappen, sondern lest global und springt in Konversationen. Weil da findet man nur dann die interessanten Leute wieder.
Das finde ich auch so interessant, dass viele sagen so, ja, auf abde.net und so, da sind meine Freunde nicht. Kann ich ja verstehen. Aber in gewisser Hinsicht denke ich mir auch mittlerweile so...
Der Trend geht zu neuen Freunden.
Ja, bei Twitter waren meine Freunde damals auch nicht. Das war mal ein schöner Spruch. Bei Facebook sind die Freunde, mit denen man nichts mehr zu tun haben will. Und auf Twitter sind die Leute, mit denen man gerne befreundet wäre. Also, weil auf Facebook habe ich irgendwie so alte Schulkameraden und so. Und da gibt es einen Grund, warum ich irgendwie mit denen keinen Kontakt mehr habe.
Auf Twitter...
Die Schule ist vorbei.
Genau, auf Twitter habe ich irgendwie coole Leute kennengelernt, die ich nie kennengelernt hätte.
Facebook ist für die Leute, mit denen man auf der Schule war. Und Twitter ist für die Leute, mit denen man gerne auf der Schule gewesen wäre.
Ja, mittlerweile ist es aber anders. Jetzt sind die Leute, mit denen du gerne kennen möchtest, die sind jetzt irgendwie bei Abtwort nett. Und auf Twitter sind nur noch Piraten.
Ach ja, nicht nur, aber genug. Zu viele, ja, genau.
Und irgendwie spürt es einem immer die Timeline.
Obwohl, seitdem ich nur noch 21 Leuten folge, ist in meiner Twitter-Timeline auch nichts mehr los.
Also ich habe die ganzen Piraten jetzt auch mehr oder weniger entfolgt. Und seitdem ist es eigentlich ganz ruhig.
Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber wenn ich die da jetzt auch noch entfolge, dann... Also dann... weiß ich nicht. Weil es mir mal interessiert, was gerade los ist. Also ich finde das jetzt ganz schön, Twitter so als Thermometer, so als Gesellschaftsthermometer einzuschalten, um mal so kurz zu gucken, wie die Temperatur ist. Regen sie sich gerade wieder alle über irgendwas auf oder nicht? Und dann...
Ich habe so eine Liste, die nennt sich apps in Twitter, weil so viele Softwareentwickler auf Twitter ihre Accounts haben, wo sie irgendwie Werbung machen und Informationen über Updates und so raushauen. Da schaue ich einmal am Tag rein. Dafür ist es ganz praktisch. Aber so für alles andere? Weiß nicht.
Übrigens eine kleine Zwischenansage. Also es wird ja jetzt warm, ne? Und so als Deutscher und speziell als Berliner ist man jetzt ja auch geneigt, sich schon über das zu warme Wetter zu beschweren, aber man muss jetzt noch zwei Wochen...
Die Tankstellenbedienung meinte zu mir, es wäre viel zu schnell warm geworden.
Es ist offiziell verkündet jetzt hiermit, dass es eine zwei Wochen Übergangszeit gibt, wo man sich nicht über das zu warme Wetter beschwert. Man verwirrt auch die ganzen Zugezogenen und Zugereisten aus anderen Herren Länder, die jetzt denken, okay, jetzt müsste doch jetzt hier jeder mit Freude strahlend ein Gesicht durch die Gegend springen. Also zwei Wochen gibt in diese Illusion, bevor dann wieder voll sich beschwert werden kann über die zu warme Außentemperatur, ja?
Ja, aber was macht der Berliner, wenn er sich nicht über das Wetter beschweren kann?
Ja, da gibt es genug andere Sachen.
Bleiben wir noch mal kurz bei up.net. Mir fiel auch gerade ein, ich habe ja noch Invites.
Hast du wieder so einen tollen Promolink?
Ja, ich habe schon wieder so einen tollen Promolink, den kriege ich mittlerweile auf Zuruf.
Aber bitte, bitte, bitte keine Promolinks mehr in den Kommentaren posten. Ich glaube, vorletzte Sendung, da waren die Kommentare einfach nur kaputt, weil da nur Promolinks drin waren.
Oh Gott, ich muss noch mal raus, es gibt eine Plattform, da kann man seine Promolinks quasi spenden und dann können Leute quasi dort sagen, ich hätte gerne einen Promolink und dann kriegt man daraus einen zugewiesen. Naja, die haben quasi gesagt, hier gib deine Promolinks ein, dann werden die in der Datenbank gespeichert. Und wenn jemand einen Link braucht, also nicht Promolinks, sondern halt Invite-Link, und wenn halt jemand einen Invite braucht, geht er halt auf die Webseite, sagt, bräuchte einen Invite, dann kriegst du halt aus der Datenbank per Zufall einen zugewiesen. Ja, dann folgst du per Zufall irgendeiner einzigen Person, der du wieder entfolgen kannst.
Ja, gut, nicht dass es schlimm ist.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht eh die wahnsinnige Inflation, warum machen sie jetzt nicht einfach die Floodgates aus, wenn es gut ist?
Weil sie sagen, dass sie es kontrollieren wollen. Dass sie das Wachstum kontrollieren wollen.
Das könnten sie auch so machen. Sie können jetzt ihre Tür aufmachen wie ein Floodgate und wenn ihnen zu viel Wasser den Damm runter geronnen kommt, machen sie die Tür wieder zu.
Deswegen gibt es ja die Invites.
Nein, aber sie können jetzt einfach sagen, wir machen jetzt auf, wer jetzt so einen Scheiß-Account haben will, soll sich einklicken und wenn es ihnen zu viel wird, machen sie die Tür wieder zu.
Nein, aber so machen sie die Tür so spaltweise auf.
Es hat mehrere Gründe, warum sie das so machen.
Erstens wollen sie wissen, wo die Leute herkommen.
Sie wollen wissen, wo die Leute herkommen. Sie wollen vor allem ganz bewusst das Netzwerk über andere Leute erweitern. Sie wollen jetzt nicht sagen, einfach jeder kann rein, sondern sie möchten gerne, dass vor allem Leute da reingehen, die wegen jemandem dort hingehen. Sie möchten explizit über Communities eröffnen, einfach weil die Experience eine ganz andere ist. Du kommst irgendwo hin. Wenn jetzt irgendjemand da so, ab dort net hier, freier Account, hab ich mal geklickt, hab da rumgeguckt, interessiert mich alles, nicht weggeworfen. Aber wenn du weißt, weil du das jetzt auf Mobile-Max gehört hast, oder weil Bits und so geschrien hat, oder weil dein Freund jetzt auch da ist, oder was auch immer, dann hast du da einen Grund.
Ich finde die Dinge inflationär.
Ja, zurzeit werden sie relativ viel rausgehauen, weil auch Leute...
Das ist schwierig, ich meine, wir haben jetzt 75.000 Accounts, das ist irgendwie in Internet-Dimension, das ist ein Schiss. Nein, das sind nicht alle meine Follower, ich habe nicht 75.000 Follower.
Noch nicht.
Ich werde auch nicht 100%...
Hast du zwischen Heugi überholt?
Ja, schon lange. Ich war schon immer vor Heugi.
Weil du irgendwann mal meinst, dass Heugi der beliebteste Deutscher ist, bei irgendeinem NSFW.
Achso, weil ich ja technisch gesehen kein Deutscher bin. Aber das kennt mittlerweile auch nicht mehr. Ich glaube, das iPhone-Blog hat mit seinem Invite, Herr Ulmer hat es sozusagen ausgereicht.
Hast du einen Invite für Deutschland gekriegt?
Mal gucken, ob mir Deutschland nochmal einen Invite gibt.
Übrigens, habt ihr in letzter Zeit mal einen Twitter-Account aufgemacht? Habt ihr in letzter Zeit mal einen Twitter-Account aufgemacht?
Nicht persönlich. Warum?
Da wirst du zwangsgefollowed irgendwelchen Leuten.
Ach so, wenn man einen neuen aufmacht?
Wenn du einen neuen aufmachst, dann sagst du, dass du aus einer Liste von Sachen aussuchen, wofür du dich interessierst, und dann bekommst du Follower übergeholfen, so ein Dutzend.
Follower, Leute, die mir folgen?
Followings, also Leuten, denen du folgst.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, schon mal irgendwo mal gesehen.
Ekel.
So richtig schmierige Celebrities, die dir da anklicken müssen.
Ja, genau, das ist ganz schlimm.
Und dann bist du plötzlich Fuller von Heidi Klum und so ein Scheiß.
Genau. Deswegen hier von wegen, du folgst dann einem.
Aber also hier für dieses tolle Internetprojekt, das ich da jetzt kürzlich gemacht habe, da wurde ja jetzt auch ein Twitter-Account angelegt. Und da folgen wir da doch keinem weiter. Also entweder er hat die gleich geputzt. Er hat schon geputzt oder das hat sich auch...
Niels, jetzt aber vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen anderer Gesichtspunkt. Du beschäftigst dich ja extrem auch mit Twitter. Du hast auch ein sehr... Entschuldigung, mit Abdotnet.
Das andere Twitter.
Du hast dich auch schon mal mit Twitter.
Das ist kein Twitter mit viel Geld.
Erzähl doch mal so ein bisschen aus deiner Perspektive, was gefällt dir eigentlich technisch am besten? Vielleicht erzählst du auch noch mal von deiner Client-Liste. Da hat sich ja auch einiges getan. Mich würde einfach mal so deine Perspektive interessieren, was so deiner Meinung nach so den Reiz ausmacht.
Ja, also was für mich an sich den Reiz ausmacht, ist halt, dass Konversationen scheinbar funktionieren oder bis jetzt weitaus besser funktionieren als auf Twitter. Diese 116 zusätzlichen Zeichen machen da irgendwie eine Menge aus. Dass man irgendwie mehr als nur einen abgebrochenen Satz hinschreiben kann und sich dadurch Konversationen nicht so aufsitzen. Also selbst vor kurzem, als es irgendwie eine Konversation gab, über was war das? Leute mit Kindern sind irgendwie arrogant gegenüber Leuten ohne Kinder. Also so ein total untechnisches Thema. Konnte halbwegs gesittet ablaufen, ohne dass ich da komplett gefetzt wurde. Und auch ansonsten sind irgendwie Themen, die halt nicht so hochgekocht gefühlt werden. Also hochgekocht im Sinne von, da geht einmal der Shitstorm drüber.
Das Beste ist auf dem sozialen Level. Der kann sich ja auch jederzeit ändern.
Ja, natürlich. Aber es scheint sich durch diese Mehrzeichen abgedämpft zu sein. Oder es sind einfach ruhigere Leute auf Abdotnet. Das kann natürlich auch sein. Dass moderatere Menschen aktuell eher auf Abdotnet sind als die Trolle.
Das verhalte ich für wahrscheinlicher.
Das kann natürlich sein. Das weiß man nicht. Was ich ansonsten recht gut finde technisch, sind halt diese Link-Entitäten. Also dass ich quasi so HTML-Steel-Links posten kann. Das fehlt mir inzwischen jedes Mal, wenn ich auf Twitter irgendwas poste, dass ich irgendwie nicht meinen Link direkt einbetten kann.
Wobei es für mich noch zu wenig Kleines gibt, die das auch unterstützen.
Ja Gott, also es gibt für mich, es gibt Sail auf Mac, der es unterstützt. Sail kann das, ja, mit Markdown, also entweder Command-K.
Ach, bei Sail kann ich Markdown machen?
Oder du kannst Command-K, dann kannst du den Link und den Link-Titel eingeben und dann fügst du das dir an Markdown ein. Happy auf dem iPhone kannst, mit Markdown. Felix kann das. Wie? Felix gibt so einen Plus-Knopf. Wo du Media kannst auch sagen, Add Link. Und dann fügt er dir einen Link ein. Oder wenn du einen Link einfügst, wird er so blau, kannst du Backspace machen auf den Link und dann fragt er dich, ob du einen Link-Text editieren willst. Und dann kannst du einen anderen Link-Text dann schreiben. Ja, genau. Markdown für Links. Das teste ich jetzt mal. Ansonsten, ich habe da auch so eine tolle Client-Liste unter bit.ly slash ADN-Clients und da gibt es auch diesen tollen Punkt in deinen Links.
Für manche ist es eine Liste, aber für die meisten ist es das größte Spreadsheet der Welt.
Ja, es ist ziemlich groß. Es hat jetzt jemand eine API dafür entwickelt, mit einer Suchmaschine.
Ich schick das mal hier mal kurz auf den Bildschirm. Ich habe ja hier mehrere Bildschirme nebeneinander. Das hat den Vorteil, dass es vielleicht sogar... Das passt nicht. Drei Bildschirme und das passt nicht.
Drei große Bildschirme.
Ich mache meine Schrift ein bisschen kleiner. Wie weit geht denn das hier noch?
Den gibt es nur im Mac App Store.
Was ist denn jetzt mal mit ein paar Features? Wenn wir schon eh bei Markdown sind, wann kann ich denn mal HTML in einen Tweet, in einen ADN-Tweet reinmachen? Vor allem einen Java-Skript und vor allen Dingen einen ActiveX-Control.
Das geht noch nicht. Das Ding ist ja, diese Link-Entität wird quasi angehängt. Das Markdown wird von den Clients nur benutzt, um diese Link-Entität zu erzeugen.
Klar, aber jetzt der erste Schritt. Wann kann ich denn jetzt noch mal was in Fett schreiben oder in Bund oder den Front wechseln?
In River z.B. interpretiert schon Markdown zwar nicht links, aber da kannst du in Fett schreiben. Der interpretiert Markdown für Fett.
Wie gesagt, Rich Text und als nächsten Schritt möchte ich deine Java-Skripte mit im Bett.
Kann man da auch Java-Applets mit schicken? Ohne animierte GIFs kann das sowieso nichts werden.
Ja, animierte GIFs gehen da schon lange ab.
Aber jetzt erzähl doch hier nochmal ein bisschen was über deine Liste.
Ja, aber es gibt ja nicht nur die Inline-Links, die schön sind. Das Ding ist ja, dass up.net mehr als nur quasi diese Mikro-Blogging-Plattform ist, die die meisten Leute sehen, sondern dass es ja so mehr Kram gibt. Also es gibt ja so diese Channels, die für private Messages auch verwendet werden. Und da gibt es da dieses tolle petterapp.net, was so ein bisschen an IRC erinnert oder an alte AOL-Chat-Räume. So vergleicht sie Dalton zumindest immer. Gegen IRC haben sie den Vorteil, dass die History halt immer mitgespeichert wird und man deswegen auch zurückscrollen kann, was da so, während ich nicht eingeloggt war, geschrieben wurde.
Da wird ja alles abgelegt, wird ja alles dauerhaft gespeichert.
Ja genau, wird halt als Nachricht gespeichert. Leider wird dann nicht mehr der Postcount erhöht, aber wer Wert drauf legt, sondern dadurch, dass es in einem Channel läuft, läuft das an diesem Postcount vorbei. Früher wurde das ja über diese Posts gemacht, die keinen Text hatten, sondern nur so maschinenlesbaren Text, wie es für Spiele verwendet werden kann. Es gibt ja irgendwie dieses Schach, was man darüber spielen kann, über up.net. Ja genau, über dieses machine-readable-only-blubber-di-blubber. Ich bin ja auch kein Entwickler, ich kenne nur die Up hier, weil ich irgendwie Feature-Request stellen will, um zu gucken, was die Leute so machen können. Was geht.
Ja, aber Annotations sind halt einfach so benannte Erweiterungen, wie so kleine JSON-Objekte, die man einfach mit an den Post mit dranhängt.
Genau, maximal 8000 Zeichen. Und es gibt auch longpost.com ist es, glaube ich. Da kann man dann überhaupt dort nicht bloggen. Da wird dann quasi über eine Annotation der Blogpost gemacht. Also der Titel kommt in den normalen Posttext rein, mit einem Link zu dem Blogpost. Und die fischen das dann aus der Annotation raus. Mit Markdown, genau.
Nur so nebenbei, auch IMAP kann Annotations. Aber geht auch.
Ja, siehst du, in Updeutnet benutzen die Leute Annotations. Dann gibt es ja noch diese tolle File-Up hier inzwischen, wo man dann irgendwie seine ganzen Sachen ablegen kann. Was auch ganz angenehm ist, weil man...
Wobei die aber sehr eingeschränkt ist. Also mehr als Ablage für Screenshots taucht das derzeit noch nicht so richtig.
Ja, und sie wollen ja irgendwie auch keine Folder machen. Das haben sie ja auch mehrfach jetzt in Podcasts gesagt, im offiziellen Abdotnet-Podcast. Und es gibt irgendwie große Diskussionen, wie man Folder emulieren kann. Irgendwie über Annotations und was weiß ich nicht. Aber so richtig schick wird das glaube ich nicht. Als Ablage für Screenshots oder für Clima, was so ein Weinclon ist. Die Länge für 11 Sekunden finde ich übrigens immer noch das lustigste. Wie war das? 140 durch 256 mal 6 Sekunden ist die Länge eines Clima-Videos. Sie haben sozusagen die Weinlänge......genommen und dann den UPDOT.NET-Postfaktor draufgerechnet. Deswegen ist ein Clima-Video F Sekunden lang.
Aber konsistent.
Das Schöne ist halt, man kann halt irgendeinen Client nehmen wie Orbit zum Ablegen von Dateien oder so. Oder Happy, der dann... Happy, weiß ich jetzt gar nicht, Chimp kann es auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, Happy kann es auch, dass man dann seine File-App nach Bildern durchsuchen kann. Es ist halt nicht irgendwie, der eine Client legt es bei Tweet-Pick ab und der andere bei Posts, als es das noch gab. Und der dritte Client macht es da und da. Sondern es legt halt alles, man kann halt alles bei UPDOTNET ablegen.
Ja, das ist schon cool, wenn ich alle meine bei Twitter veröffentlichten Fotos mal in meinem eigenen Storage hätte. Schön wär's.
Ja, und man kann den halt abrufen. Man kann den halt abrufen. Es gibt ja auch dieses filesup.net, was so ein Online-File-Manager ist. Oh Gott, Ed Ludolfus macht den. Der macht auch dieses konsolup.net, womit man die API testen kann. Ich weiß aber gar nicht, nee, der macht nicht diese API-Lite. Es gibt noch so eine API-Lite, womit man quasi mit der API rumspielen kann, damit man ohne einen Developer-Account sich selber Commandline-Skripte schreiben kann, damit man, keine Ahnung, sein Twitter in einen Blumentopf in ein Updott.net-Channel rein posten lassen kann und nicht auf Global, also damit man da nicht irgendwie einen Developer-Account braucht, um für solche Kleinigkeiten Kram zu machen oder mit seinen Nagios in ein Updott.net-Channel reinläuft.
Also, dass wir nicht zu sehr jetzt hier in ADN-Sprache verfallen. Ich wollte noch mal kurz hier auf deine kleinen Feature, Matrix, zurückgehen. Also, da gibt es jetzt eine API für, sagst du. Also, dieses Spreadsheet wird irgendwie irgendwie ausgelesen.
Oh Gott, da hat sich Atchemic herangesetzt und der liest diese Liste aus über Google. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob er die CVS nimmt, die es da gibt, die das Ding ausspuckt. Der liest sie irgendwie alle fünf Minuten ein und dann kann man über eine API drauf zugreifen und kann sie halt durchsuchen. Er hat auch so eine Suchmaschine für gebaut, so eine sehr rudimentäre. Und die kann das dann auch durchsuchen und dann kriegt man irgendwie Jason, glaube ich, zurück. Und die Idee ist eigentlich nur, dass man mal aus dem Spreadsheet irgendwas macht, was man ordentlich filtern kann, weil es ging zwar mal Filter bei diesem Spreadsheet, aber als dann einmal Vandalismus über das Spreadsheet betrieben wurde, habe ich halt den Zugang eingeschränkt. Also es wurde halt mal, ich habe halt irgendwann mal gesagt, hier, ich habe irgendwie 90% aller iOS-Clients habe ich. Jetzt mache ich einfach mal eine Liste, die die Features, die wichtigsten abdeckt. Das wurde jetzt so über die Zeit immer weiter erweitert. Und das hat dann die Community auf up.net innerhalb von 8 Stunden mal für alle Clients, die es gab, aufgefüllt, mehr oder minder. Und irgendwann musste ich dann zumachen und habe halt zum Beispiel bei den Android-Clients habe ich teilweise die Entwickler direkt dran, die das up-to-date halten. Oder bei Chapper und Spinnaker macht das auch der, also so Windows-Client, da macht das auch der Entwickler, der das direkt up-to-date hält. Die iOS-Clients, die habe ich inzwischen alle, die halte ich dann up-to-date, genauso die Mac-Clients.
Hast du denn Feedback bekommen von den Developern, wie die das so finden?
Ausschließlich Gutes. Also die Developer, die sich gemeldet haben, fanden es ausschließlich gut, weil sie dann sehen, weil sie selber sehen, was denn zum Beispiel für sie, was die anderen können und was sie gegebenenfalls selber noch so reinhaben wollen. Und so eine ganz wichtige Spalte ist auch dieses Accessible zum Beispiel, ob ein Client Accessible ist, was halt dann für blinde Nutzer ganz praktisch sein kann, aber das Problem ist, dass die Chart selber wohl für blinde Nutzer nicht so wirklich zu gebrauchen ist aktuell, wie mir gesagt wurde, weil Google-Spreadsheets da einfach nicht so bei ist.
Da hilft dann genau dieses JSON-Ding, damit könnte man das ja direkt in Preie umsetzen.
Ja genau, das ist die Idee, wenn mal jemand die Seite neu schreibt, also wenn jemand eine Seite schreibt, die über die AP drauf zugreift, dass man da irgendwie mal was besseres baut, als das, was es jetzt gibt. Mit dem Accessible, da gibt es übrigens auch so ein schönes Up.net-Feature, man kann Language Annotations, man kann quasi sagen, mein Post ist in Deutsch geschrieben, was dann, was bis jetzt leider nur Happy kann. Happy hat dann auch gleich noch das Accessible Feature dafür inzwischen eingebaut. Und zwar kann man halt ranhängen, ich habe meinen Post in Deutsch, Englisch, was auch immer geschrieben. Das bedeutet, ich kann meinen Stream filtern, ich hätte gerne nur noch deutsche Posts, englische Posts, japanische Posts und Posts ohne Annotation.
Darauf habe ich gewartet, dass ich mir endlich mal die japanischen Posts rausholen kann.
Ja, dann kommt aber mal ein Post in Russisch, also in Chirilisch geschrieben, den ich nicht lesen kann, der wird halt rausgefiltert. Den muss ich da nicht mehr sehen. Und was halt für blinde Nutzer praktisch ist...
Also für uns ist das glaube ich noch ein weniger Problem, weil wir das allermeiste von dem, was kommt, sowieso lesen können. Aber ich glaube so, ich würde gerne, nehme ich zum Beispiel auch so ein Problem. Bei Twitter habe ich am Anfang viel Englisch geschrieben. Dann war es klar, dass ich irgendwie im Wesentlichen so eine deutsche Community habe und bin dann immer mehr dazu übergegangen, einen deutschen Account rauszumachen. Obwohl mir so ein paar englische Freunde folgen, weiß ich, dass die nicht wirklich lesen. Wenn man das halt so machen könnte, dass man sagt, ihr seht nur meine englischen Posts, dann wäre das ein super Feature.
Die können sich das halt selber filtern. Mit Happy geht das, mit anderen Clients halt. Die anderen Clients ziehen jetzt hoffentlich nach.
Ich hab jetzt mal den Abnettesens-Typ angehauen.
Habe ich gesehen. Was für blinde Nutzer interessant ist, dass zum Beispiel bei iOS Siri automatisch die Sprache umstellen kann. Die Entwickler können dann quasi sagen, wenn ein deutscher Post kommt, benutze ich die deutsche Sprache, benutze ich die deutsche Stimme. Wenn ein französischer Post kommt, benutze ich die französische Stimme. Und nicht alles, was in lateinischen Lettern geschrieben ist, mit der gleichen die Fortstimme vorliest. Sondern halt automatisch die Sprache wechselt. Was halt extrem praktisch ist. Für mich ist es der Filter für blinde Nutzer, dass da VoiceOver den Sprachwechsel machen kann. Es ist aktuell nur an der Beta von Happy, aber es ist auf jeden Fall cool.
Darf ich mal zur Auflockung kurz eine Anwenderfrage stellen? Ich mach jetzt mal Anwender. Muss ich abpollen?
Also es gibt Server-Streams. Die Entwickler können quasi sagen, ich hab hier meinen Server stehen und die haben irgendwie so einen Token, der streamen kann. Also über den sie streamen können, das brauchen sie für die Push-Notifications, damit die halt zeitnah reinkommen. Ansonsten, für User kann nur pollen. Die arbeiten zurzeit an User-Streams. Also die arbeiten schon ziemlich lange an User-Streams. Ja, genau, es ist aktuell noch ein Plattformproblem. Sie sagen, sie arbeiten dran, es ist irgendwie nicht einfach, aber es kommt. Aber aktuell ist es ein Plattformproblem.
Zweite User-Frage, die mir die fünf Leute gestellt haben, die sich überhaupt mal mit diesem Thema befasst haben, sagen, ja, es ist aber jetzt ein tierischer Zoo hier. Ich meine, das ist bei Twitter nicht anders, aber nur bei ADN nochmal neu. Was ist denn jetzt nur der angesachte heiße Scheiß? Mach doch mal jetzt Werbung für einen Client pro Plattform.
Ich mache jetzt mal...
Was sage ich den Usern, die mir begegnen und sagen, was spiele ich jetzt auf mein Android-Phone, auf mein iPhone und auf mein Mac?
Android habe ich selber nicht. Android habe ich am meisten Gutes von Robin gehört.
Hab ich getestet, ist eine Android-Applikation, die nicht scheiße aussieht.
Ja, und sie ist am meisten Feature-complete und kann auch Petter-Räume, also kann diese Chat-Räume auch in öffentlich und im Privat. Unter iOS sind meine Favoriten Felix, Happy und Petter. Das sind so die drei Kleins, die ich auf dem Homescreen drauf habe.
Aber welche ist deine Nummer eins? Was empfängst du dem User?
Ja, warte, warte. iOS, Felix und Happy. Und ich sage dir, warum ich beide auf dem Homescreen drauf habe. Felix habe ich auf dem Homescreen. Das ist so mein Brottenbutterklein quasi. Der kann ja inzwischen auch Multi-Account und kann auch ein dunkles Theme, was praktisch ist, wenn man abends neben seinem Kind liegt, was irgendwie kurz vorm Einschlafen ist und dann doch wieder mal hochschießt, man deswegen daneben sitzt und es aber nicht hier den Raum ausleuchten will.
Dunkle Themes sind sehr wichtig für Eltern.
Ja, dunkle Themes sind sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und kann leider keine öffentlichen Petterräume, aber zumindest private Petterräume, die einen Vorteil gegenüber Private Messages haben, dass man im Nachhinein noch Leute hinzufügen kann? Kommt aber bestimmt auch noch. Weiß ich nicht. Aber wie auch immer, es basiert ja auf der gleichen Technik. Es sind ja beides Kanäle. Und ist feature-complete und funktioniert gut für mich.
Hat noch so ein paar Schwächen bei Multi-Account. Also wenn man mit mehreren Accounts arbeitet, dann will man auf jeden Fall auch noch Netbot haben. Weil das irgendwie solider funktioniert.
Und Happy ist am besten, wenn man so... Zum Beispiel... Also Happy sieht vielleicht nicht unbedingt am schicksten aus. Dafür hat es zum Beispiel die tolle Funktion Load No Images. Was bedeutet, dass es keine Avatarer und keine Inline-Bilder und nichts mehr lädt. Und wenn man gedrosselt... Genau, es funktioniert auch in Edge-Land. Oder wenn man wie ich gerade gedrosselt ist, dann kann man Abdonnet immer noch benutzen, weil keine Bilder mehr runterkommen, sondern nur noch der Text. Der Overhead ist zwar immer noch für den Text relativ groß, wie sich Entwickler schon beschwert haben, dass da irgendwie für 256 Zeichen immer noch zu viel mitkommt. Aber es kommt halt kein Text mit. Und deswegen für Edge-Land ist Happy einfach großartig.
Hat er sich gegesibt, kommt auch aus Deutschland.
Ja genau, Happy kommt auch aus Deutschland. Und der Entwickler hat, nachdem Leute meinten, warum ist denn Felix nicht kostenlos? Repost und Netbots sind ja auch kostenlos, hat der Entwickler von Happy gesagt, das kann ja wohl nicht sein, dass Leute jetzt sagen, hier, mach mal alles kostenlos. Deswegen habe ich meinen kostenlosen Client, mein kostenloser Client kostet jetzt was. Also der hat den Preis angehoben. Ja, fand ich gut. Und der macht halt sowas wie diese Language-Annotations schon. Und der entwickelt auch sehr fix. Also ähnlich wie bei Felix, haut der mit die meisten Updates raus. Der entwickelt halt in seiner Freizeit an dem Client und macht aber sehr viel. Ja, und dann halt für Petter benutze ich die Petter für iOS-App. Weil auch wenn Happy öffentliche Petter-Räume kann, ist die Petter für iOS-App doch etwas schöner und etwas fixer bei Petter-Räumen. Für Symbian gibt es nur einen Client, soweit ich weiß. Für Windows Phone kann ich mich nicht äußern. Angeblich gibt es aktuell auch nur noch einen Client. Aber ich war der Meinung, da gibt es mehr. Da kann ich mich nicht äußern, weil ich Windows Phone irgendwie zweimal in meinem Leben in der Hand hatte. Ja, genau. Für Mac OS X benutze ich Kiwi als Hauptclient. Wenn ich nur was posten will, weil der inline links kann, der kann Multi-Accounten, kann über Shotguns auch schnell zwischen den Accounts wechseln. So Command oben, Command unten wechsle ich schnell die Accounts durch. Der ist toll, wenn man einfach nur schnell mal was posten will. Und Kiwi so für alles andere. Und wenn ich mal irgendwie einen Zweit-Account öffnen will, wenn man nur zwei Accounts hat, dann tut es halt noch. Ich hoffe, Kiwi schiebt irgendwann mal einen Multi-Account nach. Das hoffe ich schwer. Aber Sale ansonsten so fürs Posten.
Aber es ist doch erstaunlich, dass es gerade für die Desktop-Dinger doch im Verhältnis zu den Mobile-Client weniger gibt.
Ja, da meint er aber zum Beispiel, MAP zu mir ist halt weitaus schwerer für OS X zu entwickeln als für iOS.
Das ist viel moderner auf iOS als auf Mac. Dementsprechend ist der Aufwand auch größer.
Unter Windows benutze ich Chapper. Den benutze ich unter Windows 7. Der ist nicht schick, der kommt auch aus Deutschland. Er tut es, er wird bald besser aussehen, weil bald Teams kommen. Solarized kommt dann auch mit für die Solarized-Fans unter uns. Und gegebenenfalls Spinnaker, das ist quasi ein Sale-Clone von dem Chapper-Entwickler für Windows. Der ist in der Entwicklung in Open Source. Web-Clients benutze ich am meisten Nudel, weil er auch inline-Links über Markdown-Syntax kann. Für private Messages benutze ich Ketter im Web.
Meine Güte, das haben wir gefühlte 50 Kleines.
Wenn du selber sagst, ich benutze, wie hättest du denn den Sync? Funktioniert das mit den Markern?
Also die Streammarker, also Chappar und Nudel haben zum Beispiel keinen Support für Streammarker bis jetzt. Da funktioniert es nicht. Für mich funktioniert es mit Kiwi, für viele Leute funktioniert es leider nicht so gut. Bei den iOS-Kleins funktioniert es für mich einwandfrei. Also egal, ob ich jetzt zwischen Repost, also ich wechsle wenn dann E zwischen Repost, Felix und Happy, da funktioniert es für mich. Das Wichtigste, das gelesen markiert wird für private Nachrichten. Das funktioniert bei allen, die private Nachrichten unterstützen. Dieses gelesen funktionieren, das ist somit die wichtigste Funktion. Ich habe vor kurzem Twitter aufgemacht und habe die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschlagen und gesagt, nein.
Ja, also Menschen werden als gelesen markiert.
Das funktioniert bei den iOS-Kleins.
Das finde ich auch wirklich sexy. Du beendest so ein Programm, hast 10 Minuten in dein Timeline rumgescrollt und dann wechselst du aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen in einen anderen Client und der atmet mal kurz durch, tankt kurz bei app.net nach und dann scrollt. Dann ist er genau an der Stelle, wo du im anderen Programm aufgelassen bist.
Vor allen Dingen, sie haben jetzt auch verbessert, dass die Clients abrufen können. Ich hätte gerne die letzten 100 neuesten Posts inzwischen, können sie sagen, ich habe an dieser Stelle aufgehört, lad mal nach und ich hätte jetzt gerne die 60 Posts nach dem, was du gerade gelesen hast. In Felix siehst du das zum Beispiel, wenn du gerade am hochscrollen bist, nach neun Posts und dann auf den Laden-Button drückst, dann lädt er von unten nach oben. Wenn du in die andere Richtung scrollst, lädt er von oben nach unten, weil er quasi abhängig von der Scroll-Richtung den Chunk holt. Aber Netbot funktioniert besser als bei Felix. Ja, aber Netbot macht das irgendwie anders, weil Netbot kann dieses Feature noch nicht eingebaut haben, weil das jünger als zwei Monate ist. Ja, aber sie machen das dann irgendwie anders. Sie ziehen sich mehr Posts oder was auch mal.
Bei Felix ist dann auf einmal die Position anders und dann weiß ich nicht mehr, wo ich war.
Also bei mir funktioniert es einwandfrei.
Ja gut, also im Wesentlichen kann man zusammenfassen, es tut sich einfach eine Menge. Es gibt echt viele Clients und die bemühen sich alle enorm, die Experience zu verbessern. Alle zwei Wochen hat sich wieder irgendwas substanziell verbessert. Das finde ich echt scharf.
Ja, es wird zwar gerade so etwas langsamer. Teilweise wünschen sich die Entwickler, dass es etwas langsamer wird, damit sie mal Zeit haben aufzuholen, weil sie Bugs fixen können, anstatt immer nur neue Features einzubauen.
Ja, genau.
Die würden gerne mal so einen Zeitraum haben, wo sie atmen können.
Genau.
No-New-Features.
Da wollten sie immer Features haben, jetzt kriegen sie Features, können sie auch nicht beklagen.
Und ich kann auf jeden Fall empfehlen, den Podcast von Dalton selber zu hören, diesen app.net-Podcast, weil er da selber erzählt, was so kommt und was sie sich bei Dingen gedacht haben. Und warum manche Dinge mal länger dauern oder so. Warum private messages einfach mal gedauert haben, damit Gruppenprivate messages einfach funktionieren. Und das tun sie.
Ja, und es funktioniert wirklich gut. Das ist echt erstaunlich.
Und vor allen Dingen im Gegensatz zu jedem Instant-Messaging, also im Gegensatz zu XMPP oder so, habe ich halt nicht das Problem, dass irgendwie meine History dann fehlt, wenn ich den Client wechsle, sondern die komplette History kommt halt immer mit. Und im Gegensatz zu Twitter kann ich halt auch mehr als nur eine Person drin haben.
Lass uns mal das Kapitel zumachen, aber nicht bevor wir nicht nochmal so ein bisschen über die Geldaspekte gesprochen haben. Weil ich glaube, Sie haben ja im letzten Podcast auch nochmal, oder was war der vorletzte, nochmal so über die Modelle geredet, so diese Billing-API, die Sie gerade entwickeln.
Ja, da haben Sie jetzt... Also da hat Dolt einen verschiedenen Podcast, wo er zu Gast war, schon mal drüber geredet. Da hat er es angeschnitten. Also wofür es sich am meisten für mich anhört, ist, dass Sie es ermöglichen wollen. Und Sie wissen, das hat er auch schon gesagt, Sie wissen, dass Sie es bei iOS-Klines, dass es da nicht funktionieren wird. Aber dass Sie zum Beispiel so etwas machen können wie, ich baue eine Plattform auf, die auf abdeut.net basiert und die kostet auch Geld, die kostet dich nämlich 6 Dollar im Monat und dass quasi die Plattform selber die 5 Dollar durchreichen kann, die Billing-Plattform von abdeut.net benutzt, selber den Dollar bekommt und sich aber um nichts mehr kümmern muss, sondern halt die komplette Infrastruktur von abdeut.net auch für das Bezahlen mitbenutzen kann.
Dass du sozusagen deinen ADN-Account einfach mitkaufst durch das Nutzen dieses Super-Netzwerks.
Zum Beispiel, ja genau, dass du halt irgendwie, du baust das nächste Facebook, was auf abdeut.net basiert und wenn du halt noch keinen Account hast, brauchst du halt vielleicht einen und den können sie dann für dich gleich mitkaufen.
Aber es gibt kaufen, es gibt regelmäßige Subscription.
Ja, ich glaube...
Es gibt Pay What You Want.
Ja, sie wollen mehr oder minder so alles, was man so...
Ja, so wesentlichen Donations.
Ja genau, so was man so braucht, wollen sie halt umsetzen.
Oder zahlen überhaupt irgendwas, es ist egal was. Hauptsache du zahlst. Ich mag dann irgendein Minimum geben, das ist unklar. Ich frage mich halt, ob sie irgendwie eine Chance haben, darüber auch so ein Micro-Payment-System zu implementieren. Das werden sie unter Garantie nicht in dem ersten Schritt machen. Und ich frage mich auch, ob die auch irgendwie gegen Flatter vorgehen werden. Ich kann es mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen. Aber trotzdem, in dem Moment, wo jemand von außen mit dieser Monetarisierungsdrohung kommt.
Das glaube ich nicht. Wenn ich sie richtig verstehe, ist ihnen das Wichtigste, das Geld über die Accounts, über die User so zu kriegen. Sie haben schon mehrfach gesagt, sie wollen nur die Pipe sein. Da gibt es ja die Beschwerde von jetzt, dass sie diese Phishing-Protection immer mit reinposten, wenn man einen Link postet. Wenn man so eine Link-Entität postet, wird immer die Phishing-Protection hintendran. Also wenn ich jetzt schreibe, hier ist der Text, und dahinter ist eine URL, dann wird immer in eckigen Klammern da hingeschrieben, domain.com. Genau, das ist die Phishing-Protection. Du kannst es nicht ausschalten. Wo jetzt halt sagt so, naja, da seid ihr aber nicht wirklich eine Pipe, weil ihr mir ja so in meine Daten reinfuscht. Aber ansonsten sagen sie halt, wir wollen nur die Röhre sein, die die Daten liefern und nicht mehr. Und von daher denke ich auch nur, dass sie die Billing API als zusätzlichen Service für Entwickler anbieten, aber nicht jetzt anderen Leuten, die irgendwas mit Geld machen innerhalb von app.net, denen jetzt sagen, so oder nö, dürfte nicht mehr. Dass sie in ihre API-Guidelines reinschreiben, wenn du eine App baust, die auf app.net basiert, dass du dann kein Geld nehmen darfst, wenn du es nicht über unsere Billing API machst. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Aber sie könnten natürlich theoretisch auch so etwas wie Flatter machen innerhalb ihres Netzes.
Ja, natürlich. Ist die Frage, ob du als Benutzer, ob vielleicht der Zusatz von einem Developer-Account ist, dass du Geld auszahlen kannst. Sie könnten es ja so machen, dass nur jemand mit einem Developer-Account sich Geld auszahlen lassen kann von seinem Account und das normale Benutzer nur einzahlen können.
Ja, aber das würde dem Micropayment-Gedanken ja widersprechen. Und warum auch? Ich meine, wenn sie da einen Kreditkarte haben, dann können sie da genauso gut was hinbuchen, wie sie was abbuchen.
Ja, natürlich, aber das kann halt so dieses Ding, wie gesagt, ist halt die Frage, ob sie es für Developer nur darstellen wollen. Also so als, hier habt ihr was, um eure Services zu unterstützen, damit ihr irgendwie so jemand wie Blimps, der so eine Multimedia-Seite verabeneint.
Wir müssen eigentlich über den Vorteil von dem Flatter-Modell sprechen, mit dem Flatrate, ich definiere, was ich ausgebe, lalala. Also wenn ich sozusagen so ein Payment machen kann im Sinne von, ich lege 10 Dollar in den Topf, ja, und die werden auch automatisch abgebucht, so wie auch sonst mein Account abgebucht wird, ja. Sozusagen ich zahle noch mehr da rein in den Topf, aber nicht um meinen User-Account zu bezahlen, sondern um eben Micropayments zu machen auf Flatter-Base.
Ja, das ist halt die Frage, wie sie es machen wollen. Wenn sie sagen, du hast da deine Kreditkarte hinterlegt. Ja, sie können es ja so machen, dass du quasi einzahlst, dass du in den Topf einzahlst und sie das Geld irgendwie verwalten müssen. Also quasi, dass sie irgendein Konto haben müssen, wo das Geld einfach so rumliegt, bis es genutzt wird. Oder sie können auch sagen, am Ende des Monats ziehen wir von deiner Kreditkarte deine Einkäufe ab. Weil es geht ja aktuell auch nur über Kreditkarte und auf Anfrage per Paypal.
Ja gut, ich meine, das ist dann letztlich ein technisches Detail.
Aber am Ende ist es halt alle Spekulation, solange das Feature nicht draußen ist.
Ah, ich weiß warum, Huckels. Ich weiß warum. Huckel, du musst mal den Stuhl wechseln. Der Grund ist der Stuhl. Ja, dein Stuhl, das ist der böse Stuhl mit dem weißen Aufkleber. Wenn du den anderen Stuhl nimmst, dann knupst es nicht mehr. Ich muss den Stuhl irgendwie tauschen, der erzeugt irgendwie elektrische Felder hier. Vom Sitzen, vom Wippen lädt er sich irgendwie auf und dann gibt es irgendwie Überspannungen. Dann geht das hier voll. Du musst besser ernten. Ja, die anderen haben es alle nicht.
Genau, so eine Erdungsschleife wie damals an den Mantas. Ja, einen guten Erdungsschleif an den Bürostuhl.
Häng halt einen Fuchsschwanz mit, die tauscht den gegen einen anderen.
Na gut, wir können jetzt viel spekulieren, ob sie es machen werden oder nicht, aber vielleicht stimmst du mir zu, sie könnten es theoretisch tun. Sie könnten quasi das Flatter-Modell einbauen und ich fände das irgendwie gut, auch wenn Flatter damit irgendwie ein bisschen außen vor ist, weil sie sich sicherlich nicht Flatter als Dienstleister einholen, es sei denn, sie kaufen den Laden. Das wäre aber nochmal ein Modell. Gut, das ist alles unrealistisch.
Da können sie ja vielleicht ihr VC-Geld für einsetzen, was sie haben.
Na gut, ich denke, wir können das ADN-Fenster schließen, wenn es keine Userfragen mehr gibt. Hast du noch welche? Ach so, ich habe dich mal kurz hier, jetzt darfst du dir was sagen.
Nach einer dreiviertel Stunde können wir auch mal wieder über was anderes reden.
So, hier Bitcoin-Crash. Denis ist nicht da.
Nächste Mal.
Keiner ist reich geworden.
Naja, ich habe immer meine Motorradreparatur rausbekommen.
Na super. Na, ich nicht. Ich warte auf die nächste Bubble.
Die kommt bestimmt.
Ja, die nächste Bubble kommt bestimmt.
Tja, ich war auch noch so ein bisschen zu gierig. Ich habe ja bei 200, was auch immer, der Höchststand da war, gedacht, da, an dem Tag, haben wir uns so drüber nacheinander mit Denis gechattet, ob er jetzt nervös wird. Denis hat gesagt, oh, nö, ich behalte die einfach erst mal. Und am Tag später ging es halt ab. Ich habe mir irgendwie ganz viele Alerts hier in meinen BTC-Reports gesetzt, um dann immer früh informiert zu sein. Als es dann passiert war, war ich im Proberaum, jenseits von Empfang, von Internet. Und dann kam ich so raus, drei Stunden später. Genau, und dann irgendwie Alerts, 82 Euro irgendwie getriggert. Da habe ich schon so ein bisschen mich geärgert. Dann bin ich noch nach Hause und habe dann noch den letzten Aufschwung so vor dem finalen Abstieg nochmal abgewartet und habe dann immerhin noch für 137 meine Bitcoins losgekriegt. Aber wir haben ja alle darauf gewartet und es war ja auch mal an der Zeit, dass jetzt so ein reinigendes Gewitter mal wieder kommt.
Ja, aber es hat sich auf den Preis eingependelt, so um die 70 Euro rum derzeit, die deutlich über dem liegt, was vorher so üblich war. Also ich weiß. Also, dann bis dahin, Die erste Aufregung vor dem Jahr war ja so, oh Gott, 30 Dollar, 30 Euro, was auch immer.
Knapp 30 war der Höchststand.
Ja, da war schon auch alle total am hyperventilieren und so, oh Gott, ich hab's nicht verkauft, oh Gott. So, und jetzt irgendwie 200 und weißt du, Geier, was das nächste ist?
Aber es ist eigentlich immer noch zu viel, damit diese ganzen Stromverschwendungen, die ganzen Leute lassen jetzt ihren alten Rechner mit den Grafikkarten wieder rattern, weil es sich gerade noch lohnt.
Nee, nicht so richtig.
Gerade noch.
Ja, aber.
So wie unsere Kohlekraftwerke jetzt kein Problem haben, da ihre Emissionszertifikate zu kaufen, ist alles, die Welt ist ungerecht.
Ich finde, jedes Milliwatt, was in dieses Bitcoin-Netzwerk investiert wird, gerechtfertigt. Nee, absolut gerechtfertigt, weil es ein absolut wichtiges globales Experiment ist. Weil es einfach diese ganze, dieses ganze Finanzsystem, was sowieso schon existiert. Ich meine, Gold ist im Prinzip das Oldschool-Bitcoin. Weil niemand, der mit Goldhandel trägt, außer vielleicht Pavel, seine Schubkarre voll Gold bahn aus der Bank raus. Und dann klickt er in irgendein Web-Formular und sagt, ich hätte gerne mal und ich kaufe jetzt mal so und so viel Gold. Niemand sieht das, niemand hat das. Wer weiß, ob es überhaupt existiert.
Nur alle Jahre lang geht man die engen Königinnen und Königinnen auf die Kursuhr und guckt, ob es da ist.
Und der Preis geht hoch und runter. Und das ist ganz witzig, wenn du die Kurve von Gold über die letzten zehn Jahre mit Bitcoins die letzten zehn Wochen vergleichst. Die Kurve sieht exakt gleich aus. Das geht auch bei Gold so, wo wo wo wo, zonk.
Das ist halt auch ein Spekulationsteil.
Alles genau das Gleiche. Und Bitcoin ist jetzt im Prinzip sozusagen so das Abstraction Layer über diesen ganzen Kram, den sich so die Menschheit in den letzten Jahrzehnten und Jahrhunderten ausgedacht hat, in komplett reiner digitaler Form. Distributed, nur Bits only, alles komplett virtualisiert. Und ich finde das extrem wichtig, dass jetzt also die Menschheit mal diesen Schritt geht und eine dezentrale, unregulierte Währung da ausprobiert. Und mit all seinen Konsequenzen.
Ja, also du meinst diese Millimeter, sie sind da folgerecht.
Definitiv.
Also, dann sollten wir da eine Assalzpflanzung machen und dann wenigstens sowas wie Online-Werbung abschalten.
Und ich mein...
Das São Paulo-Modell.
Nein, aber ich meine, es gibt jetzt nämlich, es gibt ja jetzt auch Forks von Bitcoins schon, also die Energieverschwendung geht sozusagen weiter, aber das Ding ist halt auch die, finde ich gut, weil die erproben jetzt nochmal andere Variationen.
Ach sozusagen so ein Zweitnetz mit derselben Technologie.
Nee, es gibt zum Beispiel... Ach ja, da hat sich der Denis das letzte Mal der Diskussion verweigert, weil er mal den erkennt, aber wenn du hast du da einen kleineren Einblick, dann erzähl doch mal, was gibt es denn dafür?
Also zum Beispiel, es gibt jetzt welche, die sagen einfach nur, okay, wir geben einfach mehr raus, damit es sich lohnt, wieder mit Commodity-Hardware zu rendern und noch mal alles so ein bisschen gebootstrapped und auch die Difficulty-Berechnung, alles nochmal ein bisschen anders. Genau, diese Litecoins. Dann gibt es glaube ich, die heißen Freecoins oder Freedomcoins. Ich weiß gerade den Namen nicht.
Das erinnert mich an Freedomfries.
Das Konzept da ist, glaube ich, bei denen gewesen, dass da das Geld sozusagen, je länger du es liegen lässt, desto weniger wird es wert. Also die sozusagen darauf setzen, dass es eine Zirkulationswährung ist. Und die erproben jetzt so sämtliche Konzepte auch, die sonst in irgendwelchen Ökonomen-Unis nur theoretisch durchgespielt werden, gibt es da jetzt da draußen. Und ich finde das extrem gut. Also ich meine, der ultimative Schritt wäre natürlich, so die Star Trek-Utopie gar kein Geld mehr zu haben. Aber bis dahin haben wir, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen Erprobungsphase. Ja, irgendwas ist da natürlich bestimmt auch involviert. Und ich meine, diese Frage halt, ich weiß nicht, haben wir bestimmt hier auch schon besprochen, warum ist jetzt überhaupt die Bitcoin was wert? Oder warum ist überhaupt Geld irgendwas wert? Was ist dieser Wert? Woher kommt das Vertrauen? Jetzt in irgend so ein abstraktes Konzept wie Währung? Das kann man sich da alles sehr schön herbei diskutieren und veranschaulichen. Und es gibt halt auch extrem valide Anwendungsfälle für dieses Bitcoins Zeug. Ich weiß nicht, hatte ich letztes Mal das mit dem Argentinier schon erzählt. Also so als Transfergeld für eben die Leute, die jetzt mit ihrer Währung gerade nichts mehr anfangen können und so. Die einen nennen es Geldwäsche, die anderen...
Western Union willst du doch jetzt auch einsetzen eventuell. Die überlegen doch auch, ob Bitcoin zu nutzen.
Ich weiß nicht, hat man das letzte Mal schon gesagt. Ich hab letztens bei einem Mittagstisch mit irgendjemand, also bei uns in der Mittagspause, da wird eigentlich immer, wenn ich mit den üblichen verdächtigen Mittagessen gehe, dann wird immer über Bitcoin geredet und wie man den Markt richtig sicher, also mal so baut, dass er nicht beim ersten Atemzug umgepustet wird. Weil das ist ja auch gerade so ein Problem, wenn da jetzt so eine kleine Verkaufspanik losgeht und diese ganzen Rails und Django-Applikationen dann gleich so hinten über kippen. Also naja klar, da ist jetzt halt schon auch so ganz viel so in der Schmuddelecke. Also online, also Poker gibt es mit Bitcoin, Satoshi Dice, also Online-Roulette. Dann Silk Road, ich meine, die einen finden das ja durchaus, also zeitgemäß, dass es so was wie die Silk Road jetzt mal endlich gibt. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass... Ja, das weiß man halt nicht, ne? Also ja, da ist eine Briefmarke und ein Poststempel drauf, aber also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt halt bei irgendeinem Händler was bestellst, da weißt du wohl, in welchem Briefkasten die das schmeißen.
Vor allen Dingen läuft bei Silk Road, ist doch eigentlich nur eine Handelsplattform, von denen bekommt man ja nichts.
Genau.
Ich bekomme ja auch von Ebay keine Post oder so.
Deswegen, die Händler, also die Sachen, die von Silk Road in den Nachrichten sind, das sind nur einzelne Händler, die sich halt so doof angestellt haben, die kriegen sie dann halt dran so und fahren dann mal bei denen zu Hause vorbei und finden dann halt irgendwie kiloweise Gras und was noch, nicht noch alles, aber es ist halt einer von Hunderten oder Tausenden, ja. Und ja, also ich meine, übrigens, es gibt jetzt wieder so eine tolle Meldung, dass OkCupid oder wie auch immer man das korrekt ausspricht, akzeptiert jetzt übrigens auch Bitcoins als Zahlungsmittel für ihre Proversion. Also, Online-Dating ist jetzt auch im Bitcoin-Land schon angekommen, ja. Also, ich fand es schon von Anfang an ein extrem cooles und auch durchaus interessantes Experiment und ich finde auch mit diesen ganzen Marktbewegungen, das jetzt hier hat ja jetzt so ein Start-up angekündigt mit Foundern von Microsoft und Facebook und 500.000 Dollar Seed-Capita, dass die jetzt einen Forexchange machen, also wie heißt das? Also, du kannst Short Selling auf Bitcoins halt machen. Das ist extrem cool, weil du kannst jetzt wirklich, das ist komplett abstrahiert von allen anderen Bündnissen, irgendwie Notenbanken oder was auch immer, komplett in diesem virtuellen Raum das jetzt mal ablaufen lassen.
Es ist halt eher, es ist halt keine Währung, sondern irgendwie eher wie ein Wertpapier oder so.
Ja, wie Gold oder irgendein abstrakter limitierter Rohstoff oder Ressource.
Irgendein Spekulationsmittel, aber als Währung ist es halt irgendwie durch die hohe Inflation oder Inflation, Deflation, je nachdem, welchen Kreislauf du gerade hast. Gerade hatten wir ja Inflation und nicht Deflation. Also wir haben da echt große Schwankungen, also Wertschwankungen und von daher ist es halt nicht als Währung so wirklich zu gebrauchen, weil die willst du stabil haben. Da möchte ich gerne morgen noch wissen, wie viel man einer Bitcoin wert ist.
Klar, das ist halt Teil des Experiments und ich habe auch allen, denen ich jetzt schon immer davon erzählt habe, genau das auch gesagt und deswegen auch für die letzte mal schon die Warnung, dass man das mit Spielgeld ausprobieren sollte und nicht mit seinen ersparten Ressourcen, von denen man sie irgendwie auskaufen will oder was auch immer.
Ich habe davon im Jahr ein Chaos-Radio mit Andreas zugemacht, mit Andreas Burg zu dem Thema. War ich damals jetzt hier? Aber ja, ich würde auch sagen, nicht mit deinem echten Geld einsteigen. Also nicht mit deinem Ganzen.
Nicht mit dem Ganzen, nur das, was man wirklich verlieren kann, auch wenn es ein bisschen ärgerlich ist. Aber die Chancen, dass man da auch noch mal den einen oder anderen Euro rauskriegt, die sind gar nicht so schlecht.
Und der Einstieg ist leichter als wahrscheinlich als ein Börsenhandel.
Ja, definitiv.
Wir verschicken noch ein paar Bitcoin-Invites.
Kauft, kauft, kauft.
Weil wir haben hier noch Bitcoins rumliegen, die wollen wir noch mal ein bisschen versilbern.
Ja, also einfach mal die Füße stillhalten. Nein. Also ja, diese Panik war auch ganz witzig. Irgendwie wohl in diesem Bitcoin-Channel war auch ein Kollege drin, als es dann so losging. Und dann gab es auch so die verschiedensten Erklärungen und Phänomene. Und auch so diese ganzen Konzepte aus dem Aktienmarkt, irgendwie Bulltrap und Bear Trap und keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Sachen wurden da ganz ausführlich erklärt. Also da kann man noch mal richtig was über den echten Finanzmarkt auch dabei lernen.
Kaufen Sie jetzt, rufen Sie die Nummer neben der Landesflagge an.
Und kriegen Sie ein Messer, was Schuhe zerschneiden kann, noch obendrauf.
Das ist ja wirklich unglaublich. Auch total unglaublich war ja mein Ausflug in die Windows-Welt, den ich gestern gemacht habe, nachdem mir so viele Leute zugerehlt haben.
Mondlandung.
Nein, ich leide ja hier unter den Insuffizienzen der Software, wie immer, wie wir alle ja auch leiden unter den…
Ers sei denn, wir haben sie selber geschrieben. Dann ist sie natürlich super.
Ja, aber das kommt ja jetzt bei so Audio-Workstations nicht so häufig vor. Das ist ja auch schon mal eher so ein komplexerer Kern, den man da zusammenschneidern muss.
Bisschen.
Bisschen. Ist schon eher eine der größeren Herausforderungen. Und nun habe ich mich mal Reaper zugewendet, nachdem so viele Leute der Meinung waren, das müsste sie mir doch noch bringen.
Moa Kaubel. Den hast du gar nicht verstanden, oder?
Na, das ist doch ja so eine olle Combo irgendwie. Wie hieß sie noch gleich?
Die Combo.
Blue Oyster Kalt. Ja, dazu gab es mal so ein Verarschen, das Ding, wo sie irgendwie... Ja, ja. Man sollte immer mehr Kaubel machen.
Moa Kaubel.
Und das Lied, das sie spielen, heißt Don't Fear the Reaper.
Ja, genau. Also Reaper hat auf jeden Fall eine Menge Kaubel. Das ist schon mal so. Und naja, es war für mich... Also mir ist klar geworden auf einmal, nachdem ich eine Weile... Oder soll ich erst mal... Was soll ich zuerst sagen? Soll ich erst beschweren oder soll ich erst mal das Gute sagen?
Hallo?
Erst beschweren.
Ich mach mal wieder den User. Was ist denn das überhaupt?
Reaper hat eine...
Eine DAW, wie es so schön heißt.
So eine Dampfmaschine, genau.
Digital Audio Workstation oder auch Audio Programm.
Kennst du ein Audio Programm, ey? Schönen, billig? Das Genre heißt Cross Platform. Ja, wa?
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich nehme das zurück. Es ist nicht schlimmer als QT.
Definitiv nicht.
Also es ist nicht so schlimm, wie es ist, wenn es mit so einem Unix Cross Platform Kit gemacht ist, wo es eigentlich ja nur unter Linux wirklich gut funktioniert.
Wo du selbst auf einem Computer aus dem 21. Jahrhundert das Gefühl hast, direkt wieder ins Letzte Jahrhundert zurückgebeamt worden zu sein, weil alles irgendwie Sekunden braucht.
Das Gefühl hat sich trotzdem eingeschränkt.
Aber nicht von der Geschwindigkeit der UI.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein. Also das muss man, doch ich würde erst mal sagen, was ist gut an Reaper? Also weil es ist einiges gut. Es ist wirklich eine schnelle Software, die solider Audio-Recording-Funktionalität bereitstellt.
Kann sie den Soundcard mit mehr als zwei Kanälen?
Das ist schon wirklich ein ausgewachsenes Teil. Also das konkurriert von dem theoretischen Feature-Set her schon mit Live, Logic und diesen ganzen anderen Sachen, Ardua und wie sie alle heißen. Das ist ein Paket, das kann eine Menge, da ist eine Menge drin, das hat einfach eine Menge Brumm.
Hat was für einen Status?
Naja, du kannst halt immer wieder auf Still Evaluating klicken, oder du kannst auch einfach mal die non-commercial, nicht ganz so commercial, Lizenz...
So ein Ding mit so einer funktionalen Kaputt-Drossel, wenn du eine Audio-Aufnahme machst und nach einer Stunde brummt, wird dir eine Signal oder so. Also, erstens lassen wir Tim nochmal kurz ausreden und dann erzählen wir nochmal kurz, wie das Lizenzmodell ist.
Ja, kann man ja schnell sagen, du kannst da aus zwei Preisen auswählen. Und der eine Preis gilt nur, wenn du kommerziell bist und über einen bestimmten Amount of Money pro Jahr umsetzt.
Wenn du 50.000 Dollar im Jahr mit deinem Audio-Produktion machst, dann zahlst du 200 Dollar. Wenn du da drunter bleibst, zahlst du 60 Dollar. Oder du klickst... Wartest du am Anfang?
Kaufen und fertig.
Kaufen und fertig. Und du kriegst das nächste große Update noch oben drauf.
Da habe ich auch nichts dran auszusetzen. Auch einen Preis für so eine Software in der Kategorie gibt es jetzt bei Apple auch nicht billiger und auch bei den anderen schon gar nicht. Aber es ist schnell, es kann eine ganze Menge Sachen. Es hat vor allem viele der Einschränkungen, unter denen ich gerade leide, nicht bei Live.
Was ist das andere zum Beispiel?
Ach naja, also Live nimmt irgendwie zwei Stunden auf und dann hört er auf irgendwie die Spur aufzunehmen, weil die Datei ist ja dann zwei Gigabyte groß und dann kann man ja nicht eine neue aufmachen und so. Also sowas schon mal, völlig hirntrute Sachen. Live rendert unglaublich langsam raus. Also diese Sendung jetzt hier, wenn wir hier durch sind mit unseren drei, vier Stunden, die wir dann erreicht haben werden, da sitze ich dann eine halbe Stunde davor und schaue dem Programm zu, wie es eine IFF-Datei schreibt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, bei Reaper ist das so, der nimmt pro Spur einen Chor sozusagen.
Naja, der nimmt alle richtigen Chors. Also der ist hier auf der Büchse mit den acht echten Chors, also die Halbpass-Rendern nutzt er komischerweise nicht, zumindest nicht beim Rendern. Und der hat hier eine Rendergeschwindigkeit von Faktor 85. Also er schreibt die 85 mal so schnell raus, wie sie lang ist. Das heißt, ich warte da zwei Minuten und nicht 20 oder 30 Minuten. Und das ist schon mal eine echte Ansage. Und er kann halt auch alle Formate, also alle Rendenformate, das heißt, er schreibt mir auch gleich einen Flagg und ich muss nicht erst noch aus dem ARF einen Flagg machen. Und er kann auch während der Aufnahme schon alles in Flagg schreiben. Das heißt, wo jetzt derzeit so eine Sendung hier 12 GB auf der Platte wiegt, wiegt sie dann halt theoretisch nur noch die Hälfte und so weiter. Das ist schon mal alles okay. Dazu kommt, dass das Programm auch extrem viele Hooks und Automatisierungsoptionen hat und es gibt irgendwie Plug-Ins. Und vor allem gibt es ein ordentliches Marker-Modell, was ja für mich meine Hauptpein ist, weil ich das derzeit mit MIDI mache. Also mit Ableton Live rekorde ich MIDI-Noten, was auch Vorteile hat, aber was einen riesen Nachteil hat, dass ich sie nicht direkt benennen kann. Ich kann nicht meine Kapitelstrukturen direkt beim Abhören da mit reinsetzen und exportieren und ich habe die Titel dabei. Nein, ich setze so MIDI-Noten und muss danach die Titel dazu machen und dann habe ich einen zu viel oder zu wenig und dann weiß ich nicht, wo fehlt jetzt einer oder was. Also Konfusion und das kostet alles Zeit und Energie und Konzentration und das ist genau das, was ich mir verspreche, eine andere Software einzusetzen. Soweit ist das alles toll.
Aber.
Aber, dann habe ich irgendwie, dann startet so dieses Programm und ich habe ja schon mal gesagt, die erste habe ich sofort beendet, weil ich einfach diese Icons da links oben gesehen habe, die so dermaßen abgrundtief hässlich sind.
Kannst du nicht dran lecken.
Die will man nicht lecken.
Die will man wirklich nicht lecken. Die will man doch nicht mal angucken. Also die sind nicht nur nicht schön oder so.
Die sind nicht gut, die sind funktional kaputt.
Die sind gar keine Icons. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, wie das, was dein C64 angezeigt hat, wenn du ganz schnell den Aus-Schalter wieder eingemacht hast. Ja, so in-memory-free, wo der Refresh weggefallen ist und irgendwelche random-mäßig gekippt sind.
Das ist auch das, was alle populären Themes gleich sind. Das ist so das Minimalste, was sie ändern an dem Standard-Reaper-Layout. Die haben irgendwie alle andere Buttons für die Standard-Icons. Zumindest die populären Themes.
Okay, aber jetzt kommen wir wieder auf die eigentliche Qual. Nämlich Cross-Plattform. Cross-Plattform heißt ja nicht, es läuft auf allen Plattformen und überall ist es so, wie es zu sein hat. Cross-Plattform heißt, es sieht aus wie auf Windows.
Und du musst auch die Datei-Namen wieder mit Backslash eingeben, um mit Laufwerk-Doppel-Punkt-Funktion zu machen.
Nein, Punkt 3, weißt du doch.
Naja, es hat viel mit Verzicht zu tun. Also ich meine, ich benutze Macintosh aktiv seit 1991 und habe Kontakt mit Windows, also aktiver Benutzer von Windows war ich glaube ich in meinem Leben ungefähr, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, aber ich glaube so was wie zwei Monate oder sowas, als ich mal PageMaker 1.0 auf Windows 1.0 benutzt habe. Das war so meine aktive Windows-Zeit. Das war es dann auch. Und vorher habe ich noch ein bisschen DOS gemacht. So DOS 3.11 irgendwie ein bisschen größer und so. Aber danach wurde es schon besser. Und jetzt startest du halt so eine Software und du hast irgendwie das Gefühl, du bist dann wieder im letzten Jahrhundert. Aber wir so richtig, weil einfach alles, was du gewohnt bist so als etablierter Macintosh-Benutzer ist auf einmal weg wegen Cross-Plattform. Da sind dann in diesen ganzen Fenstern, wenn da irgendwo ein Ordner ausgewählt wird, dann siehst du nicht den Namen des Ordners, den du ausgewählt hast. Nein, du hast also ein 5 km langes Textfeld, wo der Pfad drin steht.
Mit Backslash.
Aber natürlich nicht der ganze Pfad, weil der natürlich so lang ist, dass er trotzdem wieder rechts rausrollt, sodass du überhaupt nichts davon hasst, dass das da angezeigt wird. Dann musst du da mit der Maus reingehen und in diesem Textfeld durch Selektionen irgendwie nach rechts scrollen, um zu wissen, was du da ausgewählt hast. Und ich mich sowieso frage, Pfade anzeigen irgendwie, geht's noch? Dann wählst du solche Pfade dann aus, so was weiß ich, Speicher ab in... Und deine Settings sind da und da. Okay, was machst du so auf dem Mac? Naja, den Ordner habe ich scheiße benannt, das benenne ich mal um. Und stellst dann später fest, dass natürlich dieses Programm sich nicht, wie das 1984 auf dem Macintosh ist, sich eine File-ID merkt, und die immer dieselbe ist und es scheißegal ist, wie dieser Ordner heißt. Nein, er speichert natürlich einen String mit dem Pfad ab. Und wenn du dann diesen Ordner umbenennst, dann gibt es irgendwie Error oder er legt dir einen anderen Ordner an, den du gerade umbenannt hast und dann liegt das Scheiß wieder woanders. Und es ist schon so ein bisschen so, als ob du irgendwo gerade die Tür zugemacht hast, weil es zieht und es kommt irgendwo so ein Düssel und dann macht sie wieder auf. So, und dann denke ich so, hallo, könnten sie bitte gehen irgendwie? Was machen sie in meinem Zimmer? Und es sieht so hässlich aus. Es ist wirklich unglaublich. Jedes Fenster ist voll gerammt mit irgendwelchen Dingen. Und wenn da noch irgendwie fünf Pixel frei waren, dann muss da noch irgendwie eine Option rein. Und alles ist schief und schräg und liegt irgendwie über Kante aufeinander. Furchtbar. Hässliches Fontrendering zum Kotzen. Es ist wirklich unglaublich. Ich frag mich wirklich, wie diese Leute überhaupt den Tag überstehen mit so viel ätzender Hässlichkeit, die sie da irgendwie produzieren. Und es ist nicht mehr... Und es ist schade.
Aber...
Da ist eine gute Engine drunter.
Es gibt Teams.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Also, es gibt ja schon ein Weilchen, aber jetzt auch noch nicht so lange. Und der Mac-Bild, der ist, glaube ich... Also, das war Windows-only vorher. Und den Mac-Bild haben sie mit Version 3 irgendwas angefangen. Und ich habe jetzt mal mir Screenshots angeguckt, wie das vorher aussah.
Du meinst, es geht noch schlimmer. Deswegen soll man froh sein.
Und sie machen schon zwischen den Versionen echt große Sprünge auch vorwärts. Und ich bin mal vorsichtig optimistisch, dass der Mac-Bild auch noch um einiges mehr lieber erfahren wird in der Zukunft. Also, die erste Beta oder die Alpha von Reaper, das war wirklich... Also, da hättest du auch...
Gut, aber das Problem ist ja nicht nur so, wie es dann aussieht. Sondern es ist einfach, welche Denke da drin ist. Also, alles ist konfigurierbar. Es ist natürlich schön, wenn das entscheidende Feature, was du jetzt mal anders brauchst, auch einstellbar ist. Klar. Aber du blickst überhaupt nicht durch, wo irgendwas ist. Also, das ist ein bisschen wie mit dem Internet. Du findest so ein Setting mal. Aber find mal danach, wo du was geändert hast. Weil die Sachen auch an vollkommen unlogischen Orten irgendwie sind.
Wobei ich sagen muss, von den Audiotools, die ich mir angeguckt habe, war ich jetzt so mit... Also, es ging ja darum, vier Spuren aufzunehmen, Interface ranstecken, vier Spuren aufnehmen, war ich tatsächlich mit Reaper am schnellsten, ohne ins Menu zu gucken am Start. Das muss ich auch mal sagen. Also klar, wenn es dann so ein bisschen spezieller wird, dann habe ich mich auch mal dadurch irgendwelche Foren und so gebühlt. Aber es gibt halt auch extrem viel Doku und es gibt auch tonnenweise Videos und Screencasts, wo dir halt irgendwie die tollsten Sachen da erklärt werden, wie es geht. Und bisher konnte ich zumindest auch alles in einer, sagen wir mal, sinnvollen Zeit lösen.
Na gut, ich saß ja hier schon mit einem anderen Reaper-Experten hier einen Tag und dann gibt es schon noch so ein paar gehobene Ungleiten. Aber auch da wieder das Licht im Schatten, was auch sehr geil ist. Reaper kann halt OSC, also Out of the Box irgendwie. Es ist halt alles mit OSC ansprechbar. Das ist für mich, wenn ich denn das mal hier damit so zuverlässig alles zum Laufen bekomme, ist das ein Riesenvorteil, als jetzt mit MIDI arbeiten zu müssen, weil MIDI sackt einfach als Automatisierungstool und da ist OSC wirklich stark. Und da kann man irgendwie schon mal nette Sachen machen, hat dann aber auch echte Bugs. Also zum Beispiel gibt es über OSC so ein Event, wo er dir die aktuelle Zeit, also die Play-Position sozusagen rausschickt als String. Und es gibt ja auch so ein großes Fenster, diese Big Clock, wo du das anzeigen kannst. Nur, dass die Zeit, die er über diesen String rausschickt über OSC ganz anders ist, als die, die er den Clock anzeigt. Also die weicht dann irgendwie in so einem Projekt, was 20 Minuten war, am Schluss irgendwie um 6 Sekunden ab. Also das ist irgendwie richtig broken. Und die Automatisierung ist an sich recht knifflig, finde ich, im Vergleich zu Live. Also da ist auf jeden Fall noch so einiges zu leisten. Also wenn man sich mit auf Frickelei einlässt und wirklich tief durchatmet, bevor man sich irgendwie mit dieser auch recht schlechten Doku auseinandersetzen möchte, die auch genauso voll gemalt ist und wirklich jedes bisschen weiß auf dem PDF, die mit Buchstaben belegt sein muss. Also keinerlei... Merkst einfach, dass niemand in diesem Projekt sich ernsthaft um die Kommunikation mit dem Endanwender wirklich kümmert. Sondern es ist so, ah, wir haben wieder ein Feature, das müssen wir irgendwo hinschreiben, wo ist denn noch Platz? Und dann natürlich diese ganzen Windows-Krankheiten, so wie diese hierarchischen Pref-Panes. Also wo du sozusagen so deine Preference-Pane hast und dann hast du so links deine Kategorien und die sind dann auch noch hierarchisch und du hast natürlich auf jeder Hierarchieebene auch was. Also nicht so Gruppen, in denen dann drei Items sind, sondern der Gruppenname hat seine eigenen Settings und die Unterteile haben dann auch nochmal Settings und alles ist irgendwie total durcheinander.
Haben sie auch Tabs auf zwei Ebenen?
Die so nach vorne hüpfen und so.
So schön hin und her changieren.
Die habe ich noch nicht gesehen. Das ist ja wirklich das Schlimmste.
Nein, das haben sie nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich meine, klar, du hast da auf jeden Fall Abstriche zu leisten, aber es tut schon so seinen Job. Und so zum Beispiel für mich jetzt mit meinen Recording-Anforderungen ist es halt genau das Richtige gewesen, weil von Logic gibt es keine Demo. Dann, als ich Logic mir mal irgendwie woanders angeschaut habe, Wink, Wink, Natschnatsch, habe ich dann Scheiße gefunden und auch nicht gewollt. Bei diesen ganzen anderen Tools, die auch immer noch DVDs von ihrer Software verkaufen und so, das sind halt auch solche Monster und so unglaubliche Komplexität und die einfachsten Tasks, also wirklich mal so irgendwie vier Tracks, Record, Trigger und los, die sind bei anderen Tools irgendwie so krass aufwendig und mit irgendwie Settings auch sonst wo versteckt, also Pro Tools ist auch so ein Settings Monster, wo irgendwie an 23 verschiedenen Stellen kannst du da einmal in so einen Konfigurationsdialog und nochmal hier ein Häkchen und dann musst du aber nochmal da ein Häkchen, damit es dann losgeht und bei den anderen ist es ähnlich. Und das ist halt so für den Preis und wie gesagt, du hast halt eben 60 Tage volle Funktion und ich glaube, gelesen zu haben, selbst nach den 60 Tagen, dann musst du halt nochmal 5 Sekunden länger warten und sagen, ja, still evaluating und du hast trotzdem vollen Funktionsumfang. Du kannst es halt ausprobieren, bis der Arzt kommt. Es tut seinen Job, wie Tim halt schon sagt. So die essentiellen Dinge kannst du irgendwie endlos aufnehmen. Es crasht nicht, es ist schnell. Der Download ist 12 Megabyte und es kommt mit auch mit einer Handvoll richtig professionellen Plugins, also das, was man halt so braucht. Kompressor, Equalizer, DSR, diese ganzen Standard-Tools sind halt auf einem ziemlich hohen Level. Auch wenn sie scheiße aussehen. Aber es gibt genug, wenn man mal so ein bisschen googelt, halt, hatte ich ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, von so ein paar professionellen Mixern und Masterern, die den Plugins sehr, sehr gute Qualität attestieren. Und wenn man dann halt eben sagt, okay, ich will jetzt nicht so viel Geld ausgeben, aber ich will trotzdem irgendwie Performance und irgendwie ein ordentliches Recording hinkriegen, dann ist das schon definitiv eine valide Option.
Ja, also ich will jetzt auch nicht sagen, das darf man nicht benutzen oder ich will das nicht benutzen. Ich werde es nochmal ausprobieren, aber die Lernkurve war wirklich brutal und vieles fand ich wirklich extrem, also wirklich extrem unübersichtlichen, vollkommen unlogisch, also schlimm. Am Ende ist es Gewohnungssache und ich habe auch so den Eindruck, bei Audiosoftware gehört das irgendwie auch dazu, also so einfache Audiosoftware.
Na, ich bin ja ganz unbefleckt reingegangen. Ich habe keine der Audiotools vorher benutzt. Ich meine, du bist jetzt ja so seit Jahren auf Ableton und hast dich natürlich da jetzt auch so eingefahren. Und ich habe Ableton vorher ausprobiert. Und was hatte ich noch? Von was hatte ich noch eine Demo? Was? Pro Tools oder Cubase? Eins von den beiden. Garage Band und Logic. Und irgendwie fand ich tatsächlich auch so gegen den ersten Abwehrreflex, den ich da aussah. Das soll ich benutzen. Seid ihr denn wahnsinnig? Irgendwie hat es dann doch irgendwie seinen Job getan. Und das war am Ende des Tages das essenziell Wichtige.
Also ich habe mal die Version von Logic 7 probiert. Und das war ja auch so ein krasses Tool. Weil es mir dann auch nicht gelungen ist, einen Trackkin zuzufügen. Und das geilste war, du hattest dann in den Tracks, konntest du Plugins reinmachen. Aber du hattest halt so...
Begrenzte Slots nur.
Du hattest begrenzte Slots. Und vor allen Dingen, du konntest nicht ein Plugin einen Slot nach oben oder nach unten schieben, sondern du konntest nur das Plugin aus dem Slot rausmachen und in einen leeren Slot das gleiche Plugin wieder reinmachen und alles wieder neu einstellen.
Five Plugins are enough for everybody. Das ist übrigens bei dem aktuellen Logic immer noch so, dass sie dir per Default da irgendwie so fünf Slots nur reinrändern für Plugins. Das habe ich auch noch nicht verstanden. Ich vermute, dass man mehr reintun kann, aber so die GUI suggestiert erstmal, ne, fünf ist genug. Überleg dir ganz genau, welche fünf du jetzt haben willst.
Naja, es ist bei Garage Band natürlich genauso. Das müssen irgendwelche komischen technischen Gründe sein. Nur da sieht man es nicht auf Anhieb. Vor allen Dingen gibt es da so ein paar Effekte, die dir Garage Band so quasi als Standard unterjubelt. Die kannst du dann nur ein- und ausschalten. Und die sind auch an fester Stelle.
Ja, bei Garage Band ist es halt wirklich, also das ist wirklich Spielzeug. Das geht für ein gewisses Level ganz gut, aber das geht auch ganz schnell nicht mehr.
Garage Band geht gar nicht. Das ist eine echte Zumutung eigentlich.
Es gibt nicht mal einen Crossfader drin.
Ja, also Garage Band kann man wirklich komplett vergessen. Also wer damit arbeitet und glücklich ist, Gratulation, ich habe das wahrscheinlich noch nie so richtig irgendwie benutzt, aber naja. Ja, was soll mich jetzt noch groß aufregen, aber du bist mir auf jeden Fall jetzt noch so eine Session schuldig. Dann werde ich dir mal zeigen, was ich hier für Herausforderungen habe und ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob wirklich alles gehen wird.
Ich bin mir auch nicht sicher, weil, also ich meine, bis jetzt jede Frage, die ich so hatte und dachte mir so, geht das in Reaper, geht Sampling, geht MIDI, geht dies, geht das, irgendwie ging bisher alles, aber so bei deinem Podcast Setup, das ist ja nun hier auch schon sehr elaboriert, könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass da auch Punkte auftauchen, wo so, hm, keine Ahnung, wie wir das jetzt hier machen. Mal schauen. Aber ja, ich bin dafür zu haben.
Super, nämlich beim Wort. Das kannst du gleich hier bleiben.
Also zum Beispiel, ja, nee, ach.
Envelopes zum Beispiel ist wirklich noch so eine Sache. Das habe ich nicht hinbekommen.
Aber das ist eigentlich voll cool. Also da gibt es ja vor allen Dingen alles.
Das, was ich jetzt hier mache, das geht natürlich alles und nicht nur auf Volumen. Das habe ich nicht hinbekommen.
Mit der Remote oder so generell?
Na, diese parametrische Aufnahme im Reaper. Ich will da wirklich so eine Parameter-Kurve haben.
Ja, das gibt es ja.
Ja, aber ich habe mir nicht gelungen, das zu automatisieren. Ich habe den ganzen Track irgendwie gemutet und das wollte ich nicht. Ich wollte sozusagen nur und so weiter. Aber es interessiert natürlich keinen, der hier zuhört.
Außer wenn wir jetzt alle unsere Tracks automatisch muten.
Genau, am Ende muss ja der Podcast auch alleine stehen, dass wir hier nicht so lange sitzen müssen. Es gibt übrigens eine neue Version heute. 433. Ach echt? Extra für die Sendung jetzt released worden. Mal gucken, ob irgendwo ein Feature-Request von mir berücksichtigt wurde.
Hast du schon welche gestellt? Ja, und die sind durchaus auch empfänglich dafür.
Ja, aber auch dieses Menü. Es ist so vollgeballert und dann sind bestimmte Kommandos in zwei Menüs eingetragen. Also z.B. Insert Track ist halt sowohl unter Insert als auch unter Track. Ja, aber es ist auch alles so crammed irgendwie. Das ist auch so eine Windows-Denke. Ja, das ist genau das, was ich meine. Das ist so eine Windows-Denke. Oder was weiß ich, dann kommt so ein modales Fenster hoch und dann ist oben das Menü reduziert auf einen einzigen Eintragspunkt. Und erst wenn du wieder auf dein Main-Window gehst, ist oben die komplette Menü-Zeite wieder da. Das verhält sich auch einfach nicht wie so eine McIntosh ab. Und dann sind auch so Erklärungen in Menü-Items. Also wo sie hinschreiben, was es tut, und dann nochmal Klammer auf, um das zu erklären. Ich meine, dann nimmt auch gleich einen Namen, der irgendwie sich selbst erklärt. Nein, das muss dann irgendwie alles noch erläutert werden. Und trotzdem versteht man das irgendwie alles nicht. Show all takes in Lanes, in Klammern, when room. Das sind einfach keine Kommandos irgendwie. Was sie auch überhaupt nicht verstanden haben, ist so dieses, welche Sprache eigentlich ein Menü sprechen soll. Also es gibt zum Beispiel ein View-Menü. Aber die Erwartung, dass jetzt alles, was den View beeinflusst, in diesem Menü ist, nein.
Aber das meiste.
Manches. Andere Sachen sind im Menü Options. Options ist ja auch klar, was da ist. Da sind nämlich die Options. Das sind alles Sachen, die man irgendwie anders machen kann.
Optionalen Views.
Und dann gibt es noch Sachen. Also es gibt natürlich überall Kommandos, weil das ist ja das, was in Menüs sozusagen drin ist. Dann gibt es aber auch noch Actions, die im Actions-Menü sind. Woher soll ich jetzt wissen, was eine Action, was ein Kommando, ein Menu-Item ist, oder wann es eine Option ist oder so? Also es ist... Wirklich.
Es ist noch Luft nach oben.
Vor allem sollten uns irgendwelche ehemaligen Windows-Programmierer zuhören, die jetzt irgendwie damit liebäugeln, für den Macintosh Software zu machen. Bitte macht euch mit... Nein, dürft ihr. Aber macht euch bitte damit vertraut. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wenn man zu Besuch ist bei Leuten...
Moment, es gibt ein Dokument, das wird in der Szene HIC genannt. Der Human Interface Guideline. Ein Dokument, das, wenn man es jetzt ausdrucken würde, vielleicht so 300, 400 Seiten hat. Und wer meint, iOS oder macOS-Software machen zu müssen, der sollte das Ding einmal komplett durchlesen. Und dann schläft er drüber und dann liest er es nochmal komplett durch. Und dann hat er eine Chance.
Und dann nochmal. Und dann sind folgende Sachen nicht mehr in eurer Software an. Jetzt müssen wir eigentlich mal so... Die schlimmsten Sachen müssen wir wirklich mal auflesen.
Yes, no, cancel.
Also yes, wenn dein Programm Yes, No-Buttons enthält, dann ist dein Programm funktional kaputt. Das ist einfach schon mal die Wahrheit. Yes, No-Buttons? Nein. Es gibt keine Yes, No-Buttons. Es gibt keinen Grund für Yes, No-Buttons. Und es gibt sehr viele gute Argumente dagegen. Das Kernargument heißt, ein Button ist eine Aktion. Und der Button sollte immer so beschriftet sein, wie die Aktion, die dann ausgelöst wird. Also wenn du sagst, irgendwie soll diese Datei gelöscht werden, dann heißt natürlich nicht dann der Button Yes oder No, sondern er heißt Delete oder Do Not Delete.
Alle Daten nicht löschen, ja, nein?
Das ist genau das Problem.
Auch der Klassiker.
Dieser Apply-Button, das ist auch so eine Krankheit, die irgendwie so aus dieser Windows- und Unix-Welt kommt. Das ist da sehr populär. Gibt es manchmal auch auf Mac. Macht ganz selten auch Sinn, ist aber in den allermeisten Fällen echt Schwachsinn.
Ist ein OK-Button, der das Fenster da lässt.
Genau. Das ist sozusagen etwas andere UI-Behaviour, die aber letztlich genau dasselbe macht, wie OK nur, dass das Fenster nicht zumacht. Warum überhaupt diesen Scheiß-Button? Warum überhaupt ein OK-Button? Warum nicht einfach die Option anklicken und dann ist sie gesetzt? Warum muss ich dann nochmal OK drücken?
Naja, es gibt Optionen, die sich gegenseitig bedingen. Also so nach der Art, mach das an und dann kriegst du weitere Buttons, mach das und das und das und das noch an.
Das ist für die Leute, die in Transaktionen denken.
Genau.
Und dann kannst du mit Apply die ganze Transaktion applyen. Das ist Bequemlichkeit der Programmierer.
Das ist einfach falsch und eine Beleidigung des Benutzers.
Das Öffnen des Fensters beginnt Transaktion und der Apply-Button ist das Commit. Und das Schließen des Fensters ist ein...
Ja, aber so darf man einfach nicht darüber nachdenken. Das ist einfach...
Wenn du eine App baust und die hat eine lokale Datenbank, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit hoch, dass du auch schon was falsch gemacht hast.
Jetzt noch eine ganz wichtige Information. Und Ableton, ihr dürft jetzt bitte auch gleich mitzuhören.
Die Ohren spitzen.
Gibt da auch noch ein paar andere. Der OK-Button wird erstens immer in Großbuchstaben geschrieben. Das kriegt ihr übrigens hin. Aber das ist auch noch so ein Ding. OK, das K ist groß. Und er ist rechts, rechts, nichts links, rechts, rechts vom Cancel-Button. Immer, überall, immer.
Es sei denn, es gibt Ausnahmen. Es sei denn, die Cancel ist die Safe-Option.
Sondern irgendwas anderes.
Es gibt auch Software, die so alle Daten nicht löschen. Ja, nein. Du musstest zweimal Bestätigung, oder dreimal, bei den ersten zwei Bestätigungen ist der OK-Button links. Und bei der letzten Bestätigung ist er rechts, um zu gucken, ob du wirklich wach bist. Kennst du diese Dinger? Wurde sonst immer so, ja, klick, klick, klick. OK, OK, OK. Scheiße, wollte ich doch nicht löschen. Hatte ich noch nicht mal so eine Software, die hat echt drei so eine Abfragen gemacht. Die ersten zwei war der OK-Button links, bei der dritten war der OK-Button rechts, damit du sie nicht durchklicken kannst mit der Maus.
Da hätte wahrscheinlich nie ein OK-Button.
Das hat mir gefallen, weil ich finde mich cool.
Also eigentlich hast du ein OK-Button doch auch nur, wenn es ein Hinweis ist.
Nur ein OK-Button.
Also eigentlich hast du den OK-Button nur dann, wenn der Dialog ein Hinweis ist, den du durchliest, und dann klickst du OK.
Dass du ihn gelesen hast.
Genau, ansonsten hast du keinen OK-Button, weil dann hast du auch was falsch gemacht.
Es gibt schon OK und Cancel.
OK, Cancel und Don't do anything. Was ist da das OK? Nee, ist falsch. Weil wenn du OK sagst, dann ist der OK mit der Aktion beschriftet. OK, ist sowieso ganz... Das ist der Grund, ein Programm nie wieder zu starten. Weil man will so einen Dialog nie sehen.
Never.
Es ist wirklich...
Ist auch nicht so einfach, ja?
Ja, ich will jetzt gar nicht anfangen, hier mit Keyboard, Navigation und diesen ganzen Kram und auch so die Art und Weise, wie hier so mit Kommandos, Keyboard-Shortcuts umgegangen wird. Wie auch immer. Da ist auf jeden Fall noch einiges zu leisten. Und... Und das File-Menü heißt auf Deutsch nicht Datei.
Da weiß man, wo es herkommt.
Sondern Aktenordner.
Aber das ist doch hier auch gar nicht deutsch.
Nein.
Ablage. Aber da weiß man, wo es herkommt. Weil in Windows heißt es Datei.
Ja, das ist ja auch schon falsch verstanden. Das ist ja auch schon falsch kopiert.
Also, das war jetzt so generell gesagt, oder?
Ja, das war so generell gesagt. Weil... Es geht da in dem Menü um das File.
Es gibt noch was, woran man ein Programm erkennen kann, was von Windows kommt. Was ist der Undo-Shortcut? Apfel-Z. Was ist der Redo-Shortcut?
Apfel-Shift-Z.
Richtig. Unter Windows ist Apfel, also Command-Y. Da habe ich damals auch bei Ableton gesagt so, äh, Redo ist kaputt.
Halt, halt, halt. Ich mache auch unter Mac OS 10 immer mit Command-Y mein Redo. Schon seitdem ich OS 10 verwende, mache ich eigentlich mit Command-Y mein Redo mit allen möglichen Programmen. Ich mache in der Regel mein, wenn ich ein Redo machen muss, mache ich es mit Apple Y. Vielleicht mache ich es dann ja nur in der falschen Software.
Nee, du stellst vorher heimlich intuitiv deine Tastatur auf Amerikanisch und machst dann Apple Y.
Also in Text-Edit geht das auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht so.
In Text-Made geht es auch nicht.
Ich schlafe ja normalerweise schon.
Und dann natürlich solche Sachen wie, wie viele Klicks muss ich machen, um in ein Eingabefeld alles zu selektieren? Oder was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich in einem Eingabefeld einen Cursor habe und ich drücke, oder ich habe, genau, ich habe alles selektiert und drücke nach hinten oder drücke nach vorne, drücke nach oben oder nach unten, Cursor-Tasten und so. Das ist ja auch alles komplett anders in Windows.
Icon-Perspektive ist auch noch so eine tolle Sache.
Ja, dazu musst du erstmal Icons haben.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Um jetzt vielleicht mal diese ganze UI-Depasse abzurunden. Also, wenn das so ist unter Windows, dann weiß ich, warum ich das immer gemieden habe. Das ist echt schwer. Es ist kein Wunder, dass die Leute so verzweifelt sind und ihre Computer hassen.
Es ist auch schade, dass die Reaper-Jungs auf Windows geboren wurden und nicht auf Macs. Sonst wäre die Software wahrscheinlich jetzt schon nochmal zehnmal geiler.
Ich habe auch so den Eindruck, die haben keinen Mac. Weil, ich meine, dann hätten sie ja vielleicht mal das Trackpad ausprobiert und festgestellt, dass irgendwie by default ihre ganzen Gesten falsch rum sind. Also sie folgen nicht dem Native Scrolling sozusagen. Ich musste erstmal alles in den Settings. Kannst du das dann natürlich reversen. So, muss ich aber auch erstmal machen. Und sie verwechseln auch Zoom und Scroll. Also man benutzt dann unter Windows ja auch mal manche Sachen für die aber witzigsten Dinge. Also dieses Rad wird dann zum Zoomen benutzt. In der Timeline.
Wobei ich das...
Ich will natürlich, und wenn ich jetzt auf meinem Trackpad mit zwei Finger hoch und runter gehe, was ja quasi das ist, was man auch mit dem Rad, mit dem Scrollrad eigentlich macht, dann zoomt er auch. Aber ich will nicht zoomen, sondern ich will meinen...
Ja, aber Zoom mit Scrollrad, das ist so eine Krankheit. Ich meine, das Problem hat doch auch Google Maps. Also alle sagen immer Google Maps wäre so eine tolle Oberfläche, aber sie kriegen ja noch nicht mal Scroll.
Aber ich muss sagen, also Pinch to Zoom ist halt auch manchmal einfach zu unpräzise. Also manchmal, wenn ich meine externe Maus mit so einem Ratter, Ratter, Ratter Scroll hat, dann ist mir das ehrlich gesagt tatsächlich manchmal lieber, weil es so definierte...
Wir pinchen funktioniert gar nicht, das ist viel zu unpräzise.
Da wabert dir das einmal so über den Screen und du weißt nicht, wo du bist.
Shift, ja, ein Modifier drücken.
Ja, das finde ich auch.
Kontroll, irgendwas so, aber nicht das normale, ich bewege mich in meinem Dokument XY auf irgendwas anderes matchen. Er kommt auch manchmal durcheinander, also das ist auch so eine Krankheit. Man scrollt irgendwie nach links, rechts, links, rechts und auf einmal ist irgendwie alles zersüht. Spricht dir irgendwie eure Events noch irgendwie klar?
So, und wem das jetzt noch nicht genug Audiothemen war und sich jetzt wieder beschwert wird, dass wir die Audiothemen abwirken? Wer kann sich jetzt mal im neuen Podcast?
Wir reden über Bananen-Interfaces.
Du kannst mal deinen Podcast mal pluggen. Ich habe reingehört, wie du mitbekommen hast.
Ja, genau. Du warst ja gleich einer der ersten Korrekturgeber. Ich habe jetzt auch mal diesen Podcast ausprobiert. Die ganze Toolchain durchgegangen. Also der Podcast hat erstmal 300 Hertz natürlich. Und irgendein Mobile-Max-Hörer hat sich schon Twitter-Account und Domain registriert und macht nichts damit und hat auch nicht auf meine Nachrichten reagiert. Mahnend Anmerk. Aber wir haben es jetzt halt 300 Hertz ausgeschrieben. Also 300 die Zahl und dann herzausgeschrieben.de. Und das kam so zustande, dass einer auf ab.net mich angehauen hat, einer der Mobile-Max-Hörer, der Felix, und meinte, ja wie sieht es denn aus? Irgendwie redet ihr dann doch immer nicht lange genug über die Audio-Themen, wollen wir nicht mal uns zusammensetzen und ein Podcast machen. Ich kenne ihn halt nicht. Und dachte mir aber, weil ich auch darauf Bock hatte, ja okay, lasst mal machen, ging es ein bisschen auf ab.net hin und her mit Direct Messages sogar. Und dann bin ich letztes Wochenende mal hingefahren und dann haben wir halt mal losgelegt. Und ich habe meinen Focusrite Sapphire Pro 40 mitgenommen und wir haben ganz unkonventionell mit Kondensator-Mikrofonen aufgenommen und nicht mit den Industriestandards, den Biodynamic-Headsets. Und wir haben uns halt so richtig die Großmembrane quasi... Das meiste Feedback bezog sich tatsächlich darauf, dass der Sound so angenehm anders ist als in der Meta-Eben tatsächlich. Also Leute haben gemeint, wow, das klingt ja so schön natürlich und offen und...
Ja, Großmembrane sind geil, aber Großmembrane sind in unserer Situation ja mit fünf Leuten, das ist schwierig.
Und natürlich wir saßen halt also bei Felix dann im Begierzimmer quasi an so einem kleinen Tisch mit den Schattiven und so ein bisschen so wie die Henne auf der Stange. Und dann darfst du ja auch nicht so links und rechts davon abweichen, weil sonst gleich irgendwie die Sprachqualität leidet. Aber nichtsdestotrotz relativ Low-Tech, ohne Expander, ohne Kompressor, ohne Noise Gate einfach ins Mikro gelabert. Und dafür ist es doch erstaunlich gut geworden. Ja, Moment, genau. Haben wir also zwei Stunden vollgequatscht, ganz einfach. Und jetzt auf dem Weg schon ganz viele neue Ideen gesammelt. Und glücklicherweise gab es jetzt auch schon einiges an Feedback und neue Ideen. Es wird also weitergehen. Und dann ging es natürlich an die Produzenten-Toolchain. Dann habe ich mich an die ganzen Stichwörter, die bei Mobile Max hier schon durchgesprudelt sind, auf Phonik, Podlove, Podlove Player, WordPress und so alles mal durchgewurstet. Als erstes auf Phonik, wobei ich jetzt, ja, da... Also es hat funktioniert, kann man so sagen. Hat mir halt Files gerendert, hat irgendwelche Filter appliziert. Ich weiß jetzt, also den großen Unterschied zwischen vor und nachher konnte ich jetzt spontan nicht feststellen, aber ich hab jetzt auch nicht wirklich sehr konzentriert drauf gehört, aber es war ganz nett, dass halt schon gleich dann eben die Files so rauskommen und es bestimmt auch alles ganz gut dann noch gefiltert und so hinterher gewesen. Und dann hab ich mir halt noch ein WordPress aufgesetzt, dann irgendwie das Podlove installiert, dann deine viel zu langen und viel zu verbosen Screencast anguckt, obwohl man natürlich sagen muss, dass es gut ist, dass es sie überhaupt gibt, weil...
Ich hab durchgeskippt, es hat gereicht.
Ja, ja, ich hab dann auch geskippt, aber ich hatte immer so Angst, dass ich jetzt so weit skippe und dann doch wieder so die essentielle Option überspringe und dann mach ich irgendwie die anderen Haken, dann geht's nicht und dann muss ich doch wieder alles gucken. Ja, ich hab's halt da so im Web einfach so abgespielt. Kann man auch doppelte Geschwindigkeit klicken?
Na ja, also die HTML5-Player können theoretisch beim Browser auch auf eine Speed-Attribut zurückgreifen. Beim Podlove-Player ist das derzeit noch nicht drin.
Also ich hab mir das einfach installiert und hab mal dann einfach gemacht, ohne irgendwelche Screencasts anzugucken. Und das mit dem Slack war das Einzige, wo ich drüber gestolpert bin.
Ja, also er hat ja Recht. Und das kommt auch. Und ich will die auch mal auf Englisch machen. Und dann werd ich auch so einzelne Bereiche in 10 Minuten machen. Aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich das gemacht hab, ging's überhaupt erst mal darum, eine Community andocken zu lassen, die sich dafür interessiert. Und da war das ganz hilfreich.
Nee, und es war ja auch alles gut. Bei mir, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, ich bin an irgendeinem Punkt, hat so ein bisschen gehakelt. Ich wusste nicht, wie dieser Player dann letztendlich da reinkommt. Und wie das mit diesen File Assets und wie, wo die Files dann jetzt letztendlich reinkommen. Und irgendwie kam halt nicht dieser Dialog, wo ich jetzt sage, hier, so heißt das File auf dem Server, nimm's von da. Und irgendwie muss ich dann doch nochmal kurz in den Screencast reinskippen, um dann so, ah, okay, ich leg erst die Assets an. Und dann gibt's im Episoden-Fenster da die Checkboxen, dann klick ich die an und dann kann ich den Namen eingeben. Und dann lad ich sie hoch und dann findet er die. Und dann war auch alles gut. Das hat auch nicht lange gedauert.
Aber es ist am Schluss relativ schmerzfrei. Vor allen Dingen, wenn du auf Phonic damit verbindest, kannst du dann auch sagen, so, ah, ich möchte nachhinein noch Formate hinzufügen. Und wenn Phonic noch deine Ursprungsdatei hat, kannst du sagen, renn da mal nach da raus. Er lädst die automatisch hoch und du sagst, hier, bitte jetzt auch.
Jetzt auch mit Opus.
Also, letztendlich, ich meine, ich hab's ja so an einem Abend da zusammengelötet, das ging schon alles. Und dann haben ja die Leute jetzt auch schon alle ganz fleißig hören können, das war ja auch schon mal super. Dann hab ich auch das erste Mal im eigenen Leib deine Beschwerde oder deine Probleme mit diesen Feed-Statistiken erlebt, weil ich bin uns ja pivig sozusagen immer, und vielleicht kann man da auch irgendwie so Feeds so einrichten, dass sie das tracken, aber ob der Player ein File abspielt oder nicht, wird da halt nicht getrackt. Und dann hab ich halt SysStat minus IfStat1 auf dem Terminal laufen lassen und da ich sonst keine großen Dateien hoste, konnte ich dann sehen, sobald es über die einen MBit-Marke mal springt im Outgoing, muss es sich jetzt wohl um Podcasthöre handeln. Da haben wir jetzt schon 60 GB rausgeschoben. Und die Files hab ich ja relativ groß encoded, mp3 mit 128 Kbit. Oh, gute Frage.
Spielt er da auch Musik ab oder gibt es einen guten Grund?
Nee, einfach so im Zweifel mehr als weniger. Na ja, von daher ist jetzt erstmal alles ganz gut geglückt und war mal ganz interessant, auf jeden Fall diese ganze Toolchain da zu durchlaufen. Jetzt auch bei iTunes angemeldet, festgestellt, dass sie auch Podcast-Feeds ja irgendwie bedächtig sich erstmal anschauen, bevor sie das in ihr Directory aufnehmen. Das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht habe, ist halt Bit.Love heißt es, weil da habe ich irgendwie noch nicht so ganz gecheckt, wie jetzt.
Ganz einfach.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, aber...
Bit.Love machst du ja einen Account und dann trägst du deinen Feed ein.
Das Einzige, was verwirrt ist, dass es dauert, bis er da ist. Weil es so aussieht, als ob es gleich kommen müsste, aber es dauert irgendwie.
Ja, aber jetzt bin ich halt da voll drin.
Tja, einmal Podcaster, immer Podcaster.
Ja, also ich meine, seitdem ich jetzt hier Mobile Max mache, habe ich jetzt auch schon ganz vielen Leuten gesagt, jeder sollte mal irgendwie einen Podcast machen, weil...
Aber jetzt, wo du selber auch einen produzierst, dann können wir dann auch nachher noch Initiatons-Ritos vollziehen und dich mit dem Geheimwissen versorgen. Nur für die es ausgewählte Elite gibt.
Okay, ich bin gespannt.
Ich habe ja neulich die Webseite von der Band neu gemacht und habe halt die Songs, die wir bisher so veröffentlicht haben.
Dein tolles Lied.
So direkt jetzt, da mache ich jetzt mal einen Podcast raus mit Podlove und so. Es gibt auch richtige Tools.
Wie war nochmal die Webseite?
Die neue müsste ich gucken. Die Domain ist noch nicht umgezogen. Das ist das Problem.
Die Domain ist noch nicht umgezogen?
Kann man das jetzt aufrufen? Ja, im Prinzip schon. Warte mal, lass mich mal.
Egal, ich glaube, das tolle Lied habe ich sowieso hier.
Ja, ja, du kannst auch das tolle Lied spielen. Wie auch immer. Das waren irgendwie so fünf Songs oder so. Die habe ich halt dann noch mal als Podcast-Episoden in Podlove eingeblendet. Und das hat relativ schmerzfrei funktioniert bis zu dem Punkt, wo ich dann irgend so eine Frage Tim stellte und er nur so meinte, mach uns doch mal einen Admin-Account zu deinem Wordpress. Und ich so, ja, hier. Und dann fünf Minuten später, jetzt ist gefixt. Ich weiß nicht, was es war.
Ich kann dir sagen, deswegen kommen auch gerade so wenig neue Features, weil die letzten zwei Wochen im Wesentlichen dafür draufging, einem Wordpress irgendwie so ein bisschen auf die Sprünge zu kommen oder zu begreifen, wie bekloppt das da intern funktioniert, um diese URLs irgendwie besser unter Kontrolle zu haben. Und da sind wir so verschiedene Fehler reingelaufen, die unter anderem dazu führen, dass irgendwie der Artikel zwar auf der Übersichtseite ist, aber wenn du dann den Einzelnen anklickst unter seiner eigentlichen URL, dass da dann nicht gefunden wird und so weiter. Dieses ganze Routing von URLs, das ist total im Arsch. Gott sei Dank kann man irgendwie den Denis jetzt irgendwie mit im Boot da bei Podlauf, der sehr viel Wordpress-Erfahrung hat und der hat jetzt irgendwie, wie es aussieht, einen Fix gefunden, mit dem wir vielleicht tatsächlich wirklich jetzt alle URLs wieder garantieren können. Das heißt, wir können mit ein bisschen Daumen drücken, auch nach einer Migration die alten URLs vollständig beibehalten, was bisher noch unklar war, ob das überhaupt geht. Das kann ich ja auch gar nicht erklären, weil das will man auch gar nicht verschwinden. Abgründe. Dieses Wordpress ist an der Stelle echt alt. Echt schlimm. So, und da bist du reingelaufen, da sind noch andere reingelaufen. Da wäre noch ein paar rein.
Den Link in den Chat, da ist das neue Blog. Aber das hat halt, wie gesagt, die Domain noch nicht.
Ich verstehe ja das sozusagen auch bei Uberspace.
Bei Uberspace unter...
Der Martin Dieselhorst Vierer.
Genau, so heißt die Band.
Was fliegen die Kuh?
Soll ich mal das tolle Lied von Roddy spielen? Wollen wir mal hier eine kleine Musikpause machen?
Na bitte machen.
Machen wir mal eine kleine Musikpinkelpause hier.
Oder eine Bierholpause.
Genau, alles das.
Jetzt habe ich etwas sagen können. Oder eben am Kühlschrank. Nimm dir Essen mit, wir fahren nach Brandenburg.
Großes Kino Rolli, ich liebe diesen Song.
Ja, der verfolgt mich schon.
Wie alt ist er?
Zu Recht.
2007 oder so, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Er hatte aber recht, das ist ein echtes Problem. Diese Minen hier. Ist Berlin nicht dieser internationalen Echtung der Landminen beigetreten? Warum haben wir hier so ein Problem damit?
Ich lebe an Neukölln, das ist am schlimmsten.
Das sagt jeder von seinem eigenen.
Ja, aber nach einer Weile hat man ja auch so ein Bauchgefühl entwickelt und läuft eigentlich gar nicht mehr rein. Also wann bist du das letzte Mal in Hundekot gelaufen?
2007.
Gestern habe ich wieder welchen aus dem Schuh gekratzt.
Echt?
Ich bin auch die ganze Zeit dabei, die Kinder davon abzuhalten, in irgendetwas reinzutreten.
Aber lass sie doch mal reintreten, dann kriegen sie später nicht so Allergien und so weiter. Du weißt schon, die Abwehrkräfte müssen ja auch gebildet werden.
Genau. Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Sprudelter.
So, dann haben wir es jetzt.
Haben wir denn noch irgendwie Themen? Wir könnten noch über Ups reden. Ja, wir können auch Schluss machen.
Ich habe mir eine kurze Sendung versprochen.
Ich habe keine kurze Sendung versprochen. Wie kommst du drauf?
Was erlaube. Aber sag mal, Tim, was mir gerade noch so einfällt zu dieser Mikrofonierung und den Headsets und dem Sound und so weiter, der Metaebene, den jetzt so diverse Hörer halt bei mir so angesprochen haben. Was ich ja bei diesen Talkshow-Sendungen, bei diesen amerikanischen und ich weiß nicht, ob es die Deutschen jetzt auch mittlerweile machen, also weißt du schon so Letterman, Leno, Conan O'Brien, wie sie alle heißen. Die haben ja alle so was an der Krawatte geklippt. Dann haben sie auf dem Tisch auch nochmal so einen großen membranen Mikro so irgendwie einfach so stehen. Wahrscheinlich um halt nochmal so die räumliche...
Ich glaube, diese großen Mikros stehen einfach nur weil sie geil aussehen.
Ich glaube, die machen vielleicht auch sogar so noch ein bisschen mehr Atmosphäre.
Nee, Atmosphäre ist das letzte, was du da willst.
Die hängen doch bestimmt Mikros rein für den Ambiance-Noise von irgendwie Publikum oder so.
Das steht halt immer so auf dem Tisch.
Die stehen da auf dem Tisch, weil das so amerikanische Tradition ist, sowas auf dem Tisch steht zu haben.
Ich würde das gerne mal ausprobieren.
Probier es aus.
Ich bringe mal eins mit.
Alles Unfug. Du brauchst noch keins mitbringen. Ich habe hier noch genug. Bei jedem Podcaster, der eine Weile unterwegs ist, stehen Großmembranen-Mikrofone auch im Schrank.
Geil.
Weil irgendwann hast du die mal ausprobiert, weil du wolltest unbedingt damit arbeiten. Und dann hast du festgestellt, die nehmen zu viel Raum ein, die nehmen zu viel Platz weg. Die sind dir im Blick. Entweder stehen sie immer vor dir und du kannst deinen Tisch nicht benutzen oder du musst einen komischen Arm installieren. Der liegt ja die ganze Zeit irgendwie im Gesicht und du kannst ihn nicht angucken.
Okay, pass auf, ich habe die Lösung.
Chat meint gerade, die sind nur Attrappe.
Alle Podcaster, die jetzt dieses Problem haben und überhaupt nicht mehr wissen wohin mit diesem großmengbaren Mikrofon, die können wir gerne zu mir schicken. Ich nehme die mit Kusshand, denn zum Aufnehmen zum Beispiel von Gitarrenverstärkern und auch anderen Instrumenten sind die auf jeden Fall sehr...
Instrumentenmikrofone sind doch keine Großmembranen.
Wie bitte?
Instrumentenmikrofone sind doch auch keine Großmembranen.
Also man nimmt zum Beispiel für einen Verstärker einen SM57, das ist halt sehr mittenlastig und kriegt halt so sehr den Bite, wie man so schön sagt, den Mittenbite und dann hältst du noch einen Kondensator daneben und dann, die beiden gemischt, macht so einen richtig schönen, warmen, runden Gitarrensound.
Kondensator, aber doch kein Großmembran.
Doch, Großmembran und warmen Kondensatormikrofon.
Also für Gesangsaufnahmen macht es sich verdammt gut.
Auch für Schlagzeug kannst du das nehmen.
Ich nehme Chor mit Großmembran auf, das macht sich sehr gut.
Klar, natürlich, wenn ich alleine spreche, dann, wenn du einen gut isolierten Raum hast, da ist dieser hier für meinen Geschmack noch nicht mal ausreichend isoliert, auch wenn ich hier schon ganz viel gemacht habe, dann ist natürlich so ein Großmembran Mikrofon schon cool. Aber dann willst du auch eigentlich gleich einen Neumann funzeln. Ich war ja gerade auf der Musikmesse in Frankfurt. Ach, warst du da? Okay.
Mal wieder Gitarrenversteiger angucken.
Ja, nee, und dann komme ich ja auch so beim Neumann-Stand und die sind mal ganz fies. Die haben dann immer so ihr komplettes Line-up. So von links nach rechts wird es halt immer irgendwie so, es ist immer zehnmal so teuer. Und kannst dann immer so testen, einfach Kopfhörer aufsetzen und so, obwohl es natürlich höllisch laut ist und pipapo, du merkst einfach, wie sensitiv diese Scheiße ist. Also wirklich, man ist schon die Einstiegsmikrofone, die glaube ich preislich, ja ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wo die preislich liegen, aber das ist alles irgendwie vierstellig, oder ist das kleinste sogar noch? Die sind schon ganz gut so, aber du merkst dann immer nur einen riesen Schritt immer von Modell zu Modell, dass sie das schaffen, das irgendwie noch ansprechbarer zu machen. Da war so eins, das war irgendwie so groß und das roch geradezu nach irgendwie ich nehme jede Frequenz aus, wenn du mir entgegenschmeißt. Und wenn du da irgendwie zu laut geraunt hast, oder auch nur so das Echo der ganzen Halle, das kam dann irgendwie so bretta zurück, das hat mich schon richtig schockiert. Das ging gar nicht mehr. Aber das ist dann sozusagen optimal. Das ist ja auch der Radiostandard. Also wenn du so bei Fritz bist, ich muss kurz mal gucken, das ist glaube ich hier dieses U87.
Für sportliche.
Ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen der Standard. Ich glaube, das sind so die Dinger, die bei Fritz so zu finden sind.
Das sieht aus wie mein T-Bone.
Das sehen so ähnlich aus.
Rollen wir mal runter zum Preis.
Ja, das T-Bone kostet wahrscheinlich so 169 oder so was.
Ja, 60 glaube ich oder 50.
Was denkst du, kostet das Neumann?
Tausende Euro, so wie ich die kenne.
Entspannter, 2395 Euro für ein Mikrofon.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich hatte ehrlich gesagt ja voll Angst davor, dass wir jetzt halt irgendwie da mit zwei so einen Großmembran-Kondensatoren uns gegenüber auch noch sitzen.
Und da hat es bestimmt noch nicht mal USB.
Und es hat aber erstaunlich gut funktioniert. Du hast es ja gehört, oder? Also das klang noch nicht schlecht. Und wir saßen in einem kleinen WG-Zimmer ohne Schallisolierung. Wir saßen so direkt quasi uns gegenüber mit den Mikros. Also es war jetzt nicht unerträglich irgendwie.
Ja gut, also klang nicht schlecht. Es ist jetzt relativ. Also was du ja auch, es gibt ja auch praktische Anwendungen. Und natürlich ist hier die Brillanz dieser Mikrofone, die wir hier so verwenden, nicht so groß. Ja klar, du kannst mit so einem kleinen Mini-Mikrofon einfach nicht denselben Hub haben. Die sind schon okay, so diese Headset-Mikrofone. Aber die haben natürlich beileibe nicht so die Kraft, wirklich die Stimme so nachzuzeichnen, wie man das mit so einem Großmembran machen kann, weil er einfach die Bassfrequenzen nicht so mit aufnimmt. Aber sie machen irgendwie auch einen schönen neutralen, schön trockenen Sound und der ist ganz gut, weil du willst halt möglichst wenig überstrahltes Signal haben, weil umso mehr Geschepper und Echo du da drin hast und umso mehr Raum du aufnimmst, umso schwieriger wird es am Ende, das Ganze in lauten Umgebungen zu dekodieren. Also wenn du in einer Straßenbahn bist oder im Auto, was nicht ganz leise ist, Autos sind heutzutage teilweise gut gedämmt, aber wenn du einfach viel Background-Noise hast, öffentlicher Nahverkehr ist ein typisches Beispiel, wenn du hier so mit der U2 durch die Gegend rumpelst, mit Quitsch, Quitsch, Quitsch und 1000 Leute quatschen und der ganze Lärm, dann ist es halt wichtig, dass einfach das Signal trocken und gut trennbar rüberkommt. Das ist eigentlich das Primärziel und nicht unbedingt, dass jetzt wirklich die Stimme völlig...
Aber was ja auch noch so ein Tipp ist, ist ja Bändchen-Mikrofon. Das ist ja so das Richtige für diese... Genau, für diese... Und gab es sonst noch was auf der Musikmesse Frankfurt?
Ach so, na ja, doch. Ich habe mir ein Audiogerät ausführlich erläutern lassen von RMI. Das Fireface UFX ist das große, ja. Das ist nicht billig, aber ist schon ganz schön fancy. Also es ist so, die machen echt fast alles richtig. Das ist schon erstaunlich.
Hatt ich ja auch schon mal gesagt, dass ich auch in so Musikerkreisen kenne, die dann halt auch so auf der Bühne und so weiter, die nehmen alle irgendwie das Fireface, weil mein, das ist es einfach.
Ja, also es ist schon nochmal so eine Investition, aber damit könnte ich so mein mobiles Studio ganz gut machen. Das Einzige, was mich stört ist, dass halt du das Teil nicht direkt steuern kannst, ohne nochmal einen Rechner zu haben, wo die Software drauf läuft. Also die Steuerung geht sozusagen nur über ihr RME-USB-basiertes Protokoll. Und das haben sie irgendwie einmal in der Rechnerversion und einmal in der iPad-Version. Aber dann hast du halt auch nur so eine Standard-Software, die natürlich alles abbildet. Und nicht so ein reduziertes Set. Und dann haben sie zwar innerhalb der App auch OSC. Da mach ich so, ah super, OSC, alles klar. Also ist es so, naja, okay, dann lass ich halt die scheiß Software noch laufen, wenn du unbedingt das OSC noch umsetzen musst. Und so anstatt, dass er da irgendwie eine Bridge da direkt über den USB macht, wie auch immer. Und dann hat er so, ja, aber da gibt es da noch eine Einschränkung und so. Wir haben dann irgendwie erst mal so, wir machen das erst mal so wie dieses Mackie-Teil. Das ist so eine Krankheit in dieser ganzen Musikszene, dass man immer erst mal Mackie-Control macht. Und so wie Mackie das macht. Und dann hast du so sinnlose Sachen wie so Bank-Switching. Hast immer so acht Kanäle und dann musst du die Banks umschalten. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen so ein modales Interface, was sozusagen immer so die richtige Einstellung. Der Regler 1 steuert nicht die 1, sondern er steuert die 1 oder die 9 oder die und so weiter. Na ja, dann mach ich so, wie wär's denn mal mit so einfach so jeder Kontrol hat so seine eigene OSC-Adresse und so. Und dann so, ja, sie arbeiten dran.
Herbst.
Zumindest haben sie das verstanden. Das wäre dann auch immer so Moden. Hab mich dann noch mit dem Chef noch mal ein bisschen unterhalten. Das wäre dann auch immer so Moden und so. Weiß der Geier, was die nächstes Jahr einem alles erzählen irgendwie? Die kommen immer an und wollen immer irgendwas, was gerade so eine heiße Scheiße ist. Und zwei Jahre später kräht da irgendwie keine Ahnung mehr danach. Jetzt wollen sie gerade halt alle OSC direkt adressieren. Will ich auch. Aber immerhin, es war schon mal so ein Gespräch.
Hast du auch zu ihm gesagt, das will ich auch noch in zwei Jahren?
Ich habe meinen Punkt schon recht klar gemacht, aber ich bin ja sowieso für die irgendwie keine Größe, weil wenn ich da ankomme, guten Tag, ich bin mein mobiles Radiostudio und so, da rieche ich nicht jetzt unbedingt gerade nach Massenmarkt. Gut, den haben die eh nicht, aber die orientieren sich natürlich an den Musikern. Aber ich war dann nach einem bisschen Gespräch, habe ich sie eben so ein bisschen entlockt, war das ganz interessant, dass sie da durchaus auch für sich so eine Chance sehen. Ich meine so, so eigentlich sind sie ja klassisch eher so Audio-Interface, so schließe ich an meinen Computer an, damit ich meine Sachen ranbamme, aber sie haben jetzt auch schon begriffen, dass sie durch diese ganze Automatisierung auch Funktionen übernehmen, für die die Leute halt heutzutage sehr viel teurere Mixer-Environments, Digitalmixer und so weiter machen. Und da sind sie natürlich doch recht konkurrenzfähig. Und von daher glaube ich, werden sie diesen Weg schon mitgehen. Das ist wirklich ein nettes Gerät und vor allem das erste Gerät, was einfach mal selber aufnehmen kann. Und das machen sie halt auch konsequent mit Multitrack und so, und dann kann es Ein- und Ausgänge machen, und dann kann es überall Kompressoren und Expander draufschmeißen. Schon solide. Richtig erstaunlich. Deutschland und Audio, das ist eine interessante Paarung.
Da geht was.
Ist das eine deutsche Firma?
Alles ist eigentlich...
Eigentlich ist alles deutsch.
Naja, ich meine im Software-Bereich, alle großen Audio-Workstation-Programme kommen aus Deutschland.
Pro Tools?
Nein, Pro Tools nicht. Nee, Pro Tools ist eine Ausnahme.
GarageBand nicht.
Doch.
Doch. Ist doch.
Wie hieß es denn?
Project Encouragement.
eMagic hieß die Firma, die Apple gut kauft hat. Eine Ausgründung aus den Leuten Steinberg, die Cubis gemacht haben, übrigens.
Was auch Hamburg ist, sozusagen. Also auch deutsch. Ableton, auch deutsch.
Und GarageBand ist ja nur eine andere Oberfläche für Logic. Da ist ja gleich ein Engine drin.
Hatten die Magic nicht diese Sequencer gemacht, die dann sogar in der Fernsehwerbung irgendwie im Privatsen an damals kam?
Bei Audio-Hardware gibt es ja, da sind ja die Asiaten, also hier irgendwie Mucky, Kork und so. Da gibt es ja irgendwie Boss, diese ganzen irgendwie Hardware-Lieferanten. Letztens habe ich mal geguckt, so bei irgendwelchen Mischpulten und so weiter, da kommt ja übelst viel Zeug einfach auch hardwareseitig sozusagen aus dem asiatischen Raum. Weil Kork und Mucky klang jetzt nicht unbedingt so asiatisch.
Dann gibt es aber noch Native Instruments. Kork und dieser ganze Kram auf Deutschland.
Also Ableton ist wiederum eine Ausgründung von Native Instruments.
Ja, also ich sage ja auch nicht alles kommt aus Deutschland. Aber ich meine, kennst du überhaupt einen Software-Genre, wo Deutschland so eine Rolle spielt? Irgendwann anderes, außer vielleicht SAP.
Ja, ja, Herr Liener hast recht, das ist schon okay.
Das ist erstaunlich. Ich finde das irgendwie erstaunlich.
Steuersoftware für Deutschland.
Die E-Mail.
Oh man, da habt ihr die Beitrag von Sascha Lobo auf Spiegel Online zu die E-Mail gelesen. Das ist ein großartiger Abgesang irgendwie. Die E-Fail. Die E-Fail ist ein De-Bug.
Habt ihr diese Preisliste von der Telekom dazu gesehen zur De-Mail? Man bekommt ein 500 Megabyte Postfach. Jede 100 Megabyte drüber kostet 59 Cent.
So, noch lachen wir.
Das kommt nicht. Das ist so tot. Das ist so dermaßen tot wie noch irgendwas. Na ja, Musikmesse. Hab ich sonst noch etwas Interessantes entdeckt?
Du bist nur für dieses Interface dahin gefahren.
Tatsächlich bin ich im Wesentlichen wegen dieses... Das war mein Ziel. Ich wollte darüber reden. Und dann bin ich natürlich noch ein bisschen rumgeguckt, habe auch noch zwei Hörer getroffen. Und ob ich noch etwas Interessantes entdeckt? Es gibt da nicht so viel Interessantes zu entdecken. Also die Sachen, die ich haben wollte, die gibt es wieder alle nicht.
Ja, nur weil du dich nicht für Gitarren interessierst.
Das kann natürlich sein. Ich habe auch noch so nach Funkstrecken geguckt und so weiter. Weil es gibt jetzt von Sennheiser eine Funkstrecke, die komplett zulassungsfrei ist, so im 1800 MHz-Bereich. Weil bei den anderen hast du immer das Problem, die steht dann in Konflikt mit DVB-T und LTE und Pipapo und musst da anmelden und Lizenzgebühren zahlen. Das kannst du natürlich alles ignorieren. Aber ich dachte mir, bevor ich da in die Technologie einsteige, dann kaufe ich mir lieber was, was lizenzfrei ist. Das ist halt nur dahingehend eingeschränkt, dass du nur maximal zwölf Kanäle da irgendwie fahren kannst, was für mich jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade eine Einschränkung ist. Weil ich will ja jetzt hier nicht unbedingt einen Tatort produzieren. Ja, gibt es aber leider noch nicht so kompakt, wie ich es haben wollte. Was ist sonst noch? Ansonsten nervt mich irgendwie diese ganze Messe. Lichtblick ist bloß immer wieder Herr Schneider, den ich hier schon mal bei CAE hatte, über Synthesizer. Weißt du, der so diesen ganzen Vertrieb macht für handgebaute Synthesizer.
Oh, das war eine geile CAE.
Ja, und der hat mittlerweile es geschafft, vom Laden richtig zum Vertrieb zu werden. Und der vertreibt mittlerweile einfach alles, was Rang und Namen hat. Also weltweit alles, was sozusagen so die Creme de la Creme von handgebauten Synthesizern ist, hat er im Angebot. Ist er jetzt sozusagen. Und der hat immer den coolsten Stand auf dieser ganzen Musikmesse. Leider hatte ich ein bisschen wenig Zeit, aber es war nett. Joa, der Rest ist eigentlich eher so meh. Ah, nee, dann habe ich mir noch hier irgendwie mich mit den Jungs von Fokus Ride noch ein bisschen angefreundet, weil die ja massiv in diese Dante-Ethernet-AVB-Geschichte, die ich hier auch verwende, reingehen. Da hatte ich irgendwie so ein paar Support-Fragen, da konnten die mir weiterhelfen. Und das entwickelt sich eigentlich ganz gut. Also ich glaube ja auch immer noch, dass das so der nächste große Durchbruch wird für so Ethernet-Kram, dass es einfach mal ein Standard gibt, wie Audio und Video da übertragen werden. Dieser AVB-Standard, der kommt so langsam und wird jetzt auch langsam so in die Switches eingebaut. Hast du dich eigentlich schon mal mit beschäftigt, Clemens? AVB-Standard, also Audio-Video-Broadcasting über Ethernet.
Ich habe es mir nur mal angeguckt, als wir uns mal über deinen Pult unterhalten haben, um den Multicast-Thema. Aber ich habe da weder länger drin rumgedräst, noch irgendwie mal was implementiert worden.
Ja, weil das so meines Wissens im Wesentlichen ist eigentlich nur noch so an den großen Switch-Herstellern, an deren Bedürfnisse, wie denn das alles korrekt zu switchen ist, hängt. Aber das definiert ja im Prinzip so einen Standardweg, wie man Audio und Video über Ethernet überträgt. Und ja, das weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, wann das durchbreitet.
Da ist jetzt die Frage, wer sich da an welche Standards annähert oder annähern sollte.
Der AVB-Standard halt.
Ja, aber wenn der sagt, wir benutzen Ethernet, dann können Sie erstmal bei der IEEE nachschauen. Was da schon geht. Nochmal, wer muss sich da annähern? Soll sich die Switch-Hersteller an den AVB-Standard annähern?
Nein, der Standard wird sozusagen noch fertiggestellt in den Anforderungen, die die Switches haben in dem Bereich. Das eigentliche Datenübertragungsrahmen, Protokoll, Timing und so weiter, das funktioniert ja alles schon. Aber wenn das dann in Large-Scale-Networks ausgebreitet wird, wie sich das dann konkret bei den Switches dann verhält, das ist mein letzter Stand, wo es da noch hängt, keine Ahnung, in welchem Zustand sich dieser Standard insgesamt befindet. Aber da bewegt sich schon so einiges. Ansonsten war die Musikmesse eher so meh. Meh? Ja, für mich ist das irgendwie nichts. Viel zu laut. DJs, die überall unheimlichen Lärm erzeugen. Man kann sich nirgends so richtig unterhalten. Das nervt. So, haben wir's. Oder wollen wir noch mal? Das interessiert mich noch hier, Roddy. Status Board.
Status Board.
Für das iPad.
Für iPad.
Von Panic.
Genau.
Du hast das ausprobiert.
Ich hab das ausprobiert. Ich fand das aber jetzt, ja, das war so mittel.
Ach so, ich dachte du hättest gleich fette Installationen gemacht.
Nee, ich hab da so ein bisschen rumprobiert. Status Board ist so eine Art Status-Anzeige für allerlei Dinge. Man kann konfigurieren Uhren und so ein Wetter-Widget gibt's, das man da reintun kann, wo die Wetterdaten aber glaube ich eher so mittel sind, weil sie mal wieder aus Amiland kommen. Dann kann man irgendwie so ein Kalenderzeug machen.
Kannst ja ein eigenes bauen.
Ja, Moment, dazu kommen wir noch. Also es ist halt das eingebaute Wetter-Ding. Du kannst da so Kalender-Ding ins Anzeigen lassen, wo er dir so die nächsten Termine anzeigt. Das E-Mail-Teil ist ganz interessant. Da kannst du dir also nicht nur die neuesten E-Mails-Header anzeigen lassen, sondern halt auch so Sachen wie, wie viele E-Mails habe ich in welcher Inbox? Oder wie ist der Verlauf an angekommenen E-Mails pro Tag? Dann gibt es Twitter-Dingens, wo du halt entweder nach irgendwas suchen kannst oder Hashtags oder so. Ich habe da jetzt einfach mal meine Followerzahl hingemacht.
Also so für einen Support ganz praktisch.
Dann gibt es so ein RSS-Dingens, wo du halt RSS-Feeds liest. Ja, wie gesagt, das ist halt eigentlich so zum Hinhängen und Angucken. Die letzten drei sind eigentlich die Spannenden. Und zwar gibt es einmal Graph nennt sich das. Da kannst du deinen eigenen Graph erzeugen, indem du irgendwo entweder eine CSV-Datei hinlegst, die regelmäßig refreshed und die Sachen als Balken oder als Linien anzeigt. Oder indem du, die haben da so ein komisches JSON-Format definiert, indem du dann deine Balken oder Kurven machen kannst. Das JSON fand ich ein bisschen bekloppt, wie sie das spezifiziert haben. Aber du kannst halt da immerhin so Farben festlegen und Einheiten und Max-Min-Werte und so ein Zeug.
Oder pollt der dann auch weg, oder wie?
Der pollt alles, im Prinzip.
Was nicht bei drei auf der Bäume ist.
Das wird ja pollt, genau. Dann gibt es so ein Table-Widget, wo du auch entweder ein CSV hinlegst, oder aber du kannst auch eine HTML-Tabelle machen, und zwar nicht ein komplettes HTML-Dokument, sondern nur, was in HTML zwischen den Tags-Table auf und Table zu wäre. Und da kannst du dann halt auch so Bilder mit reintun, wo du dann irgendwelche Statuslampen hast oder Avatar-Bildchen oder so. Und es gibt noch den Do-It-Yourself-Widget, wo du halt ein komplettes HTML hinlegst.
Hast du dir mal das SDK angeguckt dazu?
Es gibt kein SDK.
Ich dachte, es gäbe dazu. Ich hatte irgendwie gehört, dass es da ein SDK gibt, wo ja die Leute jetzt ihre Widgets veröffentlichen. Also die Widgets bauen und...
Nein, es gibt nicht wirklich ein SDK. Zu den drei Do-It-Yourself-Dingern gibt es jeweils so einen PDF von vier Seiten, wo drin steht, was du machen musst. Und du kannst für das Do-It-Yourself-Ding quasi so einen Ressourcen-Pack runterladen, sodass das dann aussieht wie... Wie der Rest. Genau, aber im Großen und Ganzen. Also ein SDK würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen. Es gibt halt so eine Beispiel, wo du das... Also ich glaube, das Do-It-Yourself-Ding, und wenn man gut HTML kann usw., dann ist es ganz spannend. Ansonsten, ja, du kannst... Das ist eigentlich ganz interessant. Du kannst mit einem Inner-Purchase noch ein External-Display ansteuern. Und zwar entweder über den HDMI-Adapter oder über Airplay.
Ich dachte, Airplay hätten sie... Ach nee, Airplay aktiviert man dann über den Inner-Purchase auch.
Also du aktivierst über den Inner-Purchase, dass du ein externes Display verwenden kannst.
Jaja, was sie aber wohl anders machen als über Airplay. Da hat ja der Morgan von Panic auf Twitter auch irgendwie gefragt, und hatten ja diesen Blog-Eintrag geschrieben, warum denn über den Lightning-HDMI-Adapter das Bild so scheiße ist. Und das wird wohl genau deswegen gewesen sein, weil sie da irgendwie ihren eigenen Kram machen und der damit nicht mehr scheiße aussieht. Was sie da machen. Zumindest hatte ich das jetzt auch letztens im Oh Gott, Excedential Tech Podcast oder so, hatten sie das erzählt, glaube ich. Dass eben das Interessante ist, dass der Kram damit nicht mehr scheiße aussieht. Was sie da machen. Mit dem, was sie da selber gebaut haben, um ans externe Display anzuschließen.
Also, wie gesagt, du kannst entweder über den HDMI-Adapter gehen. Also bei alten Geräten mit dem normalen Dot-Connector, wo ein richtiges HDMI-Signal rauskommt. Oder bei den neuen Geräten über den Lightning-Port, dann hast du dieses komische Problem, dass das matschig aussieht.
Haben sie wohl eben nicht mehr mit dem. Angeblich haben sie es damit nicht mehr.
Oder du kannst es halt über eine Apple-TV machen. Das funktioniert einfach. Und dann kannst du die Dinge halt da so zusammenziehen, vergrößern, verkleinern und hast halt dann so ein Display mit mehreren Teilen drauf. Was? Na ja, sagen wir mal so. Es gibt ja Leute, die haben so alte iPads ohne Ende rumliegen. Da kannst du dir halt irgendwie ein großes Display an die Wand hängen.
Die alten iPads werden halt immer günstiger, so auf eBay, wobei so richtig...
Er ist eigentlich zu klein dafür, oder?
Läuft das auch unter dem alten?
Ah ja, ist fünf, ja. Und auf dem müsste es dem alten iPad laufen.
Ja, weil die alten iPads sind gerade an die Wand dängeln halt echt cool.
Ist halt echt klein für ein richtiges Status-Board.
Also für das iPad selber geht es gerade noch so. Aber richtig sexy ist es natürlich, wenn du so einen großen...
Läuft das eigentlich auch auf ein iPhone?
Nein, das ist iPad only.
Ja, ich meine aber, wenn du es auf einen großen Bildschirm kriegen willst, dann ist es halt ein altes iPad.
Dann machst du einen HDMI-Anschluss. Obwohl das erste iPad hat, kannst du nur über Apple TV machen. Weil das hat ja keinen Video-Out, glaube ich.
Ja, aber ehrlich gesagt, wenn du einen großen Fernseher dranhängen willst und dafür dir einen iPad kaufst und den großen Fernseher nur für dein Status-Board, dann sind jetzt die 99 Euro für den Apple TV auch nicht mehr so das große Hindernis.
Ne, das höre ich auch nicht behauptet. Also, das kannst du machen. Das ist halt alles irgendwie, wenn du diese ganzen Kosten aufrechnest, dann sind auch die 9 Euro für die App jetzt nicht mehr so viel.
Und die 9 Euro für den In-App-Purchase.
Für das externe Display. Ja, ich habe es mir trotzdem mal angucken wollen.
Passt schon. Ich finde das generell gut. Ich bin auch ein großer Freund davon, das iPad als Anzeigegerät zu benutzen. Das ist so meine Primäraufgabe hier.
Also ich habe dir natürlich direkt gleich mal so ein paar Bug-Reports geschrieben. Das eine ist, dass in der E-Mail-Ansicht steht hier Donnerstag, Freitag, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag, Yesterday, Today. Das haben sie nicht übersetzt gekriegt. Da habe ich ihnen erstmal aus der Apple-Doku das Beispiel rauskopiert, was da prominent drin ist, wie man das übersetzt. Mithilfe von eingebauten Bordmitteln.
Yesterday kann ich nicht, da habe ich mal Sport.
Und dann habe ich natürlich mal nachgefragt, wie es mit up.net ist. Hätte ich auch gerne meine Follower. Ja, aber da sind sie dran, haben sie es schon gesagt. Na ja, mal gucken. Also es scheint so zu sein, als...
Ja, also die Firma weiß nicht, morgen ist es auf up.net. Da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass da noch ein bisschen was passiert. Also weil es momentan wirkt es fast ein bisschen unfertig. Also ne 1.1, wo sie noch mal ein bisschen ordentlich was tun, stünde ihnen ganz gut zu Gesicht, finde ich. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das ganz schön. Und vor allen Dingen, wenn man relativ leicht an irgendwelche Datenquellen rankommt, wie Umsätze, die man gerade macht, oder Spieler, die online sind, oder irgendwie sowas, dann kann man da wirklich schöne Kurven mitmachen und so. Es ist natürlich kein Statistiktool in dem Sinne, dass du jetzt da Punktwolken darstellen kannst, oder irgendwelche, weiß ich nicht, Standardabweichungen oder irgendwie sowas. Sondern es sind wirklich nur einfach Kurven oder Balken. Aber dafür ist es schon ganz gut.
Sollen wir den Nagios drauf ausgeben, dafür, dass es halbwegs aussieht? Auf dem großen Fernseher? Oder was auch immer?
Abs irgendjemand?
Ich könnte jetzt noch was über Omni Outliner 4 Beta und Omni Focus 2 Beta erzählen, aber da ist jetzt auch noch nicht... Also Omni Outliner 4 zeichnet sich eigentlich gegenüber Omni Outliner 3 aktuell nur dadurch aus, dass es eine Unified Sidebar hat. Und nicht mehr diesen Drawer, sondern halt so eine richtige Sidebar. Wie man sie aus modernen Apps kennt, wodurch es nicht mehr ganz so altbacken aussieht.
Da sind sie jetzt gefühlte 10 Jahre später zu beten.
Und man Text zoomen kann und nicht vergrößern muss.
Die Zukunft von gestern schon heute.
Ich könnte einfach so App für Plus machen und alles ist größer.
Nee, App für Plus geht leider noch nicht. Es gibt bis jetzt nur ein Pulldown-Menü, wo man dann... Aber ja, sie haben davon...
Nicht mal App viel größer, weil der auch schon die Pest ist, aber nicht mal dit.
Nee, nee, nee. Ich hab sie angeschrieben. Das war so mit der ersten Feature-Request. Warum geht's Pinch to Zoom nicht und warum gibt's keinen ordentlichen Shortcut? Na ja, das ist halt... Es sieht angenehmer aus. Mehr hat sich aber gefühlt noch nicht verändert. OmniFocus 2, Alpha ist halt... Ich benutze OmniFocus sehr, sehr viel. Es ist eine Alpha. Ich muss OmniFocus 1 noch aktuell nebenherlaufen lassen, weil so Funktionen wie ein Task duplizieren einfach noch nicht geht.
Solltest du dich nicht eigentlich auf ganz andere Sachen fokussieren mit dieser Focus-App heißen? Ich meine, als dich auf die Software selbst zu fokussieren, was damit geht und was damit nicht geht.
Naja, wenn ich eine Alpha-App in diesem Public-Beta-Test dann gucke ich auch, was geht und was nicht geht, damit ich irgendwie schreiben kann, was mein Problem ist. Weil wenn ich meinen Task, den ich duplizieren will, nicht duplizieren kann, muss ich den ja schreiben, geht nicht, weil das heißt, ich muss den Task komplett neu anlegen. Und das Review gibt es jetzt irgendwie in der Alpha, wo jetzt diese neue Review-Funktion drin ist, die wohl sehr nah an die iPad-Versionen dran ist. Sieht ganz nett aus, scheint auch besser zu werden als die alte Review-Funktion. Also wer nicht weiß, was ein Review ist in Getting Things Done, dann gibt es so dieses Prinzip, dass man halt irgendwie einmal am Tag oder einmal in der Woche oder so sich mal so über seine Projekte drüber guckt, was man denn da eigentlich noch so machen muss oder ob da noch was Neues rein muss und ob das alles up to date ist, sodass man den Überblick halt behält und da unterstützt ein OmniFocus so als einzige Anwendung so richtig. Und in OmniFocus 2 haben sie da so eine neue View drauf, die das Ganze noch mal erleichtert, verbessert. Sie haben jetzt die Forecast-Funktion ordentlich drin von den iOS-Apps. Das ist wirklich schick, dass man so einen Zeitstrahl hat und da seinen Kalender und seine Tagstransit und was da so in der Zukunft auf einen zukommt. Also OmniFocus 2 sieht nach einem weitaus besseren Update aus als OmniOutliner 4. Mal gucken, ob sie in OmniOutliner 4 auch Plain Text wieder reinmachen. Sie haben den Feature-Request wohl schon öfter bekommen, dass in OmniOutliner 4 doch wieder Plain Text 1.
Ich glaube, wir sollten nur Version 2 nochmal releasen.
Ich hätte nie auf die 3 updaten sollen.
Gibt es das denn noch als Intel-Binary?
Ne, das müsste zu alt sein, oder? OmniOutliner 3 ist schon 8 Jahre alt. Ja, das hatten sie jetzt letzten gepostet. Das hieß 2005 und damit müsstest du von...
Einfach compilen und gut ist es.
Und dann hatte Roddy doch irgendwie Alfred 2 vorhin nochmal kurz angesprochen.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Alfred 2. Alfred 2 ist ja so ein toller Launcher. Und da gibt es jetzt ganz viele neue Workflows. Also in Alfred 2 gibt es so eine tolle neue Funktion, mit der man sich so Dinge zusammenklicken kann, so Workflows zusammenklicken kann, Prozesse. Und die sharen die Nutzer zurzeit fleißig in den Alfred-Forens. Oder es gibt auch einen Petterraum bei up.net, wo Alfred 2 Nutzer Workflows teilen. Und da gibt es ein paar ganz schicke, also sowas wie zum Beispiel eine Wettervorhersage. Da startet man Alfred, drückt Vorkast ein und kriegt dann irgendwie aktuelles Wetter. Oder es gibt eine Pirate Bay-Suche, womit man dann Pirate Bay eingibt, Leerzeichen, den Filmnamen und dann kriegt man direkt so die Ergebnisse aus der Pirate Bay und kann dann Enter drücken und Transmission geht auf und startet den Torrent.
Du kannst halt sozusagen, statt jetzt einfach nur zu sagen Keyword Action, kannst du diese Action halt nochmal so auffächern, also sag mal, halt Filmrecherche, Workflow Filmrecherche, Tipps, Research, Film, was auch immer, den Filmnamen ein und dann geht halt im Safari ein Tab mit IMDB auf, der Trailer auf YouTube und nochmal irgendwie der Download auf Pirate Bay gleichzeitig oder sowas.
Genau, und kannst dann noch Shell-Skripte mit zwischen reinwerfen oder ich hab zum Beispiel einen Workflow, womit ich halt, wenn ich irgendwie was für die Uni suche, dann macht er halt eine Suche gleich über mehrere Bibliotheken auf, also der macht ein Safari auf und macht dann gleich über mehrere Bibliotheken die Suche, über Google Scholar. Ja genau, das kann man dann quasi auf ein Keyword legen oder auf einen Tastaturshortcut und der kann einem halt auch Suchergebnisse direkt in diesem, du bist ja Launchbar-Nutzer, quasi der zeigt dir die Suchergebnisse unten drunter an und der kann dir quasi dann, nehmen wir jetzt mal dieses Pirate Bay Beispiel, dann zeigt er dir halt die Suchergebnisse, du gibst Pirate ein, Leerzeichen, gibst deine Linux-Distribution ein und dann zeigt er dir die Suchergebnisse da drunter. Also direkt in der Auswahl und kannst halt direkt durchgehen, wie in Launchbar halt, drückst Enter und der Torrent startet.
Das ist kostenlos.
Nein, nein, das Powerpack, was du brauchst für die Workflows, das kostet. Also der Launcher kostet nichts, so die Verbesserung von Spotlight, das Lernen des Spotlight kostet nichts, aber an dem Moment, wo du so die Special Features wie Clipboard History oder Workflows oder so haben willst, brauchst du das Powerpacken, das kostet. Selbst die Lifetime-Lizenz ist, glaube ich, nicht so teuer gewesen. Also ich habe auch für die iFrid 2 Beta auf die Lifetime-Lizenz geupgradet und das ging dann auch.
Ich auch irgendwie, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, wie viel es war.
Oder ich habe zum Beispiel, es gibt jetzt einen Workflow, Unicode-Zeichen, da gibt man UTF ein, Leerzeichen, dann kann man anfangen so was wie Left Arrow, also anfangen zu tippen und er zeigt dann, in den Suchergebnissen zeigt er ein Unicode-Symbole ein. Und als Default zeigt er die typischen an, Command-Symbol, Apple-Symbol, Option-Symbol, also Dinge, die man gegebenenfalls häufiger braucht und kann sich dann ganz einfach so Unicode-Symbole herauskopieren.
Die Lifetime-Lizenz kostet 30 Pfund, das geht ja noch.
Ich kann mal noch in den Chat, oder Top-Prozesse kann man sich auch anzeigen lassen über einen Workflow.
Ich kann mal in den Chat noch posten, so einen Artikel, den ich dazu gefunden hatte, der heißt Alfred 2, der ultimative Workflow-Artikel. Den ich mir aber bisher noch nicht so genau angeguckt habe, außer dass da jede Menge Zeug drin ist.
Und es gibt einen Alfred-Workflow mit pH, damit kann man dann zu app.net posten, bald auch mit Link-Entitäten über Markdowns und Taks.
Getunnelt durch PML, durch den ODBC-Driver.
Ich muss mal hier aufhören, kleine Podcaster.
Ja, mein Paktik läuft in drei Minuten ab draußen.
Na dann, wir machen jetzt hier mal den Sack zu, glaube ich. So lange halte ich es dann auch noch aus. In diesem Sinne würde ich sagen, die 108 ist eingetütet und wird hiermit offiziell verabschiedet, zugeklebt und verschickt. Danke, Niels, für den Gastauftritt.
Ich danke, dass ich hier sein durfte.
Und für die Mate.
Das auch.
Und die Pizza. Tschüss, bis bald bei Mo, bei Max.
Wiederschauen.